thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
oh yeah
competitive chess the weight of a win
draw or loss is all on one's shoulders
it's easy to feel alone
those lonely Days Are Over oh my God
the protest league is back
once again in chess teammates matter oh
man oh my God what was that what do you
even do this is resign time welcome back
PCL
a unique collection of teams each with
their own personality of different
colors shapes and sizes
there are gnomes and nights spraws and
Bishops
and whatever the heck this is
the PCL is the only place where the best
players in the world risk their fate
alongside content creators and players
from different levels ages and
perspectives he's coming in and if white
goes C7 and that's it
entering its fifth season
teams will reboot the PCL Legacy with a
new format and new schedule
only one team can be crowned the next
PCL champion
oh my goodness what a save
my friends it's the 2023 Pro chess
League which team can Rise Above the
Rest they won't be able to do it alone
look at her on the screen she is killing
it today
[Music]
happy International women's day what
better way to celebrate than enjoying
yourself a pro chess League double
header I'm Grandmaster Robert Hess
alongside me is my good friend v-day
Master James Kane III James we have two
exciting matchups today how excited are
you I'm very excited of course well I'm
here with Mr chess I mean Hess himself
absolutely feeling good of course
protest league today uh double header
happy International Women's Day to all
the women around the world of course and
uh it's a great day man I'm feeling good
Robert how about you bro
feeling great because we have some great
clashes in store for everybody and well
you know where's the pro Chesley where
are we what are the standings I think we
should remind everybody because it's
been quite a long time almost a week
since we last Saw action and two teams
have secured their chances in the
playoffs the Indian yogis and the Gotham
Knights but James we're gonna see some
teams coming up the Shanghai Tigers the
Croatia Bulldogs they're fighting to
make their way into the playoffs as well
all I need is one one win if I'm two and
I'm like this is it like wow we need our
best lineup number one number two is all
we need is more than two one more point
and we are actually in the playoffs
right so we're feeling good here but it
also takes hey you could lose two in a
row and if you're the one that's it
you're out so it really is about you
know today can uh and punch home some
playoff tickets so it's exciting for you
guys
yeah these teams want to clinch their
spawn the plebs they don't want to lose
two in a row as you said because on the
other side of the standings the teams
that have struggled thus far they are
going to be one loss away from
elimination two teams the Berlin bears
and Charlotte cobras already out of the
2023 Pro chess League season we'll see
which of these teams can stay in the
hunt but today's matchups we have two
exciting ones in store for everybody we
are going to start with the Croatia
Bulldogs versus the Shanghai Tigers then
James we get the blitz there's the
Brazil capybara so my first question for
you is which of these four logos do you
like the best you know what for old
logos okay that's a good one I'm gonna
have to go with blitz I would actually
get that tatted I'm not even gonna lie
that fire with the fire and the King you
know what that's like that's probably
another logo that's amazing right and I
like what Danny says about copy bears
like what is that thing when he says
like in the uh little pre-show thing
like what it and whatever the heck this
thing is that is funny because in fact
it is I don't know the capability is
either but they need to figure out
because if they lose they go home and
that's the match I'm looking forward to
because the Blitz and the kind of bears
is the elimination match those are my
absolute favorites because a limb is
like when or you go home that's it it's
a wrap as you said they're gonna have to
find out who they are today because they
may be eliminated but we are going to
start with the Croatia Bulldogs and the
Shanghai tigers and we just want to take
care of some Logistics here because
there was a less sick and change and
it's important to note the roster rules
for the pro chess League uh that you
have to have have the rosters finalized
as of February 27th and substitutions
incurred 25 point average rating cap
penalty that's going to come into play
this week as The rosters must include
two women and a junior player uh but
James in this week in particular that's
going to play a role because the Croatia
Bulldogs the player that we see on the
screen infernos Irene sukander we know
how strong she is James but she's a last
second edition she's a substitution
that's going to cost the pressure
Bulldogs in terms of the average rating
oh yeah that's that could be tough we
have to mix around the average rating I
mean these teams are already strong now
of course we did see at the lower halves
a lot of times in the protest League
honestly it's about those third and
fourth boards I think I've read today's
fourth board today so I think on the
fourth board she can just perform if she
goes out and perform like Alice Lee did
out here swinging they're like yo Alice
Lee you know that's a grown woman in a
young lady's body like she's playing
real real big boy chess or big girl
chest okay Alice Lee was playing
excellent chess here and that's a fourth
board so it's all about those third and
four boards today Irene yes it is a it's
a substitution they take a rating cap
difference they're a hit to the rating
but if she's able to push through today
and you and do what she's supposed to do
you know we see this in third or four
boards a lot and these protest league
matches they'll just be fine or nobody a
complete disaster we'll see
yeah this crucial Bulldog seemed pretty
even across their Boards of course
they're led by Superstar super Grand
Master bogdon Daniel dayaj but the rest
of the lineup is pretty even in terms of
the ratings and well the team that
they're facing today the Shanghai Tigers
James we know that Tigers they're scary
they're dangerous and Juan Jun the
Women's World Champion she's been great
for them all season
yeah she's actually shooting me what is
that I forgot after stats was like one
of the very few basically in the world
of women to be 2600 in fact if you think
about that if you in the world who 2600
like not just women that's the extremely
strong so I mean her being underrated
definitely is uh is their 25 50 she's I
think or two for them Jew one Jew is
gonna be it's gonna play some great
chats I mean obviously being the Women's
World Champion current right now too as
well I'd be happy if I had Parents the
current women's world champion the best
of the best with us right now you know I
don't think they have a lot of a lot to
worry about Shanghai Tigers they are the
favorite I think today but they are
gonna have to prove it today yeah they
may have to rely on way he as their top
board they've been using the same lineup
each and every week so let's see if
things have changed coming into week
four because the Shanghai Tigers they've
been a model of consistency and of
course not they have not changed the
lineup what's working for them why not
Trot it out again they did lose the
Gotham Knights a week ago but James as
we look at the four boards for each team
you can see big rating lead or Shanghai
on board one and also a big rating uh
gap on board four in favor of the
Shanghai Tigers whereas the Croatia
Bulldogs have an edge on board two at
least in terms of rating yeah I was
actually uh definitely thinking about
that how uh how they would how that
would level out if it's top heavy here I
think yomez and Dora Bailey are um you
know maybe under some pressure there and
in the lower house is the other way
around so I mean it's even I think this
is even whoever just the better team
usually that's what it's about who has a
better lineup who is better right now in
that match so whoever is good and better
right now is is going to obviously take
the match really round one is a is a
like kind of kind of like where
everything comes out or like you get to
see who who runs away with stuff
sometimes you see three and a half half
sometimes you see for oh and you also
see The Comebacks but again it's about
you know who's hot right now as we saw
Alice Alice Lee beat um blue bomb in the
first round there right which definitely
boosted them around made the team go
very nice uh
clinch that win so I think it'd be the
same thing here whoever can pull away
right now in this first match uh
definitely has some big big chances the
rest of them
absolutely so you're talking about
pulling away in the first round let's
look at our first round board pairings
because uh the top two boards for the
Croatia Bulldogs and the top two boards
for the Shanghai Tigers they get the
black pieces so James we know they
outrate their opponents but it is a nice
Edge to have the white pieces so who do
you think has a better shot which teams
lower boards the Shanghai tigers with
Lou yaping and shuyi or the Croatia
Bulldogs with Auntie Sarge and Irene
sukhander what we've been talking about
you know probably uh I think the lower
boards Fair uh anti-saric and Irene them
having white down there but then you got
Jew with juice you forgot about that I
had to like you're like oh yeah I got
white and then you're like oh wait hold
on I Gotta Wait against the shoot okay
wait let me let me rethink that it might
be at the top I'm actually gonna go with
the top half there because of course I'm
just being higher rated in the white
pieces 2700 having the white pieces okay
we got a favor that way I'm going with
the titles okay so you think the tigers
are gonna get out to an early lead and
oh they would love that because Wei he's
been a force in the protest League this
season and nine wins two losses and zero
draws that guy refuses to split the
point with anybody he doesn't care if he
goes down swinging away he says I am
going to fight and he will have a fight
in his hands because I read sukhander
she may be stepping in for the Bulldogs
uh but she is a wrecking ball I mean the
way she plays chess games she's always
playing attacking aggressive uh chess I
played her over the board we had one of
the most Wild games ever and so we know
what she's capable of
wow yeah very strong absolutely I
actually looked up her her card in the
Wikipedia and some other areas just to
check and see and I'll bet she's super
strong she had one tournament she did
five out of nine in a GM tournament four
wins two wins and four wins some draws
and something like that but basically a
very strong tournament to say the least
I think she's actually really underrated
okay okay well the games are about to
begin uh we see the players on our
screen coming up it is going to be
Mustafa umaz and luya ping Louie ping
getting the white pieces in this one uh
we've seen how solid he has been that is
Louisa pink throughout the season
he is an experienced veteran
Grandmasters of James uh for the
Shanghai Tigers they want to get off to
that hot start that you've been
clamoring for absolutely I like I I'm
actually a big fan of mustafa's play I
know he's a Turkish three-time champ so
definitely a fan of his play aggressive
Sometimes some Kings Indian Etc very
very solid player Lou I'm not uh not too
familiar with Robert what do you have on
Luke yeah he's super solid but if you
provoke him he will strike and he has
had some weeks where he has a plus score
which is huge on board four and not to
mention he's about a 2500 rated player
so you some teams they have board Fours
Who are about 2200 but not the Shanghai
Tigers they trust him and he's playing
in Italian which is a trusty weapon of
uh many of the best players of all time
and I'm just curious is he going to
strike with B4 is that you know going to
be his plan on the queen side the answer
has been answered no A5 takes that away
not anymore right B4 is not happening
anymore of course uh Geary has some new
files on this that he does actually
recommend Yuri that is uh nishikiri uh
has a new test so of course not new but
it is in his chest of course he
recommends obviously the newer line of
b4a4 grab the space he's into the space
type of thing and developing pieces grab
Space Place principles solid shots as
his whole uh philosophy in this course
so B4 and A4 absolutely is going to grab
some space it looks like black was able
to do that so now white has to kind of
transfer this into some type of maybe
Roy Lopez as you see Bishop going to B3
I'm going to reroute maybe to C2 Knight
goes from B1 all the way over to G3 via
D2 so Knight B2 Knight F1 Knight G3 you
play H3 sometimes G4 then Knight G3 you
eventually play D4 it's a slow game it's
what they call Italian game anyway it's
a quiet game or slow positional bring it
yeah I mean H3 and G4 that sometimes
makes a little bit more Dynamic we see a
maneuvering Bishop to B3 Bishop j7 Pawn
H3 get away from this G4 Square because
sometimes black likes to move the king
to the side and play for F5 break open
this Rook uh on his castle Square uh but
this James this is really just
maneuvering quiet chess absolutely
maneuvering quiet there we go Knight D2
is just a quick moves right no time
really wasted here we're just gonna move
our pieces where we're supposed to in
fact actually I know an Italian game um
young Gustaf and recommends this uh easy
easy play for for black here is he
always likes to do the A6 instead of A5
A5 stops B4 but it was sort of the same
way A6 or A5 Bishop goes to A7 you go
rookie a H6 Bishop E6 that's like every
single time in every single line of the
Italian it was very easy to understand
that plans and ideas there it is there
goes the Rook to E8 Bishop goes to E6
and then you play Queen D7 maybe rook d8
and you try to play for D5 at some point
it's very very easy to play from black
here black standpoint but they're
awesome some ideas and some Venom in
there there's Bishop B6 right it's the
same I mean nothing to see here Robert
we're about to go to sleep my guy take a
nap and we'll wake up and then it'll
still be maneuvering I'm just gonna you
know take a lesson from you because you
were calling out all the last few moves
and you said you uh you know watched
some videos and courses on it but this
is perfect play from both sides and
Chess at the highest level that's often
what it's like just and no pieces have
been traded yet but the Bishops are
staring at each other if the bishop
takes on E3 thank you very much in comes
the Knight and will black be able to get
this move D5 in James that's a big
question that Mustafa Iman has to answer
absolutely he has to answer it right and
of course even the Knight E7 and G6 is
another thing going around I don't see
you hear sirens in the background there
so there's something going on somewhere
but it's not on this board it is not on
this board at all guys so there will be
something like 97 to Knight G6 also is
an idea uh as well yeah I mean it's the
same stuff you also play 97 96 c65 I
mean it's just not much here so he's
trying to figure out how he wants to do
this Mufasa that is I said Mufasa I
always call him that oh my goodness
and don't make him the villain you know
he uh you know I guess you know Mustafa
is the hero and Scar is the villain I
just you know got confused myself uh but
either way he is a fantastic chess
player uh plays for the Turkish national
team as a multi-time champion and a
great player in his own right but all
games have started so let's after the
first piece has been trading this one
let's hop to our other games because uh
well it looks like in the top right
maybe the biggest news of all is not a
single move as in played from shuyi
against vasif durability so James we
know those computer and Tech issues they
play a role in online chess oh yeah
absolutely of course and hopefully they
get that time back there I know chesscom
has been very good without getting time
back to the player especially if they're
there
um or maybe there's a transmission issue
Maybe something that we're not sure
there but definitely that time is
running and there is no move on the
board and there's almost like a four
minute time Advantage so gotta be very
very careful here my guy oh my goodness
you can't have anything you know go
wrong there without uh
about making a move I gotta make a move
right
yeah as you said that's not a move uh
James he is not moving but we'll see
when he gets back to it for now we'll
dive into the game between ante storage
and Juan Jun because those two uh have
been playing thus far on the bottom left
and as we see some pieces unlike in the
first game we can have been traded but
once again a very solid position where
we may see some more Pawn trades in the
center of both sides have fully
developed their minor pieces and now
maybe white is a little bit ahead
because the rook's already on a central
line but James not too much right
yeah I mean this is actually uh very
Dynamic it's like some type of nimso too
as well but this is a very Dynamic
um and I say that because of the two
Bishops the Bishops are out my Bishop on
D2 is not as good as the bishop on B4
but also this light Square Bishop is
super strong A3 now we might get the
bishop pair unless you do c takes D4
here it's it's Dynamic without many
weaknesses when a Jew and Jun has very
nice Pawn structure I think Pawn
structure is very nice 94 now she might
take the bishop again damage your
structure go to an in-game with the
better with the better Bishop I
definitely like this for black actually
believe it or not but white is uh engine
light splice slightly better it should
be one that's sick I like that
yeah why not because the board will
eventually open up uh once these pawns
are traded for example if black ever
takes on D4 I'll just show this very
quickly after Pawn takes D4 I don't have
to just take back the bishop can also
slide up to B4 with a hit of Queen and
rook and if you block with a knight I
know it's a you know not the best idea
then I could take on D4 with this pawn
and I'm exploiting this pin black
actually does not lose a piece here
thanks to move A5 but still you're
getting yourself into some trouble here
and you're barely escaping with the even
material so instead I don't think we
will see Pawn takes D4 it's too
accommodating for this bishop on E1 you
want to take control of all the dark
squares and right now black is doing
just that
I'm a big fan of um of improving the
position I know um Jacob Agar has the
positional book about you know what's
weakness in them in a position what's
the worst place piece what's my
opponent's idea so a lot of things a lot
of times that piece the worst place
peace in this position I think right now
is probably the night on D7 so maybe
moving it to F6 and then you have the
Superfluous Knights Knight of six and E4
but you can also play Knight D5 but the
Knight on D5 maybe even Rook a to d a um
these are are good ways to improve my
position um so I'm thinking of that
maybe even a rook to C8 as well but
we're looking to improve and she's
trying to do that right now what do you
think Robert Knight F6 rookie or p8 also
maybe you can play avoiding move like H6
kind of boring but definitely impossible
move
yeah no black has many options here
that's why Jew and June is spending time
uh because you make one in accuracy
suddenly white is better with the pair
of Bishops I liked your idea of Simply
bringing in the Knight to F6 but maybe
that allows the White Knight up to E5
the Knight on D7 is covering that square
so difficult decisions for June it's not
a tactical Affair this isn't some kind
of a very dangerous position for her
from you know she'll get checkmated
perspective but I do think that she has
a tough choice because she's handed upon
the bishop pair all of her pieces look
like they're on good squares and yet
there's no actual plan and chess is a
game of plan so why don't we zoom out of
this one well Jew and June is on the
clock we'll see what she's able to
uncork here uh but I'm looking at the
top left we see a queen trade being
offered still quite level that's good
news for the Shanghai Tigers because
they're gonna Trust luyaping on board
four highly rated board four in this
league in the top right James finally we
saw some moves played shuyi is there
playing in end game
durability in the bottom right with a
lows position from Irene sukhander and
Wei so of the four boards which one do
you think we should go to yeah all of
them boring all of them just like moving
around there's no tactics anywhere
there's just but it tells you this is
real solid real solid I'll actually like
this to see it's literally on every
board and everybody's like there's no
mistakes it shows how evenly kind of
this is right now let's actually go to
the top right let's go over here to that
imbalance there with the King on E2 this
is Bailey
let's see this see what we got wow look
at the setup there what time is it over
there
all right
it's late in China uh but you know sure
you always in the lineup for the Tigers
and well look at this Pawn structure I
don't know what received durability is
thinking about is there any move besides
you actually
it's kind of funny right just save your
time here because there is
you know what
that's why he hasn't moved wow
that's a good car I'm like man he did he
like really in the zoom that's the thing
he's gone so unfortunately the Croatia
Bulldogs they're four two has lost
connection and we'll see if he's able to
bounce back but I mean it's obvious
uh is she Frozen
no no no no no no he's he's still there
he's just waiting for the move you know
he's like down on the clock what's going
on
so shui earlier
um was struggling with the tech at scene
now verif is gone and well we'll wait
for him to come back but G takes up six
is automatic normally you have to think
is there an in-between move the answer
is no just to show you how you blunder
Bishop takes night as this bishop to
bounce back to C3 white would end up a
piece ahead so that's why James and I
were confused G takes F6 was finally
played at long last and now we could
talk about a compromised Pawn structure
on the king side but a pair of Bishops
so James would you prefer to have the
bishop pair or the better Pawn structure
that's a great question in fact uh I I
uh to be honest I am a fan of the bishop
pair I do very well with the Bishops and
tactics that arise with them especially
in open positions like this one is
definitely becoming an open position and
I have some dynamicism with the open
files just have double pawns but I have
the bishop here so I'm actually going to
go with the bishop here and the idea of
having C5 C4 available even casting
Queen side use the Rook uh to back the
d-pawn and use the files that I have to
try to you know create something and if
you play G3 after Rook G8 I can use the
F Pawn to go F5 F4 make your pawns
double attack the F Pawn take it and
then attack the other rap on so I have a
clear plan here of just like trying to
attack you with the Bishops and the
pawns and pushing them forward
everything forward
okay very instructive from James there
instead of taking the Knight and
compromising White's pawns gonna Retreat
and keep the bishop here so uh receive
as he struggles to get back his
connection let's go away from this game
we will keep an eye out on it of course
and keep you updated uh but we still
have three other games in full swing I
see the evil bar swing down in the
bottom right way that position has had
zero captures no trades there way with a
slight Advantage it would appear and
then the top left things have changed
between ALU yaping and Mustafa ilma so
maybe James we should go there I know
end games aren't what you love to see
all the time you're more of a you know
aggressive player trying to go for
tactics
I kind of like the look of this position
for white at first glance with the eval
Bar says hey Robert that's why you wear
glasses you need to check your vision
right yeah it's kind of crazy here I
mean it does it does like it goes like
evenish even as yeah I actually like
white I do like the a file practical
chances okay we have a double b we can
also double back around with 93 Knight
to D5 or F5 in many cases here
um but yeah that makes sense the
structure's so nice for black I can
understand it being very equal and A4 is
easy to defend and not easy to put more
pressure on you can double the Rooks but
when the Knight goes to B6 how do you
actually hit this Pawn besides maybe B3
B3 but then B6 is also defending A8
which The Rook is defending a so I can
take on B3 we trade on A8 and it'll be
completely equal it's all about battle
the end game here and probably just uh
play this boy out a caboblenka style
third world champion just play that boy
out play it out very nice and slow push
the P like he would play every in-game
out if you look at his old games every
single one King Pawn no matter what it
was right so it looks like one of those
in fact since you will get from a temple
board
yeah whoa you said B3 and he says B44
that surprised me you of course cannot
take on passant because your Rook on Aid
is loose so what Lu ya ping is saying is
that this Pawn A4 will be a long term
weakness yes this Knight can go to B6
but maybe then the White Knight can
slide into A5 and then the C Pawn will
Rumble up the board to the C5 Square I
mean this is a very enterprising plan
James I was not expecting it if you gave
me five move candidates this would not
have been one of them uh but he wants to
stick that Knight in A5 yeah that's
pretty nasty and he does it immediately
hits B7 then the other one can swing
around you can actually have a clear
plan of either something like Rook A3
Knight D2 Knight of the other night to
C4 and then play Knight to B2 and
actually really just go grab the pawn
eventually even double the Rooks first
and then after Knight A4 takes takes
there is no D6 there because your Rook
will be hanging due to the Rook on A8 so
you need to double the Rooks first in
your Rook then take the pawn on A4 it's
a lot you it's very slow it's a slow
plan but I mean shoot this is Italian
game number one you can also King F1 all
the way over to D3 Rook A3 Knight D2
Knight C4 double the Rooks Knight B2 and
then finally
your brilliant plan very nice he's
trying to stop it now with her face up
yeah it's funny because I think a lot of
people would have played Rook B8 to
defend the pawn this way Rook A7 not the
most natural move but it allows this
Rook to come to Aid just to preemptively
defend this Pawn A4 that James has been
highlighting can become a weakness so I
like the lead on the clock for Louisa
ping I think the position is actually
quite complicated not a single Pawn has
been traded and for white I mean D5 is
somewhat tempting just to close down the
center and try to play C4 Rook C1 C5 if
that pawn gets the C5 safely black is is
in big trouble but the problem is this
Knight it's stuck over here now you
can't get away with C4 C5 and oh King's
Indian style F5 move James they say that
end games are bored they're drawn no
this one's getting uh very exciting it's
heating up absolutely as they say all
working games are drawn but they like oh
yeah all working games are drawing well
you got to do it like oh it's not just
dropped because it says that you'll have
to do it wow he didn't take it back
no he goes ahead and defends his Pawn on
D5 E4 can be captured next with a couple
pieces and uh this might be a standstill
the Knight on A5 cannot move there is no
safe Square for that night and that's a
problem because you really want to play
C5 but your B4 Pawn is overloaded you
cannot get away with it I think that we
have an even battle on our hands here
and it looks uh quite interesting I
think both sides will have chances it's
even in terms of
the objective evaluation but practically
speaking I mean there are chances for
both sides to go wrong or to create
ideas that their opponents can't
successfully meet
as we see here of course there's a
bird's eye view see we have see we have
any new developments we actually do we
got a lot of stuff going on here any any
email about jar car jumps way over there
yeah we haven't even looked at that game
so why don't we uh check out how Wei Yi
is doing against Irene's sukhander of
course Irene was the last minute
addition to the Croatia bulldogs as
their uh other players are playing in
the European individual Champion lean
Rovers then Paulina shuvalova is playing
I believe in Uzbekistan so Irene a tough
first matchup can you imagine that
making your debut your first point is
right way you being the first opponent
here yeah that's tough that's very but
she already knew especially in the
protest so you know every opponent is
going to be very difficult here so she
already knew that going in and she's
very very calm I think she's watching
her play before she's actually Charlotte
playing before just seeing she's very
calm but on the board very aggressive
here what was this opening
uh let's check it out to see where we
came from it was a sicilian I you know
just quickly let's scroll through the
moves uh we had a sicilian that was with
Bishop B5 and one of these slow
maneuvering games no pieces are traded
uh you could take on E5 at any moment
but when the Pod takes back the D file
is open that's a backwards pawn and
black would be happy so instead uh we
just saw maneuvering developing no
trades that was not allowed in this game
James until D5 and once black gets this
move D5 in the position explodes in
Wei's favor opening up this bishop
opening up this queen that was really
good news for his pieces yeah that's
pretty rough when you open up the
position like this yeah black could
definitely be better in many cases
especially with the uh open position
Bishop so good yeah every piece is oh
Knight F3 you see that move and take the
bishop here my guy
yeah that came unexpectedly because B65
I think automatic capture back but no
Knight F3 check and after Knight takes
Bishop takes F4 your Rook on C1 is loose
here The Rook moved and then when you
recapture so all of a sudden black has
the upper hand pushes this Pawn to D4
and it's going from bad to worse and
maybe losing for Irene zukonda as this
bishop is open the other diagonal is
open and the fifth rank is open for a
rook swinging or over onto the king side
huge initiative huge Initiative for
black I think here this reminds you of
uh
semi-slav Simi saw has many games like
this in certain positions even if you
see uh what was the a what was the game
a non no it was aronian a non a famous
game of the semi-slave you guys can
Google it there this reminder it gives
you Vibes like that the Bishops point
the Queen's over there the Queen's on B8
many times you see this in the semi-slop
but you also see this in other openings
too but very nice idea Queen Bishop line
everything's aimed at lights kingside
and it looks like it's the other way
around like the knight in the bishop or
for white or on the queen side don't
really look like they're coordinated
well enough for what is about to happen
on the king side
I'm not really sure what White's Next
plan is after Knight to B4 uh you're
bringing your knight up towards the
center that's great uh but what is
Black's plan G5 G4 that looks perhaps
overly ambitious
all right he says I have no fear my Pawn
is here and he's trying to get G4 in but
D4 now is loose so big questions have to
be answered by way Yi
you know the G4 anyway who cares G4
that's why we played it Robert G4 for
the score play it now right and after
Knight takes D4 we take on H3 if you
take on G4 there it is come on way yay
big way and have a nice day
so what James is saying is please take
me on G4 and after the pawn takes back
this Rook will land on H5 and this king
is in big trouble and if you take on D4
then G takes H3 The Rook still goes to
G5 uh oh this feels like it's an
absolute nightmare for Irene sukhander
and what he hasn't even recaptured yet
is he really thinking about taking with
the Knight on G4 I think h64 would be
automatic if I were playing yeah you're
right you're right I think he's a A6 G4
is the move right but again I think
remember he played that Knight F3 move
so I'm he's now oh he took him
definitely like he's uh making the moves
that you're not thinking he's gonna make
with that little small thought there so
where does the Knight go now if the
Knight before what are we doing Rick H5
I think so I'm just bringing that Rook
into the attack why not or you can even
stop on E5 in some positions but I think
ultimately The Rook is going to H5 and
this king is just wide open you can
never play G3 to block the dark Square
pieces because it opens up the light
squares and a Checkmate thread on H1 uh
White's piece is not fully in the game
you're up a pawn as Irene sukander so if
wayi does not make the most of his
attack you might have some chances and
by the way James I would be very careful
to watch out for this move Knight E6
like if White had a free turn and that
kind of move could go after the black
king causing some dilemmas so Wade does
not have all the time in the world
is correct because he doesn't have
enough time but we do need to figure out
our next few moves for black here what
is it he's thinking let me see Rick H5 I
don't have a mate like I don't have a
puzzle brush here's something Rook H5
and Bishop uh doesn't work I was gonna
play Bishop E3 but he's gonna take the
because my idea is Queen H2 Queen H1
mate but the queen is on E2 you're going
Rook H5 he's putting it there wow look
at the eval part
bro
yeah 96 maybe ways calculator you can
just take because when the queen takes
back the king can step up the G7 and
white just doesn't have quite enough
checks and with Bishop H2 check put that
Bishop on a yo-yo string and then get it
back to E5 there may be a checkmating
thread down here on H1 so James I don't
know how white survives this game Bishop
C6 played by Irene zukonda but the Evo
bar is all the way down and it must be
some kind of bishop move get out the way
and allow the queen to get to H2 the
question is where is this bishop oh this
is the hard part about Chess is there's
so many moves you can make where is the
bishop move Queen H2 Queen H1 is mate
yeah there's yeah yeah maybe a G3 by the
way we have a something happen
um on the door Bailey board that was a
draw you got one draw one result
okay so we have a result on uh the dirt
Bailey game you said it was a draw
indeed opposite colored Bishops and then
on board one it looks like Mustafa yamaz
somehow won the game
but that game at least by the look of it
seemed to have much life left so uh
we'll keep everybody updated uh this
game still looking very dangerous for
Irene sukander but James no knockout
blow immediately apparent I'm thinking
Bishop G3 here Bishop G3 and if Bishop
G3 uh he won Bishop B5 but the idea was
obviously a pawn takes you could do
queen G3 or maybe Rook H1 first and then
try to bring the the Knight or queen in
but uh Bishop G3
just too much so he's going for Rook H1
King moves I guess we just take the
Knight is this up a piece or queen E3
here
oh so you're saying let me run away and
she does it clean up to E3 that was it
looks like the best move for white
because if Rook H1 check the king just
runs away and then the white king uh
excuse me what queen May slap the G5 at
some point and go after the King on G8
so wow suddenly she has a chance 40
seconds for Wei uh this is dangerous
territory for the Shanghai Tigers only
tripping oh that's not a move bro that
is definitely not a move engine that
says it too what is it Robert is it just
Bishops
I I don't know in the evil bar is going
all the way up and now it's gone back
down a little bit but that is a bit
misleading this position is tricky maybe
there's only one way for white to get
the job done I am going to turn on the
specific moves and now that I have done
that okay but she played it I was about
to say rookie and she's done it she
brings The Rook up she's going after the
bishop and The Rook Irene sukhander a
last second addition to this roster and
James what a move
oh my goodness Irene oh we Irene is
about to hit him real hard here Chad
that's
is sick if you're for if you're bored
four is able to do these kind of things
you're always going to have a great shot
in the PCL no matter what team you are
your fourth board can do this and take
out the big dogs or ones and Etc they're
gonna have a great day oh my gosh and
here comes that Knight E6 idea that I
mentioned a long time ago the f-pawn is
now pinned 15 seconds for Wiggy he's
gotta find a move James what do you
think he's gonna do
I think you know he's he's Stone you
know like his face is just so like no
emotion right so don't go kill her here
but
I mean definitely there's a lot of
pressure on him play check he takes it
looks like he's not panicking at all
he's like super common in a position
where like the engine say you were lost
okay he's like yeah I'm good I'm all
right well he's not so good because this
bishop on C6 is frustrating you would
love to play rookie eight and that's why
the trade has just happened but instead
of Knight takes C6 which does fork the
rook and the queen maybe Knight E6 check
James that move is available
96 King G8 Queen takes F6 Pawn takes
you went for it oh we just take the Rook
we just take the Rook no but then
goodness what is it yeah take that road
because Queen takes F7 check will be
available afterwards she doesn't
way you can cook to your old man
wow what an upset he about to be upset
about this one
it's over 94 check right just and if can
you find this Knight C6 with a fork
winning the queen
boom she found it before he gotta hit
the button King G5 again I'm looking
away there the quick Look Away what did
I do how did I get in this position I
hate this game right those are already
oh look at Irene she can't believe it
she's so happy
like you know she just dunked on
somebody right like if you get dunked on
posterize and you come down and you Flex
real hard for the cameras and everybody
everybody going crazy and wild that's
what just happened right now Irene with
a big dub wow look at her that's amazing
wow she can't believe it and neither can
the Croatia Bulldogs because they just
bullied the Shanghai Tigers I think
going into this match most people
thought the Tigers would be the favorite
Squad but James it was a demolition from
top to bottom Mustafa IL Maz oh he went
on time against luya ping a draw on
board two and then wins by Auntie Sarge
we did not get to see that game in full
detail we apologize for that because the
last game was so exciting he beats ju
and June but I've read sukander the hero
or the Bulldogs taking down someone that
outrates her by over 300 points I am 100
shocked here I was 100 going with the
Shanghai Tire I mean they're just a very
strong team camaraderies they are all
from the same place right and also I
mean very very like the the state the
teams are stacked up 2700s on the team
too as well I mean everything points
that the Tigers just being a better team
but that doesn't matter right now at
today okay what's going on right now
what are the match lineups how are we
feeling as players today well you wasn't
that as stronger some slips there and
Irene was ready she was she smoked the
blood in the water as a shark would as a
shark could and did her thing or as a
bulldog would in this case and she
definitely you know was able to
contribute to the bullying in this first
round crazy that was nuts
couldn't summarize it any better myself
you heard it from James Canty I read
sukhander she takes down Super Jam Wei
the crochet Bulldogs lead three and a
half we like the players are gonna take
a short break but when we return it's
more from the protesting matchup between
the Croatia Bulldogs and the Shanghai
tigers
I have three puzzles here it's chess
yeah yes yes that's Jazz now we're gonna
go over suddenly you know there's like
some kind of some kind of triangle so
along the place okay no okay we're no
warning I'm not the fastest
so here is the first one okay
okay so F2 check yeah Eric A6 F2 png2
check Rook takes G3 Knight H3 King h100
is there like I made anything on second
yeah I think I have sold this already
like F2 is the answer
um actually I didn't have time to
calculate King takes F2 which looks uh I
mean at the very least I can just take
on D3 and then F1 and I'm much really
ahead and and that is also a gift to
Indian so it's just Checkmate but of
course the point is after look it
doesn't matter which hook takes an
episode then that is Queen G2 okay
okay
apparently blind all right your 10
seconds is up 100 yeah I just got it
while I was singing briefly yeah so it's
obviously off two and then uh Queen G2
90 strain Rook F1
wow okay so you're I mean there's also
Rook after HD2 the same thing yeah
yeah I mean Works off takes off to Queen
you two or two tonight usually King H1
and then virtue one or two ones babe but
yeah
okay let's play and win or what yes back
to play away
thanks
I don't know I didn't find the meat I
saw them
[Music]
I'll make a mover 9ito yeah
unfortunately the move is not 92.
yeah same thing I'm gonna go find me F2
Rook takes oh F2 I need that warm up can
we start again
yeah yeah I need the warm up
um
if it was my it was again I'll go 92
takes two three and I see but I think
it's it's just special than an hour I
don't think it's a mate
no I don't
all dead
um the correct move is actually F2
yeah
and then
oh wow like this
somehow it's unusual better but it's
really cool no exactly
that's so easy
chess kit is fun Jess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent-approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
it's it feels just like playing which
has a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kid
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
50 000 chest puzzles and a whole library
of entertaining videos that teach
strategies tactics openings and end
games specifically for kids
chess kit is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
oh
thank you
foreign
with James Canty III I'm greymaster
Robert Hess and we are going to dive
into the action that we just saw unfold
it was a historic upset in the Pro chess
league as Irene sukhander takes down
super Grandmaster Wei Yi and James in
this position it looked like way gee was
dominating with Rook to H5 but what went
wrong for him after Bishop C6 check and
the bishop dropped back to E5 how could
this go so wrong for black yeah
absolutely the reason is there's so many
options in his double edge also time if
you look at the time it's always a huge
thing use time as a piece right it's the
same thing you have 16 pieces but that
17th one that you'll talk about is your
clock right so him having this clock
time and him having a good position if
he has five minutes on the clock here
this is easy win
but with 56 seconds right and trying to
figure this out and my king being weak
as well I'm going to have some problems
yeah she brought Queen E3 you were
mentioning that move that allows the
king to escape if the Rook were to give
his check but here's where he went wrong
King to G7 and the tables turned
completely instead of that move it would
appear that a move like say a queen
actually I don't see a good queen move
even because this bishop is loose on uh
B7 the position is that difficult like
any move I'm gonna suggest has a
drawback so I actually don't know what
Black's best move I'm gonna look it says
actually Queen D what queen D6 giving up
this bishop on B7 somehow is good
because after Bishop F4 there's a
problem with this queen getting trapped
with Rook H1 check so that is two five
head for me I'm gonna be honest James
instead we saw King G7 but this is where
it all went wrong Rook B5 give me your
Bishop after the bishop of Queen E7 with
96 check to follow and we saw a rook
trade but that was that 96 came give me
this Pawn F7 bring my other Knight into
the game and Checkmate is about to
happen King H6 only move Knight F5 is
mate that is why the way you resigned
that is how I read SU one and James
where that brings us in the match thus
far is a three and a half half lead or
the Bulldogs received Dura Bailey
against
um the only draw in round one but as we
head into round two the Shanghai Tigers
we know what they're capable of James
when he gets the white pieces Drew and
June she gets the white piece as well do
they have an opportunity now to come
back they definitely have an opportunity
to come back here they are very very
strong extremely strong team only losing
one time right and they have two wins so
they are they are capable of doing it
but the problem is here that you have to
get over the last round you have to say
oh they reset and kikaru says you should
have short-term memory loss when you
come when you have losses so when them
else happened we lost that round and it
was not close right we had one draw out
of four games we need to just reset and
come back and play this game that we
know how to play so well
often easier said than done and you know
as you said it was kind of like a it was
being posterized and that's not easy to
rebound from suddenly you get subjective
like you feel like you have to win and
that's where chess can go wrong it's an
objective game you cannot start thinking
about the result as early as move one
you need to play the position but at
this point James I'm going to ask you
I'm gonna put you on the spot a little
bit okay the Shanghai tigers have to
play for a win down three points after
the opening round well absolutely in
fact every round from here is more like
I need to play for a win and this is for
the team this is not just for me this is
for the whole team this is everybody's
watching right because you can get blown
out and then you won getting one loss
away from elimination that's tough to be
that's where we are this week Garden
State passers right so we're one we
every match is elimination now for us so
we don't want of course if Shanghai
tires doesn't want this we're going to
pick up pick it up now three points is
it you know we keep the same lead up you
know you're going to be you're never
going to catch up eight and a half would
be in the next
it's a surprising result if I'm being
honest because the Croatia Bulldogs came
into this week without their top board
Bogan Daniel dayat not in the lineup
this week they're relying on some very
strong but you know players in their
2600s compared to the likes of a monster
of Wei Yi who's 2700 plus and has been
for what feels like an eternity so I
think that the Bulldogs you couldn't
have scripped this any better for them
as they look to lock up a player a
playoff spot so we're gonna about to see
the round two get underway here and uh
the Bulldogs they're in great shape the
Shanghai Tigers they need to strike
right now
absolutely they need to strike now and
strike you know fast as a tiger wood as
a tiger could okay we need that right as
we will see from uh from these uh this
next game starting okay let's see what
we get we're Bailey with Eve for night
and how you responds you need to go
aggressive here's probably C5
okay waiting for a move from Lou you're
paying here no move yet
okay E5 so he's he's a very solid player
James so I'm not too surprised to see
him play uh the King's Pawn here and
we're getting an auntie Berlin none of
the mainline Berlin stuff well this has
become all the rage but it looks like
the Italian that we just saw in the
first round
absolutely it quite often transposes
into many things that you've seen before
these Royal Lopez positions or at least
the close ones like this definitely are
you see this in an Italian game by via
different move orders here but with a
more aggressive option with uh door
Bailey here and G5 oh yeah I think this
is Theory here still but there's like a
you can sack in some cases but I don't
think it's on the side hey King G7
I'm definitely attempted to sign right
now if this were a bullet game I know
you would have done this uh you know 30
seconds ago give me those two pawns or
the sacrifice piece the king is open but
as James's Instinct was the king often
slides up to G7 and there's isn't quite
enough Firepower as black is able to
defend this Knight on F6 so it seems
like received durability he probably
wants to make the sacrifice but he
probably is kind of like James I know it
shouldn't work I know I shouldn't do it
but it's so tempting how could I not
yeah it sucks I mean ah man but I think
he gets out of it by a king G7 Rook h8
with the idea of Rook H5 sometimes you
can even go Rook GA instead of King on
fa and attack the bishop I can't go F4
if I could go F4 this is the idea
usually Sac on G5 Knight G5 A6 Bishop
takes King H1 play F4 open file that's
it it's easy plan but it doesn't work if
he's able to get King G7 Rook G8 or King
G7 Rook ha and then took the king and
Rogue and I may not have enough time
here
because you're saying and F4 is often
met by Knight G4 type tactics as well
right oh man I'm going full Canty right
now wow where's that King going it ain't
going back to G1 that's for sure this is
a family channel Robert get this off the
screen
yeah just to conclude the line after
King G3 I'm guessing you could just play
uh maybe Knight H5 or politics first and
Knight H5 check to follow but this king
is being hunted and you see the Evo bar
Sky High or actually down low but in
Black's favor so no move yet from vasif
durability kind of odd to meet James
because as you said this is a
theoretical sequence so he may be
unfamiliar and you know he's calculating
that sacrifice absolutely so we
definitely some Coe here and with Bishop
G5 if it's not working he's just gonna
go with Bishop G3 yeah yes it's a sick
line with this queen with the Rook sack
and everything too oh yeah I'm just
gonna put the bishop back on G3 and
chill we don't need to do none of that
Knight G5 and he goes forward
he's going for it thank you big fella
okay all right Brethren I see you Mikey
you you know how this works James right
once you've invested some time you're
like I gotta do it I have to but this
could backfire horribly right because
you said King G7 look at Louisa Pink's
clock 9 minutes 43 seconds he is not
phased he knows that the sacrifice
should not pan out and F4 is the move
you need to get in but look at that he
takes on he takes a place
oh that's sick you were Bailey with the
Coe the calculation is sick that's nice
that's so nice you take the because he
was like the problem was the bishop this
is why we played King H1 of D4 to get
rid of the Knight then play B4 and play
f for you I like it yeah and I just want
to point out that that quickly Pawn
takes D4 would have been a terrible
decision because once the bishop moves
back white has this move Pawn to E5 and
very importantly after Pawn takes Pawn
takes we see this pin you may think
you're getting out of the pin so if Rook
takes D1 the Knight moves but that's why
you take on F6 with check first then you
take this queen and white ends up
several pawns ahead with a vicious
mating attack so we see the bishop slide
back to B6 F4 James you're a happy
camper and I think for Rapid chess this
is a pretty good idea remember Wei Yi
actually lost the game against Maxine
versus Sheila Grove where Maxine was
dead lost according to the engine but
practically speaking there were threats
against the black king that's what vasif
durable is aiming for here absolutely
threats against the black king here the
engines like yo this is garbage get this
out of here and it's crazy to me like
how they defend this I'm not actually
sure that's insane like it just feels
like white has a very nice attack and
you just really prefer to be white
because you have a lot of calculating to
do with black to figure out how is this
not losing like how am I how am I going
to untangle I mean immediately F takes
E5 is on the cars right now right now
and then Bishop takes F6 so you have to
be fast here I'm just curious to see
what do you even do here in this
position
I not really sure James if I'm being
honest I feel like uh these types of
positions sometimes there's only one
move that allows black to escape I think
Pawn takes D4 is a good start just
because we don't want to a PIN to become
overwhelming and with this Pawn on D4
you probably have to react because this
king is in line with the bishop so we'll
leave Louis pink to it he is a very
solid player who is not afraid of
tactics once they occur so see if he's
able to find the best continuation but
the game will still remain sharp so
let's go to our bird's eye view and look
at our other games that are all underway
in the top right that's the game we're
looking at between received or Bailey
and Lou yaping in the top left quiet
game between mustafael Maz and shuyi and
James I'm a little bit more interested
in the bottom left way he versus
anti-sarage and the bottom right between
Jew and June Irene sukander but I think
for now we'll go to Wei and SARS just
because that game it is looking like it
has the possibility of really spicing up
I see pawns on F4 and D4 a clamp in the
center and black just looks a bit
passive to my liking
100 passive is a not the way you want to
be planning out all the time obviously
if you would need to be passive
sometimes you have to play it or
whatever and it's just how chess goes
but definitely space is an advantage and
it's also good to be on the side that
has the space here and white it has
everything developed every piece is off
of the back rank even the bishop on D2
which is probably the worst piece but
it's still off the back rank the Rooks
are connected black is like 310p now
still what I was like four Champion one
two three you have to move you have to
move like three pieces Queen Knight and
Bishop and connector and move the Rook
right that's a lot of moves here I like
this queen B6 move though trade pieces
when you have less space yeah very good
idea playing with the chess principles
is anti-stars he won his first game
against two one June so he was maybe the
unsung hero of the round for the
Bulldogs and we have seen a queen trade
so how do you take back he says let me
take with the Knight but there's a
problem down the C file and you were
calling out for this James Black was
behind in development what does that
mean that white can strike first and now
there's already a direct threat the
Knight on C6 once the pawn takes give me
that pawn if you take on E5 white takes
back with the F Pawn and it cements
control this D6 Square I'm going to show
you how the Knight gets to D6 The Rook
gets to C7 this is just yikes it's
horrible
oh my goodness yeah this is getting bad
this is getting really really bad I
think you might have to go something
like Bishop D7 that's a huge concession
you do get up the bishop here Bishop's
already gross anyway it's a French
Bishop so it's a really bad Bishop so
Bishop to D7 might be a move and it may
be in the only move Bishop D7 maybe work
after CA and just hey hopefully we're
holding passive like you said it's
passive but you can't break it it is
passive but you can't break it yet it
says uh black Bishop D7 or I mean what
do you have to respond now to this
Knight C6 right because that's either 95
or move the Knight somewhere else yeah
hey James you're calling it man you're
calling the shots here Bishop D7 a great
move defending and I would not take this
bishop I think that there's just the
pressure the threat is strong in the
execution you want black to take here to
bring your Pawn to E5 so I play Knight
D6 go after B7 go after F7 and encourage
black to take this Knight on E5 that you
can take back with this f-pawn and open
up your Rook along the f file so I just
would say clear Advantage for way Yi I
mean Auntie Sarge has a good chest
picture painting in his background I'm a
fan of that good artwork but he's gonna
have to get creative uh because this
position does look problematic for him
he's just passive he has weaknesses in
his position he's not threatening
anything uh White is very safe and sound
so I like neither move Knight D6 James I
think way he's in the driver's seat
absolutely I think he's 100 in the
driver's seat it reminds you of one of
those Catalan positions where like you
just get denied the net the good
Advantage which is with the uh Bishop on
G2 and it's usually an open Bishop on G2
so not so much Cattleman like but
definitely with the the queen trade and
similarities that you see in the Catalan
those ones and stuff like that so
White's doing well here Knights of D6
and The Rook of B8 I mean you can even
expand on the queen side but there it is
and the B4 is coming B5 get the seventh
rank my pieces are so much better it's
the same amount of material it's very
instructive to know
um for chat here guys that this is like
the pieces are just better than blacks
like there's nothing different it's just
the pieces are better than your pieces
and that's a huge thing yeah you're 100
correct so uh we're gonna leave this
game with Wei having the advantage it's
uh noticeable it's not one that's oh
it's a slight Advantage maybe he can
take it actually like the advantage is
quite big and from a practical
perspective maybe bigger than the
evaluation bar suggests let's go back to
a bird's eye view as Auntie Sarge will
struggle to fend this off against Wei
but I'm looking at the top right right
goodness I was about to go to a
difference but maybe we have to go right
back into the game between vasif
durability and luya ping because that
could be a a huge game for the Tigers
they need every game to go their way at
this point they're down three and a half
you know you need one Victory here just
to get the ball rolling but James look
at this the King on E7 suddenly death
doesn't look like such a weak King and
black is putting pressure
into White's camp
how did we get here what happened the
bishop there was a bishop on G5 and now
there's not so what were the last few
moves here we left off F4 takes and
queen E8 sliding out of this nasty pin
and he said I gotta take you now because
uh the Knight was
out in the open he says I don't mind my
King's gonna go delayed bomb Cloud up to
E7 and James this is great play for
black white is grasping at straws here I
don't see any real threats Rook H3 could
be played at any moment this g-pawn is
pinned a queen H7 of course going after
H2 things like that
I feel like this position is just really
really good for black and I don't just
see what White's gonna do there's no
attack to speak of
yeah there's no attack what's the time
look like yeah and durabelly's down on
time as well so it's pretty tough for
him I mean it looked and it felt right
the sacrifice felt right the problem
with these sacrifices sometimes is that
you you the level of accuracy required
after the sacrifice is what is the is
the hard part that's the the easy part
is sacking the piece you know you feel
the intuitive and it feels good and you
know like tao-like Town didn't calculate
as much it was more intuitive right so
it is more you know once you see it
later on and you can calculate a little
bit you're done sometimes in these
positions here this is exactly what's
going on we only have the pawn Center
that may be mobile we may be able to
push these pawns if we can get these
pawns rolling then we have something
that's that's what he's trying to do
right now a bishop is pretty gross plays
B5 practically why still in the game via
here
yeah but as you said buy a hair and you
know barely that because uh you need
just to go out for this black king but
White's the one who has less time a
white center is in danger if you make a
move like Queen G7 at some point the
queen can flip on over the H file as
well too after this H2 Pawn I just feel
like uh the game is getting out of hand
for receive durability he's down a piece
his King is actually maybe a weaker one
surprisingly there's all this pressure
in the position that he has to deal with
Rook H3 still a pretty nasty threat just
because there's an issue along the third
Rank and the Jeep Pawn is pinned so yeah
I'm not really liking this or received
durability that would be a huge victory
for the Tigers if they're able to secure
it because the Bulldogs were out to a
blazing hot start and now it looks like
vasif is on the defensive so let's leave
him to the defensive task because with
the every game in the Pro chess league
is of equal importance I say this every
single week because it's true in the top
left mustafael Maz slight Advantage just
like way he has in the bottom left just
more space or white bottom left top left
similar Dynamics but I'd like to go to
the game in the bottom right James
because uh not too many pieces have been
traded between women's world champion
June and Irene sukhander the hero of the
first round but we'll see uh into the
second round if Irene can keep up the
momentum the magic or the uh
for the uh Bulldogs that is Irene
we are fixing that everybody don't you
worry we know that's not Irene that is
Mustafa mask that's Irene that's a
receipt
her on screen and
James look at her clock by the way she's
doing superbly well on time
yeah she's fearless I can just tell you
so a lot of times you can tell from
people's body language how comedy are
awful all sort of Confidence from that
last game yeah she got huge confidence
she's like that's your ward one all
right cool let's go Jew let me show you
how I do right okay so Irene is playing
some good good chess here right now
there's nothing wrong with her position
I mean the engine says the slight favor
for white I guess that's probably the
bishop here they like is there a pawn
deficit three six seven three six seven
it's the same amount everything's the
same besides the night versus Bishop
here yeah so very good game excellent
game from from Irene here this is what
you want from the board four of course
White's gonna have to try to push here
the dark Square Bishop isn't that good
D4 can be quite weak in a way um so I
think this is gonna be a longer game
very long game yep so we you know we've
tuned in not too much happening we might
see a bunch of Rook trades white should
be slightly better in the long term in
the end game maybe this bishop can slide
out to some of these dark squares and go
after these Queen side pawns but some
excitement is happening on the other
board so I do think we should go to the
bird's eye view two games May end any
second I said the games were similar in
the bottom left and the top left bars
are similar there Sky High should be
victory for the players with the white
pieces Wiki and Mustafa ill Mas in the
bottom left I mean look at this I think
way he suddenly is up a rook for a
couple minor pieces uh but he's also
going after the black king so let's uh
just dive in there before we go to the
game at the top left because musafiramaz
also in demolition mode James we're just
gonna scroll back a few to see Knight D6
was played that capture happened nobody
likes to see that with the open C and F
files the Bishops set up up to B4 after
Knight C8 here you go take my knight I
give give a knife for a punch but I got
this one in return an oversight by
Auntie Sarge in a tough position and
then Rook C7 Intermezzo hitting this and
putting more pressure on F7 and we see
what happened down goes F7 down goes E6
this is a big problem the Rooks are
tethered together if you took on C6
looks like a free piece you lost the
Rook that's why the bishop slid out the
G4 we'll take E6 and James let's game
over that was sick way I do know he had
I remember seeing you know what's funny
some tactics books I've seen his tactics
like and they'll show oh yeah and this
is the way he did to this person like
you know you didn't want to put a name
there because it's like you don't even
want to be resociated with what happened
with that tactic so way e very very
strong player here aggressive and found
some nasty tactics there to finish this
out again his pieces were just better
now he has what they call pigs on the
seventh there from Aaron Nim's witch but
two Rooks doubled on the seventh here
this is decisive material uh lost
especially even being down in peace
quotation marks really because I'm about
to play take on E6 Rook H7 is coming
your pieces three of your four pieces
are on the back rank for black hair so
really really rough E6 is hanging two as
well this one's lights out yeah this
one's lights out and so is the game
between Mustafa ilmaz and shuyis let's
go back to our four board scene because
that game we haven't been able to dive
into it as much as we would like but as
we're looking at it here on the screen
ouch this is just a brutal attack it
started right here F5 open up the light
squares give me the F7 Pawn he says no
I'm gonna keep that close but F6 I am
going to break open your king side one
way or another and after it takes Queen
G4 check the king had to slide to the
corner and after Queen H4 this Knight is
hanging feel free to take it because if
and when you do I am going to take on H6
with check the queen was protected by
the way by this Knight the king slides
here and Rook F3 Rook lift it's going to
end the game that's just mate it's not
much of heavy lifting here it's just a
quick Slaughter and musafir omaz James
you were talking about him as the first
games got underway he's an absolute
Beast he is he's an absolute Beast I
remember talking about him a lot right
is very very very strong and I remember
seeing him uh playing I can't remember
some qualifier or something online that
he played in and I was like every round
I was talking I kept saying his name I
was like yo this guy is really strong
who is this guy like who are you right
and he came out of nowhere smashing
everyone right here and of course when
he's on he's on and he's playing very
strong right here look how quick he's
moving instance
yeah I mean he is just feeling it right
now and his username on chess.com is
Chopper and well it looks like that's
what he brought to this game a buzz saw
and he is just steamrolling this black
king you could just take on F6 uh with
your knight over here he's probably
looking at Rook takes F6 bring the next
Rook on over the H6 Pawn will be loose
in many variations as well why not go
that way Knight F6 tempting but Rook F6
is probably better uh but yeah look at
this the Evo bar has not really moved at
all still
domination for white wow a knight of six
Blade Knight of six with maybe uh now
what's the next move I mean it doesn't
matter like we can break F3 Rook F2 over
cap four Queen H5 we can do anything
yeah just keep on building the attack
make two Rick F3 Rook G3 Queen H6 Rick
ga oh I gotta show that James
James Kitty has been doing his tactics
good call James
um just to by the way uh looks like
Louis pink did win that game on board
too we'll get to that in a minute uh no
surprise there given the peace sacrifice
did not work out but James is spying a
tactic let's say Rook B8 Rook F3 Rook C
he's saying Rook G3 check your King has
to go back and he's noticing that the
King has no safe score so Queen H6 take
my queen why don't you and Rook G8 James
that's nasty yes practice of course we
do tactics for breakfast lunch and
dinner over at our Channel but of course
uh we're seeing him right here and
hopefully we see something sick like
that in the next few moves it's going to
be maybe even a bishop E6 here it
doesn't work yet because Queen takes and
just anything right like F3
F2 I just not really want to see your
you know checkmating sequence work
because Rook at four I mean he might be
going yeah
right G4
getting Rook G4 now does it work
I think we shouldn't tunnel on it right
it feels very strong okay well that also
feels that's even man
yeah this is brutal I mean seriously no
moves for black throughout the last
bunch of the game it just is a one-sided
Affair and Mustafa yamas is going to
take this one home so
um while this game is looking good for
the Bulldogs I actually do want to zoom
out of this one because I we can trust
Mustafa if something changes we'll let
you know in the top right uh Louis ping
did get the victory you've seen the
final position a queen trade is being
offered otherwise there's a checkmating
attack in Black's favor in the bottom
left Wei Yi uh he won his game against
anti-sarx let's go to the bottom right
board between June June and Irene
sukander because James you were saying
oh maybe white should be a little bit
better because the bishop pair now
White's a lot better and it's entirely
because of the bishop air wow yeah
that's tough It's practical I mean
practical when there's practical chances
right and not looking at the eval bar
things are always different right if
these two Bishops are just better to
play as white Bishop E5 the Knight
versus the bishop here that Bishop still
on A6 now of course the other Bishop is
on F1 but definitely white is for Choice
as we have of course both diagonal color
complexes we can deal with and black can
only do with one
two we have
she's going for this Pawn over here on
A2 and if you move the pawn there might
be like a knight D1 check Knight up to
E3 and that's likely what she's aiming
for the eval bar it's still high in uh
White's favorite it's because black
can't move this queen is forever tied
down to the defense of this Pawn on G7
so that means that even in the event of
some kind of random Night Moves going
after this bishop I don't think it's
going to pan out because black is
completely Frozen and after 93 I think
you keep it light Bishop H3 G1 June does
not need to be told twice she says the
bishop pairs my bench and by the way
King dies who traps this Knight I was
just thinking I was like is King D2
trapping the Knight like what a weird
night trap never seen that one before
maybe you gotta Bounce Around wow the
Knight is really trapped that's a really
bad Beast I can't move it anywhere nice
C2 and then Knight A1 you gotta be
kidding me but the Knight on A1
this queen takes away the Nitra treaty
squares over here so the Knight goes to
A1 as you're saying Queen A3 still will
trap that Knight so I just feel like
we're in a position where Irene zukonder
she was the hero of round one looks like
Jew and June is gonna get a bounce back
victory in round two and by the way I
mean with the Tigers winning with Lou
yaping and Wei James The Comeback is
real it's already here uh there might
tie up the score and you know what
that's what I was saying here like how
strong they are to go to one in this
protest League season with these teams
and your two you got two wins yeah
they're they're a machine so they're not
gonna go down at all now without a fight
in that first round three and a half the
half looked rough there right or three
two
I mean half and half whatever it is but
it was it's rough it looked very rough
now it doesn't look rough at all here
just playing hey we had to reset play
our game and we'll see what happens and
right now we're seeing what's happening
it's over because this Knight is trapped
no safe squares for it it'll be captured
no matter where it jumps to and F4 I'm
not even gonna take your Pawn F4 I'm
gonna take this Pawn E6
remember everybody this this queen is
C7 so I will take on E6 you can't take
me back and that means I'll check my e
on squares like G8
is that free it looks like a free night
to me that's free that's for me can take
C2
I like that she's looking around when
you find a good move look for a better
one as Alaska says but I don't think
there is I mean does it seem like a
better move to my surprise is here but
King takes C2 definitely seems like the
move
and I I think Irene just Desperately
Seeking counter play against this King
on C2 maybe a check at some point but
that's it it's just one single check
let's say your next move is Queen C6 the
king slides the D2 you are out of the
checks and the queen will always need to
stay attached to the G7 Pawn so I think
that uh this one should be over in the
very near future it looks like it's just
a domination but while this is happening
let's go back to our bird's eye view
because somehow Mustafa yamas has not
won his game already
he's down to 12 seconds what
is still alive wow he got nine lives he
got none of them boys he is a team you
know it's a cat team James
ah I forgot about that they do guys the
tiger that makes sense now dang oh five
seconds mustafa's gonna move DeForest
hanging with check so can you just take
this Pawn in the center that's the big
question I think you can get away with
it if you can and then King H1 and then
how and maybe how do you defend the mate
there's definitely a mate 987 you have
to run for the heels
I'm gone all right
oh if you take Queen takes as a mate on
the back rank oh my goodness he's gonna
flag he barely got to move off two
seconds elmaz is feeling the pressure
oh my Goshi is a magician he's bullet
Houdini wow he was dead lost
wow
wow this man
is the luckiest man alive we got to play
the lottery with him guys for the
lottery number boy wow
and black suddenly is up two pawns James
this b-pawn over here on the queen side
and the double up pod so it was King G7
he can block a check with his Queen H3
played so F5 can be captured not so fast
The Rook comes up and black is doing
this perfectly right now this is not
good news for the Bulldogs jeez I mean
this is what a throw right I'm throwing
so hard chat such a hard throw like it's
really a hard throw here that well there
is no way he was supposed to let this
get like this even with the time he had
uh oh and oh Queen D6 not going for the
back rank and he says I can slide here
can I not take it one second
earlier in this game shui offered a draw
it was declined by Mustafa yamas then
Mustafa offered a draw and then it was
declined by shuyi so these players have
traded draw offers black is not drawing
this game anymore bring that Rook down
to C2 and if Rooks have to come off the
board this should be a winning ending
for Black this is gross this is crazy
wow that's one of those still yeah look
at the noises in the adult language
luckily we have his silence so you can't
hear what he's saying but definitely
some adult language and knocking over
pieces and uh and whatever's in front of
your computer after this game here this
is huge especially to take an ale from a
position that you were 100 winning the
pawns connected yeah this is take this
and go right back
now easily winning for black up two
separate pass pawns how in the world did
this happen James and if
wins maybe it's when he wins it will be
a four nothing sweep for the Shanghai
Tigers get out of here this is yeah
that's uh some some Voodoo uh witchcraft
going on here definitely something going
on here I don't know what happened but
that was insane 4-0 it's not many of
those in the whole protest League
unbelievable before this Rook is amazing
it defends both pawns at the same time
that allows the black king to run over
perfect placement for streets Rook this
is done once the king boots The Rook off
the sixth rank the king will walk up the
board already B3 is a threat with the
Rook sliding behind the pass upon I
think Mustafa Moz is gonna throw in the
towel and that means the lead that was
once a three-point margin for the
Bulldogs will be eradicated and it will
be the tigers with a one point advantage
that is unreal chat welcome to the pro
chess league right just when you thought
you knew what was going on
you did not like I didn't know that it
was gonna happen either I could have
swore he was going to win this game you
put this in any position anybody oh yeah
you could see Mustafa he's like cursing
himself shuyi gave a little bit of fist
pump celebrator we have to go back just
very quickly uh and look at this I mean
not here earlier on this was just
demolition territory we were praising
mustafa's King was getting checkmated
and I'm wondering where it all went
wrong because the position looked so
promising early on for white this King
could barely move it's about to get
mated and so we saw after this trade
over here that the black queen it was
able to scoop up this Pawn on A3 not
here on the next move steals this A3
Pawn because James he went for your
checkmating attack that was a big
mistake he went for your mating attack
man yeah he went for it too late it's
too late cause now he allowed 97. when
the Knight got to C6 I think if he went
way before then with the Rook G4 it
would be and 97 stops the whole May
threat and then you got to do something
else that's crazy
and Mustafa is still shaking his head
he's in disbelief and the whole team
from Croatia should be beside themselves
right now because the lead is now where
the Tigers names four wins in four games
or Shanghai yeah they're uh in fact here
have you guys ever seen like the
slapping contest thing that's just like
on Facebook and or like anywhere just
online where they're just like slapping
each other it's like a whole league of
people that just slap each other and I
know people in the chat know exactly
what this is but this is what it seems
like like you stand there and you hit me
and I hit you right back in the next one
and then we see who hits hard enough
who's gonna win because that was a hard
hit in round one those Bulldogs hit him
very hard then they came back and they
hit you even harder in a second round
with a 4-0 now you respond in round
three it's gonna be very scary I don't
know who's gonna win now but this is
definitely a match-up for the ages in
the PCL right now
it really is that was an epic round of
action I can't believe that we're saying
that the Shanghai tigers have a lead but
they do four and a half points for them
three and a half points for the Croatia
Bulldogs they entered round two with
three or not points they exited round
two with just three and a half because
as you see for the Tigers it wins on all
four boards they're very balanced right
now but Chris said James same from them
they are down a point right now but
still some good performances especially
by their board four I've read sukhander
in that opening game
absolutely a very good performance
stealing both sides are like all right
you can hit I can hit two as well you
swing I'm swinging two you win I it's
back and forth It's still basically
level but Shanghai does have that one
point lead and in one point it's better
than none because when we get to Seven I
have eight and a half eight and a half
takes it so right now the tigers are
definitely feeling a sense of relief and
don't even feel the first round anymore
this one crochet now fills this round
more than ever right you gotta
definitely bounce back and there's a lot
of emotions going into the round three
here about what just happened especially
for Mustafa gotta bounce over that
heartbreaking boss right now
yeah I can't believe it the Tigers did
just roar back but the action in this
match will continue and there's just so
much chess these days the protesting is
happening double headers here today
tomorrow and on Friday but there's also
a major event about to take place uh
it's finally here the 2023 chessable
Masters this is the second event of this
year's Champions chess tour and it's a
Monumental one because the chest of
Masters will be Magnus Carlson's last
major event as world champion Hikaru
Nakamura Wesley so and Fabiano caruana
joined Magnus in division one thanks to
their dominant performance in the air
things masters with four remaining seats
in the top division to be filled during
this Monday's play-in tune in for the
play-in on Monday March 13th at 8 A.M
Pacific right here at twitch.tv chess
use the command CCT in chat or details
well for that event James and I will be
sent off to Norway to cover from the
studio but for now we're going to send
ourselves off the break we'll be back in
a few from this protesting matchup
between the Shanghai tigers and the
Croatia Bulldogs we'll be right back
[Music]
so I loved puzzles I loved solving any
puzzle you put in front of me so chess
was unnatural for my brain it was the
unsolvable puzzle it wasn't one of those
things you just looked at here is the
puzzle what's the solution it it was a
puzzle inside of an enigma inside of a
mystery like what is this game and there
was so much to it the more you learned
the more there was to learn so that
puzzle solving uh gift that I had or
desire wish you know I would do
crossword puzzles back in the day as
well as a little as a high school kid
fell in love with New York Times
crossword puzzles had to do one of those
every every day that the puzzle came out
in the paper so I always was a puzzle
solver and I think that that made it
easy for me to to transfer over that
skill set to chess
hey everybody it's Danny here and as you
may know chess.com and chessable are now
one and I'm here to show you how you can
make your chest.com and chessable one in
just a few clicks to start let's log in
and connect our chess.com account I just
scroll right here above the browser and
click login scroll down and click
continue with chess.com now if you're
already logged into chess.com it's just
gonna ask you if you want to approve
that connection I'm going to say yes sir
but after approving it'll bring you
right back to the chessable home page
now the puzzle connect feature can be
found under Tools and you click puzzle
Connect Now what that does after you
type in your username is it's going to
pull positions from the games you've
played on chess.com create your very own
personalized chessable course and then
quiz you with the positions where you
may have missed the best move and the
more you play on chess.com the more
games it will have to quiz you as long
as your account stays connected it's
pretty sweet and it's going to help you
get better learning from the mistakes in
your games yes this is a pro feature
accessible but if you go to
accessible.com link you can get 30 days
of pro for free
foreign
women's world champion Juan Jun should
be feeling happy on this International
women's day she did just win her game
against Irene sukander and every Victory
from the Shanghai Tigers was necessary
in the second round of action she takes
bore two or the Squadron James Jew and
June she's an absolute Legend we know uh
her accomplishments as the Women's World
chess champion as you mentioned earlier
in the show one of Six Women to surpass
the 2600 rating threshold but in the
protest League specifically she's been
great this season she has a plus score
as an underrated board too 2555 is not
your typical board 2 in this league we
often see 2 700 plus players so what can
you say of her performance absolutely
her performance is saying well why she's
a three-time women's world chess
champion I mean of course there are some
excellent and it's super strong just as
good as the men uh world champions our
chess and chess right for for the women
so three times she's figured it out
basically over there so she's also 26
she was 2600 rated one of his six women
in the history of Jeff's to do this he's
an absolute Beast underrated still young
right lots of Chess in her career still
and still can improve so definitely a
nice highlight card from Julian she's
like a walking you know the walking
highlight reels and basketball and stuff
like that like she's a highlight reel
this is walking highlight reel is you
well she definitely had some great
highlights in that last round where she
won against Irene sukander and that
brings us to round three with the
Shanghai Tigers ahead four and a half
three and a half we know that shuyi he
was on the verge of defeat and yet he
turned that one around and uh stole
Victory from the jaws of defeat and that
means heading into the third round we
see the individual pairings as such Zhu
and Jun and Wei Yi the top two boards
for the Shanghai Tigers they get the
white pieces but auntie saritch and
Irene sukander or the Bulldogs they'll
get the white pieces themselves so James
advantage on the scoreboard Tigers what
do you who do you see it having the
advantage in round three here between
the Bulldogs and tigers I think tigers
are off the momentum tigers have a
momentum after that last one especially
if uh Mustafa hasn't you know bounced
back from that last game it was
devastating Jew was ready swinging she
was just on fire cool I just won let's
go let's get another one and I got the
white pieces it's always great when you
you like win with black then you get
white next you're like oh let's go oh
that's always the excellent feeling no
matter who you're playing but I think
it's definitely in the favor of the
Shanghai tigers
yeah and while June June her reward
after beating Irene sukhander is to play
this man right here mustafael Maz when
he was playing excellent chess it was a
bit of commentator's curse we left his
game he was completely winning and not
in a way that just the Boris says it but
it's not easy no he was just destroying
his opponent and yet he couldn't bring
it home or the Bulldogs but he's a
fantastic player he's a Turkish
Grandmaster a multi-time national
champion played in the Tata steel
Challengers event back in January where
he was very close to winning uh finished
in the top few places but I just want to
highlight as well is what a Monumental
performance that was in Route 2 by the
Tigers only the third time this season a
team has swept the other four nil we saw
the Indian yogis do it against the chess
bras in week two and then we saw it last
week when the Gotham Knights did that to
the Tigers so they have gotten their
Vengeance but this is very rare is now
the third round June June plays D4 James
what do you expect to see from this game
you know what I'm I thought it was going
to be a king's Indian he is a Kings
Indian player a lot but now with Knight
F3 he wasn't expecting to see that so we
go C5 here
there's so many ways to go you can go D5
obviously E3 even Knight to C3 it really
she goes D5 grab the space yeah
grab the space take take and this is now
benoni
I was not expecting that I you know I'm
a fan of benoni as a spectator and a
commentator right as a player I've
always been like yeah that D6 Pawn not
the best A4 what was that about B5
you're not getting that I always felt
like it was easier to play for white and
yet these strong GMS like mustafael Maz
they keep coming back to it yeah so as I
mean even I didn't know what the benoni
meant so I like Google look at looked at
the stuff and he's like but know what he
means son of Sorrow I'm like why would I
play what do you mean what is that why
are we doing this right so you know but
it's understandable there is a lot of
King's Indian action to it even Tao is a
fan of this and Tao's uh trainer
nesbittinoff was a I like these games
Talon is within off are some of my
favorite players so of course we know
they like benoni's and Kings Indians but
this day and time it's much harder to
play these things especially giving his
face to your opponents and your strong
opponent giving so much space to them it
really could be a problem later on
because of the accuracy it requires to
keep up this type of uh imbalance that
you're you're looking for
and you mentioned accuracy I'm looking
at Mustafa playing accurately and
quickly opening up this dark Square
Bishop that's the good thing about the
benoni is once that Knight hops out the
way this bishop on G7 is a very powerful
piece and B5 may be available at some
moment after Rook to beat white often
has to split A5 herself just to stop
that push but you can play it anyway
opposant is not the end of the world
with pressure down the B file control of
the E5 Square I feel like Mustafa Maz
playing the perfect opening in a game
where he really wants to win after last
game's debacle absolutely especially if
you know all the plans and ideas here
which it looks like he absolutely does
and that goes to E8 it's looking
actually pretty good here Knight C7 B5
they say if you in the benoni if you can
get Rook B8 B5 and the open Bishop you
have six you you if like you won the
game you know what I mean like you just
win you know you're not obviously
winning but it feels like you're just
winning okay cool I got everything I
could get out of the opening uh
objective achieve right level up you to
play B5 you got to get the Rook to B8
Knight to C7 or sometimes uh sometimes
uh H5 or something like that like moving
at 57 H5 but definitely getting B5 and
Rook B8 and open the bishop up and we
have chances here in uh some good benoni
games why steal all the time I remember
they said even if you get a good banoni
it's still a benoni and I was like wow
that's funny so but I mean even if you
get everything white still has a lot of
space
and well speaking of space and attacking
H4 please have that pawn it's not
hanging because once the queen takes on
H4 the bishop slides up to G5 and that
Queen has nowhere to run that would be a
simple Queen trap so H4 good recognition
good tactical awareness by Jew and June
she wants H5 next let's go after this
King it's not a mating attack it's just
to soften up some of the squares because
sometimes black plays F5 but you're
gonna think twice about that with the
pawn coming to H5 and going after this
G6 Pawn or going all the way up to H6
kicking this bishop away from its fiend
Square so Rook B8 playing into the
common ideas in the position
um H5 is automatic to me uh Mustafa and
Moz playing very very quickly but he
could find himself in a bit of danger in
the next few moves that's correct in
fact H5 is automatic you know I played
there it is H5 I'm gonna take play G3
King G2 Rook H1 in many cases now it is
annoying with the 95 stuff but I mean we
played H5 just to open this up so maybe
though maybe he might take with the F on
and there's like some sacrifices on F3
interesting interesting you have to be
careful here maybe G3 first king G2 Rook
H1 just don't open the file
I like what you're saying that first of
all the threat is strong the execution
keep the tension and after F takes G6 a
rook sack for the bishop on F3 that is a
very thematic it's a good idea it's
something that Jew and June is going to
think twice about before she plays H
takes G6 so while this game still just
getting started the action will only
heat up from here we see that the three
other games are also in session uh the
top right early stages there closed
position and the bottom right oh just
the opening it looks like it might have
been a Petrov from shuyi very commonly
played by many of the best Chinese
players the Petrov defense and in the
bottom left we have anti-sarich just
trying to get a little bit of spatial
revenge against Louisa ping so much more
of a strategic round in the games that
don't include June and mustafi Hamas so
James which of the other three would you
like to dive into let's go to Wei Endura
Bailey this is like uh some type of Roy
here it looks like something with a
reticle
um I've seen the D5 Square there so I do
want to take a look at uh
see what's going on
we'll hop right to that one use some of
the D5 Square which is often the case in
these Spanish positions you want to play
for black and that's why Rook went to E1
saying not so fast James Canty you play
D5 you drop the E5 Pawn 100 and uh now
with black here my knight on C6 is quite
strange he stopped me from playing the
Knight A5 should go on variation stuff
with the Roy so I might go Knight V8
brayer style and then back to D7 to play
uh something like Knight B6 or maybe
even just a knight B8 to play C5 but I
need to get you know he plays rookie
eight maybe bishop f8 G6 Bishop B7 you
see these same ideas quite often here so
I can play D5 that's what he wants to
defend the E5 E5 Pawn he's like yeah you
can't move it when now after I move this
bishop I can so let me be sure
oh it's a it's a good call by you and
that's why sometimes white plays Knight
D5 but here way Yi getting creative like
Queen B1 I think he wants A4 James oh I
like that that's a nice move it's just
strange like I'm always a fan of
creativity and strange moves Queen B1
it's definitely strange yeah Queen B3
and the A4 is really strong in fact I'm
a big fan of I always mention this a lot
as I'm a big fan of the tempo I worked
with a coach that was just obsessed
basically with the tempo and I was like
wow I understand that because like you
get a lot from a Tempo and you also get
time right so you can be one after A4
tonight it's a nice Tempo makes you do
something I gain a little bit of time
there so A4 definitely is something but
maybe taking a rugby a could be quite
annoying
um yeah normally you don't want to take
on A4 but James's instincts tell him
let's go to the B file and go after this
Pawn on B4 that's why the queen came to
B1 it protects the pawn so that the a
pawn can't push so to me James Queen B3
is one option A4 is another and I'm
always thinking you know black trying to
go D5 can I actually put my knight on D5
first here and then try to play C4 next
and just playing Center yeah that's nice
I like that a lot in fact that was a
very good idea when he went with Queen
B3 was probably the same thing with
Knight D5 but that Knight E5 just
clamping grabbing that space is quite
quite great and you are just grabbing
space like space is an advantage you can
try to milk that later by improving the
position just saying I just have a
better position better pieces more space
yeah so we like the way you start to
this game but I like vasive durability's
clock he does not seem phased by the
wonky chess that way you use playing
Queen B1 Queen B3 where are you going
well I'm taking away the D5 Square I
want to play A4 so now we understand but
it takes a Visionary like Wei to
demonstrate what the future holds so
let's let these two continue out as H6
was played just to take away it's G5
Square I want to go back to our bird's
eye view because some of the other games
are getting a bit spicier this one no
pawns have been traded locked up but as
we see in the bottom left Louisa ping
dropped his Knight up to H5 going after
that bishop and then the top left that
benoni I mean things have changed there
where black got B5 and C4 and so why
don't we start in the bottom left and
then we may find ourselves back to June
June uh versus Mustafa ill Maz but I
think that this position could be I
almost want to say critical between
auntie sarich and
let's actually see what this was some
type of Catalan looks like maybe with a
knight on H5 now and okay Bishop to E3
yeah and this is a thing pretty level
pretty level I actually like as I've
studied some Catalan just a little bit
from both sides but I definitely like
White's position A7 I feel like I'm more
active that's what it is of course Gary
Kasparov talks about the activity
Trump's material most times the material
is even so when you have activity I mean
and we even material so you know it
feels better to be white here it didn't
actually believe it or not likes black
crazy that they like black just by a
hair like half a pawn looks like but at
the same time here I like white because
of the activity I love being active when
you have activity and in Practical
senses you have uh um options a thing
and more chances for your opponent to go
wrong
yeah and I think what you're calling for
is that Knight takes E5 Han takes Bishop
takes it looks like it wins black opal
in the center but then A7 can be grabbed
and I'm just going to quickly show what
that looks like because you grab a
Central Pawn that has to be good news my
coach always told me to win Pawns in the
center but once this Pawn here on the
flank goes down B6 is likely next as all
of these pieces are under attack so I
think that white would be very very
happy to see this occur and we have
Knight takes E5 Pawn takes on the board
and will black take on E5 or does Lily
pink have an in-between move he says Nah
don't need one now give me that pawn
James I'm starting to feel your points
A7 can be captured maybe I've been
throwing Rook takes C8 first sometimes
it's good to just take over the C file
I'm not sure but I would just be playing
Queen A7 here yeah just Queen E7 and
there it is Queen A7 hits B7 B6 is
hanging and then we have our Catalan
type A's right where they say you know
the Catalan Bishop is strong right now
it's not because it is hitting a brick
wall with B5 but if that ever moves plus
the bishop on B7 is pretty gross is this
behind it so if you pushed upon
obviously Bishop Hanks there you'll have
problems if we get rid of the B6 Pawn we
literally have two pass pawns being a
but B2 actually is hanging in some cases
so at least we have one pass pound which
is better than none white has just kind
of that little nagging long positional
Edge especially having a pawn and a
clear plan to try to maybe trade pieces
and actually use this Pawn to win the
game as you see in a mini Kettleman
I'm not really sure what black is going
to do here because B6 is hanging
um you mentioned the move d4 with the
bishop being loose I actually think that
there may be a tactic here uh that's
worth showing that was not it you see
the evaluation bar starting to go in
White's favor I think you can just take
this Pawn on B6 and then bring your
knight back to D4 you can say my past
pawns are going to be too dangerous for
you but I was going to show something
very quickly so we bring up an analysis
board I think that James you know just
the fact that you were talking about the
move made me think about it more default
is available you take my Bishop I take
yours you move your Bishop I take yours
on G2 and then your king is a bit
exposed and there might be some tactics
so I think you just talked it into his
existence there was an opportunity to
swap Rooks and play this D4 move and
then it gets wild and don't even know
who's better right that's very spicy
luckily we didn't go down that line well
I mean shoot I'm not playing so I don't
care
hey it's not me I don't have to face
that perfect all right well visual goes
to scene six here and of course like you
mentioned Bishop b694 is an excellent
move I love the night formal because it
blocks the fact that the B2 Pawn was
hanging also it's a Tempo hitting C6 if
you take the Knight and I have the
bishop pair and the dark squares
especially after Bishop before it's an
excellent plan take on B6 play Knight B4
and like say hey I'm better
yeah I think that uh this might be an
opportunity for the Croatia Bulldogs
night look at that that is a sign of a
fantastic player I just want to say very
loud and clear that anti-sarge instead
of taking what seemed like a free Pawn
over here but his pieces might have
become Tangled he says why do I need
that pawn I don't need a material
advantage when I have positional
dominance and not to mention after Rook
takes C8 you probably have to take with
the queen and then Queen's gonna take on
B6 anyway so you might win a pawn with a
different move order props to anti-sarge
who lost in a game two after winning the
first round he may be the hero for the
Bulldogs in this round three as Louisa
ping is on the clock and while he sits
and things I think we have to zoom out
of this one because James I'm gonna pull
up a position to your liking as we look
in the top left it's a benoni it got
sharp it remains sharp what do you make
of the action on our matchup between Jew
and June and mustafael Maz oh wait I can
smell some tactics the eval bar like yes
nothing here bro look you got to be look
kidding me look at this man this Knight
hanging over there Bishop's hanging as
well whose move is it Earth's up so it
is okay it's a Jew's move but she is low
on time well she's low takes takes now
she's do I take the Knight do I take the
bishop do I play eight six like there's
so many options
I think
geez I just think it's a bad sign when
you play a movie E5 let me just go back
she played this move right he took and
now she's thinking like that just feels
like she's not in the position
comfortably she is struggling to come up
with the exact plan
absolutely especially as we mentioned
before time is a piece here and it's
almost you're almost down a piece it may
be in five minutes now basically going
on five minutes now of Time Queen takes
C5 happen takes on that four Knight
takes B5 you're gonna take on C4 maybe
B6 is a pawn but I think this was a
great benoni it worked out yep it should
be two would be one and bishop's back oh
okay you know what C3 because if you
take Rook C8 oh get out of here tactinos
oh man them tactics C3 let's see if he
spots it
oh I was thinking
he can try
three yeah you think you're taking it
away but not so fast and that's really
bad news for Jew and June because uh
that pawn is getting closer and closer
to promotion uh the Knight on B5 is
protected by the bishop on E2 once that
pawn pushes up the board that's the good
news the bad news is while black has a
pass pawn and it's an extra Pawn
absolutely it's an extra Pawn C3 is
going to be very annoying because he
finds it oh man with the bounce back is
real noticing I can't take it maybe I go
Knight D4 is that possible my idea is to
just put the Knight on C6 and try to do
97 something like that because now it's
getting out of hand if I move the Rook
there's some C2 or if I move my queen C2
is actually going to be some problem Oh
I have to move the rook and the queen so
we we have to watch out for C2 we know
that for a fact that pawn is very
annoying and it's uh defended by this
bishop here this could be very bad in a
few moves for Jew she's not careful
yeah and as James saying Rook C8
followed by C2 you win this bishop the
pawn promotes and the black goes up in
exchange with probably a checkmating
attack so uh this is a critical moment
Jew and June down under a minute on the
clock she is not happy on position I
like your instinct James to bring the
Knight to C6 that of course would
threaten the fork but also would try to
bring this Knight to E7 and go after the
black king so will she retreat with
Knight D4 sometimes you have to take a
step backwards to take two steps
forwards and that's what literally what
a knight does as it tries to go up to C6
and what's Mustafa gonna do he has time
to think James he has so much time wow
so much time of course you use it as a
piece here now if you're smart here
which Jew is incredibly smart she's
actually thinking on his time which you
should be doing just focus yes I know
it's his move but I'm thinking of every
move using your time so if you make a
move that I've already calculated and
Etc I can move it much faster I can make
the movements faster without much
thought because I uh I'm using your time
as well Queen D6 I thought was best as
well you had to do that I had to go
Queen D6 that's a great move bro yeah
he's playing he's not he's playing out
his mind now
it's gonna be hard to beat this man when
he playing out of his mind okay he's
definitely playing the greatest
yeah he's doing extremely well the only
chance that white has is to somehow set
up a blockade on the light squares and
that's what Jew and June is aiming for
but you see the eval bar oh goodness get
this off the board that's over that's
over yeah bring the knight in Knight
around town then go for this pawn and
you're just mopping it up now yeah
that's tough especially with 30 seconds
here and still got a four minute time
edge here I can take my time I can slow
this down was the problem in the last
game was his time he was completely
winning because he had no time because
he uh he got in trouble and lost
showing he's not just all bark he's got
bite as well and he's trying oh as soon
as I say that it seems like he has made
an accuracy but so did you enjoy let's
take a moment to analyze that she
doesn't have much time let's bring up an
analysis board because I'm confused what
just happened here Rook d8 was
apparently a mistake ah and the reason
why is Rook D4 you bring your Rook up to
active defense and attack and then this
Rook can slide in next and you have some
chance to survive yeah that's very nice
it's very nice
I'll just see that man that ain't chest
is hard Bishop F3 and this is
that's winning but where do we go
we got time to figure it out
hmm yeah I wouldn't be surprised if even
you know this trade wins there's no rush
that Bishop's not going anywhere so I
think that a player has uh seasoned as
mustafael Maz he'll make some kind of
improving move I don't know if it
eventually like F5 G5 G4 that feels like
a way to kick the bishop oh I love that
Rook B5 give me that pawn absolutely
Rick D4
thanks nothing cool no tactics
is every move you know it's actually a
snowball article
though
he's just gonna kick kick The Rook away
take the bishop take the D5 pawn and win
the game she's down to 18 seconds left
this is very bad news for the Shanghai
tigers and now Rook takes D5 this one is
over uh he's gonna take a second extra
pawn and then win the game so while uh
we know more or less that this one
should be in the bag Mustafa Almaz did a
throwaway of winning position in the
previous round look in the bottom right
Shu Yi is a man on a mission and
unfortunately Irene sukhander is in his
path and it's devastating it's
blistering let's Dive Right In there
because I don't think that this king is
much longer for the board
it was like a not a one-two punch it was
like a one two five punch
bam
look at that take on H3 she didn't even
take back because she saw that Queen is
about to land on H3 and go for the H2
Square so she goes Bishop D3 and then
Queen G4 offering the queen trade and
had to take it you had no choice because
after C4 uh what give me that Knight and
then you put C5 she just forget her
Knight was hanging I don't know that's
I don't know what happened there that
was like a brain fart maybe maybe
thinking too hard it was just yeah
because now she's down like two pawns
and the piece she's gonna get a piece
back maybe I say maybe because there
might be just a
threat against this King but at the very
least black is about to be three pawns
ahead so a very strange moment Irene
played well in game one against away Yi
but she just forgot her name H4 was
under attack I'm pretty positive that
you just forgot she overlooked it yeah
he overlooked it right because he's not
trying to trade Queens there and yeah
this is tough he backs the bishop up
with some devastating threats here of
Queen H1 G2 King E3 and then Rook check
nasty picking up the queen maybe
decisive material loss there everything
is pretty bad here for
or Irene after having a beautiful first
round not able to recover in the last
two here
sure he's a beast though I think once he
wins I've got a two and a half out of
three and he survived that Onslaught
that um ass and ready for him so this is
going to be a win for the Tigers that's
big news for them uh because we'll zoom
out of here it looks like Irene is
probably just going to lose this game in
a few turns because that game on the
bottom right good for the tigers look at
the top right also very good if not
winning for the Tigers so
it's coming back like that super GM
let's go into this board here because
James material count even and yet white
is completely winning look at this last
move one of those quiet little moves
hitting one Pawn why don't you just
defend that pawn oh because Bishop takes
G7 is a winning threat because your
Bishop wanna f8 is pinned gross and he
just wins a full pie and says this is GG
you're gonna have to play F6 first is
all fine gold tripping you can't play
that right never play F6 secondly the C6
Pawn is hanging you have to defend this
maybe you have to play King H7 which is
still losing C6 regardless for
absolutely nothing and it's played in
Queens only place E5 oh
that's sick oh my goodness
big weight and having a nice day he says
wow E5
what he could have taken this Pawn we
were both looking at Queen 66 probably
just winning anybody's E5 and does it in
no time
move now we're taking on C6
yeah
if Paul takes Bishop C5 anyway that was
the whole point trying to pry open this
diagonal to win the bishop 108 behind
the queen on E7 that's sick that was
sick now he can take on Eve oh yeah I
still have Bishop C5 but they're here to
check down whenever that check doesn't
matter
he has Queen H4 Queen F no we don't
Bishop defends that too yeah we're good
yep that's what he was
you're trying to get this checkmating
attack the bishop on C5 defense nope not
there defense here so Rook takes f8 lean
check you just block it with G3
is GG you can hit the button my guy
button to resign yeah
well the uh stars have aligned for the
Shanghai Tigers it was not a good start
for them but now they're just winning
all of their games they seem like they
are on a mission for just destruction of
the Bulldogs man I mean especially after
that first like match the round you're
like wow them Bulldogs is like I'd
rather have a bulldog more than a tiger
like that's crazy
now like is now the Tigers starting to
show their teeth and the big paws and
this and the strength and the speed that
tigers usually have
check if F6 that looks like a good check
to throw in there it's gonna lead to
mate oh that's mate King G5 Bishop E3
is mate resignation happens nasty win
for Wei yeah that was a sick man that
was very sick was he like sitting on the
floor
you're like sitting on the floor playing
then he went to go check his phone the
laptop let me check some files
yeah he's like sitting
I think he was but he might be checking
on his teammates and it looks like in
the top left uh Mustafa ilmaz took that
one home against Jew and June in the
bottom right
still completely winning against Irene
secunders let's go to the anti-sarge's
game against Lou yaping because we just
saw a trade of Bishops and it's bottom
left of your screen here black is
actually up upon James I wasn't doing an
account and but we just saw Irene
sukhander has thrown in the towel
against chuyi but look at this game it's
an end game but white has only 13
seconds and black is up a pawn well
these are the hardest in games of course
this is like devaresky the one that you
the chapter you don't even read because
like it's ridiculous you don't really
get these minutes you don't get the
queen and palm one is like you you don't
spend a lot of time in that one but you
spend a lot of time in like the three
Pawn in game chapters for the four
pawning game chapters in the three Rook
this one is is not it's hard even though
he has on but actually that's his pass
he has a pass one so this one could be a
little bit difficult but most times
these are draws most times
we're seeing a draw just because the
king went up to King couldn't escape
just a show really quick even if you go
to F5 the queen can say get back to G6
and go back and forth so the draw was
inescapable uh that point is split
between Auntie Sarge and Lou yaping I
think Shanghai will be happy about that
and that means that round three is in
the books and it's another round Victory
where the Tigers James
they get the job done for the Tigers
Mustafa ilmas he said hey I'm Gonna Come
Out Swinging I'm going to bounce back he
wins his game against Jew and June and
board three was a uh for Croatia true
board four for the tiger so James more
Shanghai absolutely Shanghai is uh
definitely has the high prices right now
they are one and a half away from
clinching the match after starting down
three games I think in the first round
so definitely it shows that the marathon
here is it's not a short race thing this
can be you know it had every match every
match counts every game counts every
second countdown they are very close to
clinching the match Bulldogs gonna have
to pull up a huge upset in this last one
yep seven to five in favor of the
Shanghai Tigers the players will get to
reset relax for just a moment maybe do
some quick preparation but when they
return the Bulldogs they have to come
out and play for victory they are down
two points in his protesting match James
and I will be right back for the fourth
and final round of action here at this
Pro chesting match between the Croatian
Bulldogs and the Shanghai tigers
thank you
I have three puzzles here yeah I thought
it's gonna be much easier than this okay
I get the warm up yep 10 seconds all
right and let's see this one but um
yeah that's pretty straightforward I
think
yeah that's I mean it's obviously uh
Bishop D2 King A5 or K3 Bishop A4 Queen
takes B7
it is not it's not I'll give you a
second try
really and also five seconds if you want
to look at 40. no I I don't need to I
didn't ah because there's there's a rook
G3 truck that I missed this this is true
um okay just give me one side let me
think about this
yeah I'm not gonna get it without
actually thinking so you can just tell
me what it is okay it is uh Queen to F3
first
okay okay yeah I was I would have had to
think for like a couple of minutes to
get back that's that's that's actually
pretty tricky
yeah I think I found it completely
it is not Bishop D2
okay let me try again I know the
position is
okay
this one is going to be more
of course
so I'm thinking about Queen F3 right now
I'm not sure Bishop takes and it's and
only damage of D2 so that there is no
Rook G3
yeah okay I would stay with queen of
three in the first move and after we
should take the Premiership details for
sure
Diamonds the beautiful one yeah yeah
you're you're nailing this one
ah okay okay I think um I think I this
one I I have
I think it's from the Community First
and membership did so because it Bishop
D2 there is true G3
inside the queen g38g or enough the
bishop did anything
oh Canasta may be better because I just
deflect the bishop as well
yeah Queen after Bishop of three Bishop
yes that's the one perfect yeah we know
three was like yeah
I guess Bishop D2
King A5 or K3 chip
unfortunately Bishop D2 doesn't work
because we've worked to G3
rt3 so Queen F3 first yes okay Queen of
the reverse yeah perfect
foreign
nope
that's not meat not quite it is a queen
ah oh it's a queen move
oh Queen Esther yeah it's queen of three
day after Bishop takes after Bishop D2
uh yeah yes exactly
interested in becoming a chess streamer
like your favorite creators such as
Hikaru Gotham chess and the botan
sisters come
this
chess.com is excited to announce the
community streamer program
whether you're just getting started with
streaming or already established and
looking to expand your audience you can
now connect your account to chess.com
and have your stream promoted on the
game's largest platform
simply link your account at chess.com
settings slash connected accounts set
your category to chess on Twitch and
start streaming you'll get an ad free
experience on chess.com you will pop up
on our list of live streamers your
trust.com profile will feature your
Twitch stream
and your stream will be linked to your
games on our play server type command
Community streamer in chat and start
growing your stream today
and we return for the fourth round of
action between the Shanghai tigers and
the Croatia Bulldogs currently the
Tigers lead 7-5 and it's thanks to their
board one in no small part Grand Master
Wei Yi has been a super Grand Master
since he was like 14 years old actually
this right there on screen 15 years old
my apologies and heading into this match
he had a great record nine wins and only
two losses and the protest League games
number 29 iterated player in the world
the former Chinese Champion three years
in a row how good is this guy he's a
superstar right he's like the Superstar
you need for your team or like you know
when you're building a super team you
put him on the team okay give him the
ball type deal all the time right when
it comes down to it in the clutch
moments way Yi is an absolute Beast as
you see he's helping your team try to
clinch this match one more one and a
half
yeah the team just needs one and a half
more points as James said so let's look
at how the boards are doing for each
Squad because at the start it looked
like it would be a field day or the
Croatia Bulldogs they won the first
round three and a half to half and yet
the Shanghai Tigers shoo Yi on board
three James he's got two and a half out
of three he's leading the way oh really
look at that two and a half out of three
and like he's the the board three you
know when you're lower boards and this
is always about board three and four are
the most crucial one and two they're
gonna do their job that's why you got
them on boards one and two or sometimes
they don't do their job and they go one
and four but most times you put your
border one and two up there because you
know they're gonna do their job as board
one and board two four three and four
are sort of a toss-up in a way you hope
that they're stable down there or they
can you know blanket go three and four
three out of four two and a half out of
three like it is right now you see Julie
definitely helping carry the team with
Wei up here the yeast are going crazy on
the Shanghai Tigers right now two out of
three two and a half out of three and
then of course uh Lou at the bottom down
there that extra half point every half
Point ounce right now so everybody's
contributed
for a shirt or two is struggling for
both sides and well it's the fourth and
Final Round which means that you get the
same boards or each Squad matching up
and we see that mustafael Moz board one
takes on Wei Asif durability or two it's
the white pieces against chew on June
and then Shanghai gets the white pieces
on the bottom two boards James I ask you
this question time and time again would
you rather have white on the top boards
or the bottom boards if you're the
Shanghai tigers and only need one and a
half points well right now you know what
I'm actually looking at the Bulldogs I
think the Bulldogs have a slide pool in
this one having white on the top two
boards and of course black on the bottom
two a lot of times sometimes when you're
on your backs against the wall you're
playing it with Black 2 as well we just
saw Mustafa win real quickly with the
benoni there right so with the black you
know I think it definitely can uh switch
and make something swing in your favor
I'm gonna give it to the Bulldogs this
round but they already got they need
three points you know at three and a
half or do it but two points to tie it
up so we'll see what happens
if we do get a three point to one finish
in this round for the Bulldogs it means
we get tie breaks we love a good old tie
break and that how does that work the
round four pairings they are the
opponents play each other once again
with the colors being switched but the
Tigers they want a part of that they
want to win this in regulation we see
weigi playing a nimso Indian and queen
turning into a Queen's Gambit decline
where okay we have a semi Taurus James
do you like this opening for black not
really because uh when you go well I
like the fact that you know that there's
an in-game that can happen very very
quickly where your you know exactly what
you want to do as black and you get the
two pawns versus one I mean it's just
very boring very boring now these lines
I'll take because there's isolated Pawn
you can play for more and like you know
the pieces on the board
and I think perhaps that's what
mustafael Moss is thinking about because
what James is talking about E4 is often
played in this position it's becoming
increasingly popular and just to show if
we can analyze for a second oh wait a
minute analyze it's going to happen you
don't need any analysis right everything
I'm about to say is here you take this
bishop the pawn takes back uh you're
gonna lose his E4 Pawn eventually and
black claims that once some trades
happen and the pieces are fully
developed even though white has the pair
of Bishops it's not that big of a deal
and black has a very high draw rate in
this position so Wei super Grand Master
super well prepared he is not afraid to
enter this end game position because he
has more time than he started with
absolutely he's also like yeah he's
playing for the team this is a team
player here I just want to be solid you
know get your pieces off the board don't
make sure you don't have anything
aggressive and hold you hold this to a
draw I'm fine with that because it's for
the team in every half Point counts and
once we have a draw there all we would
need is one out of the three and we we
going to the ship right we go into the
championship we'll cross the playoff
here but that's what we call it right we
go into the ship so we'll be feeling
good if we're able to clean up here so
that's a pretty nice choice here I think
nothing too aggressive or or crazy just
something very solid get pieces off the
board and two for two results
you said we'd go into the ship and I was
just thinking of Hardball in the
Cucumber so that was a Keanu Reeves uh
reference I didn't expect to make on
this show uh but I wonder if uh way Yi
has seen that movie
oh man
um well uh you know we'll see what
happens in this one other games are
starting so let's go to our bird's eye
view just to catch them in their opening
phase we see in the top right still
early stages between vasif durability
and Zhu and Jun only one Pawn on the D
file has been traded and the bottom left
hey anti-sarin saying my team needs me
to win let's get a sicilian I'm feeling
that bottom left board James I think
that it's a good call by sarich I'm
always a fan of a sicilian I'm always
like every Sicilian like what's the city
like at this point I was like you know
what I like Sicilian because I played a
lot of them at this point and everyone
almost and I like night or is probably
the favorite obviously but definitely
loving some Cecilia's this was like a
con sometimes
or some type of Hedgehog type but
definitely Khan like and I do like this
for both sides here the problem is black
is definitely the one with the space
issues and white a lot of times can just
attack you F4 G4 G5 like everything he's
going with the moroxie line set up so
very solid
I'm guessing he's influenced by the
match score because as James was saying
you could instead of playing F3 you're
gonna put the pawn F4 but he's just
creating a pawn chain saying if you're
gonna beat me and your team needs you to
win you're gonna have to do something
absolutely crazy uh typically black
looks the strike with the move D5 in the
event that move is played I'll just show
like let's say Rook C1 D5 white will
take once and then play E5 so you get to
keep this healthy Pawn in the center you
see the evaluation bar going all the way
up a black position is terrible with the
King side being open and I come into F5
maybe the pawn to E6 you don't try this
at home so uh D5 has to be timed
correctly It's always important in this
maroxy bind Hedgehog structure so James
uh what's your experience like in these
setups I always love them from White's
perspective yeah I actually do too as
well I used to play I used to play The
Accelerated Dragon quite often I
actually picked it up in 2015. I
actually had one of my first Grandmaster
draws over the board Drew kajra Dennis
or Davis with uh with uh the celery
Dragon but he actually the maroxy vine
is the one that you hate to paste you
hate to face it all ideas are the same
white just always this is better they
have more space and it's just a harder
to play there are new newer ways to play
it now I think nordebec actually plays
more of the queen V6 lines and forcing
you to do like very weird things
different but it's still white has a
just a space Advantage C4 and E4 you
can't really play D5 if you do get D5 in
and it's a problem actually like you
have failed as white so if you do get D5
in and they can play it correctly you
failed here but white usually is the one
with most of the space the problem
though I do remember from Roxy Pine
structures that once you get the
position with white once you get the
ideal position a lot of times you just
kind of sitting and waiting like you're
just waiting because you have done
everything you can do to get a great
position and now you're just trying to
wait for black to make website
it's true white continues to make
advances and then you can't really get
any further up the board and H5 played
by anti-sarge I'm familiar with King h8
and try to play for G5 right but H5 less
familiar to me he probably wants H4
maybe we'll put his Knight behind the
pawn over there on H5 and try to control
some of these dark squares because of H3
meets H4 then the G3 square is black for
the taking all right I'm in into it just
because black has to win this game or at
least find some victories across the
four boards what was that this reminds
me of that game with uh the one for
Magnus I actually just had to do a chess
con video but uh for that with Kuryakyn
Magnus 2016 where you see the queen H6
check but this this was similar a
Kuryakyn win for the H5 H4 H3 and then
ended up uh Magnus ended up taking the
pawn at some point and opening the G
file so H5 H4 H3 is probably some type
of possibility I mean I'm really not
sure what he's doing with this age spot
but that boy but you know what maybe
he's connecting me with light Square
Bishop like a long-term plan could be
like pushed upon all the way down and
you're trying to open up the diagonal so
maybe you could move the Knight and play
F5 this is a long shot removing the F
Knight and playing F5 to open up the
bishop but the H Pawn is softening the
the the base of the pawn chain GF GF
yeah no it's true that if you can get H3
and all of a sudden White's Pawn
structure does not feel perfectly
healthy and the Roxy bind usually gives
black no activity black wants some form
of it and he says yeah get out of here
I'm gonna try to go in line with this
Pawn H4 now H4 is still possible you
don't want to take because then your
queen gets Exposed on this diagonal if
your knight takes E4 black would be very
happily snatching the pawn the center
but sarich is playing quickly he's using
the clock as a weapon James you've
talked about this more than pretty much
anybody that is a piece too the time
absolutely and he's been doing great job
with his time right now 95 I'm a big fan
of this move 95 maybe it goes back
around the G6 in many cases here you
even can break with D5 at the right
moment it seems like it's not ready yet
but I do like that he's advancing his
pieces you can't get the B5 break in
either
we move ap7 a little maneuvering you
can't play F5 yet
even the other night to C5
you know Knight C5 Bishop H4 perhaps
induce G3 that's your whole goal of
trying to bring this Pawn to the board
is to push this Pawn away from G2 so I
like the way oh H3 what a move not one
that came to mind immediately Knight C5
it looks like a fight so while this one
continues they're jockeying for position
let's zoom out because the Croatia
Bulldogs they need to score three points
just to send this into overtime in the
top left it looks like way ye has
neutralized any opening advantage and
Mustafa ilmas could have dreamed of in
the top right Massif durabelly against
Jew one Jun uh that one still looks
early stages and in the bottom right we
have an iqp so you Liu yaping with the
white pieces trying to play against the
pawn but Irene sukhander James we know
how dangerous she can be she loves
attacking chess I actually think that
it's a good decision I Irene in the
bottom right to play in this style play
against uh play with the iqp get the
open lines and try to go after the white
king eventually absolutely very
aggressive player I do like this
especially when you have the iso Pawn if
you can get D4 in or oh it'll get to
pieces to play around the pieces and
around the isolate economy with the
pieces and you could get some attacking
chances you need to attack and limit the
trade so Bishop D3 it's not a move I'm
looking at at all I would rather go
Bishop E6 or maybe 94 maybe but yeah
something the E4 Bishop before but we're
not looking to trade it with a bishop D3
we want to trade on our own terms and
the bishop takes E4 we might take with
the pawn and okay we're not uh how about
well I think we have to take it upon
unless we just lose D5 so we uh we
undouble our undouble un isolate our
Pawn because now we have to act on
health a little bit but I'm not looking
you know I'm not a big fan of this
because I'm trading queens and you know
I want I need to win right so like
that's right I'm interpreting James
Canty correctly okay she played Bishop
D6 I thought this uses like Queen E7
just avoid the queen trades keep some of
the tension alive uh yeah I don't mind
this decision but it might drop a pawn
now that I'm thinking about it what if I
take honey for brand of an analysis
board really quickly uh whoa okay Louis
ping is a very solid player I think he
missed a quick tactic after Knight takes
E4 it looks like you're walking yourself
into a fork that's no good who wants to
lose a piece but Bishop takes F6 it's
the queen on d8
just give me this Pawn E4 extra Pawn
appreciate it
thank you
that's pretty good I think he just met I
think he played too quickly James he's
using the clock as a weapon but maybe it
was weaponized against himself here yeah
of course as he wants to uh he wants to
keep the business which I understand
play against his isolated Pawn maybe put
the Knight on D4 and play Queen D4 Rook
D1 literally playing Super Quick and a
play principled I mean moves that you
don't even have to think about I don't
have to take I keep the tension as it
most Grandmasters say right in the
Knight D4 Queen D4 Rook D1 Queen D2 Rook
D1 or of course I have to move the
Knight though I don't want Bishop F3 to
happen but definitely gonna play on this
pawn and now we have a trade and we we
have a concession this is what he wanted
we've traded neither the pawn is even
weaker
yeah and if Rook takes B1 well the rook
and C8 will happily send the open file
and Knight takes B1 is not out of the
question it opens up the bishop and
makes the more natural looking move of
Rook takes I think that this will
continue to be a fight I mean seriously
this Pawn D5 not hanging because if you
think your Queensland on D5 well there
was a check on H2 she said I don't even
need to worry about that let me line my
queen and Bishop up and go for some sort
of Checkmate thread so I think that this
one both players have their chances here
so we'll leave them to it because uh the
Croatia Bulldogs they just need
victories at this point they need to
score three total points at minimum so
let's look at how Irene's teammates are
doing because they got off to a great
start and they'll need an equally good
ending just to stay in this match but
James look at the bottom left
yeah oh look at that move E5 we gotta go
we gotta go look at that game there is
some spice there's some spice in that
game a real big side of spice
auntie sarich and E5 just played the
queen is in line with the Rook The Rook
almost always wins that Showdown James
this is looking very very problematic
for Sarge absolutely that E5 breaks
everything up there I mean H4 is kind of
loose okay so now here come the tactics
what do we have or we just win the pawn
you just take it quick on H4
quite simple that's one way to do things
is there anything else maybe just you
also have Knight H4 you have Bishop G5
maybe yeah that's a move it's up to you
it's up to you like what do you want
says says YouTube
yeah so many options Bishop G5 is very
interesting James ideas if you take you
can maybe even throw in some politics
d6s
just take that yeah uh I feel like white
just spoiled for choice and sarge is
trying to use the clock to his Advantage
but the position's looking really tough
now for black
um just politics D6 pickup H4 as you
mentioned that seems like the easiest
decision but I actually just realized B3
is hanging I completely forgot about
that side of the board so you can't just
focus and get Tunnel Vision on the H4
Pawn it's actually right yeah that's
kind of annoying it just feels like I
can just mate him but if I do takes
Bishop takes Queen H4 Knight B3 Bishop
B3 don't care nothing about The Rook
let's just see what happens takes Knight
B3 Bishop D3 and it's not there nope
it's not there I was trying to go Knight
T5 next and then Bishop H7 but there's
not enough nope that would be nasty but
unfortunately this Knight on D3 here so
you uh you'll get to survive with all
your pieces so it's an interesting
attempt and he pulls a Canty he says let
me go Knight G5 his Queen F7 check has
to be on the radar and if you take I I
guess I'm realizing you can't take on D6
with Queen d8 will defend this piece
over here right um but or you can just
take on E3 even but just take take and
then H4 will drop and the king is open
absolutely there it is takes takes
and he takes okay so he got that pawn
yeah this isn't that easy for white
because B3 is hanging H7 is covered
wow we're Queen taste man that night on
f8 they say when a knight on f8 you it
won't be made there is no mate right
that's really crazy that's insane yeah
Knight B3 Queen X4 probably get in there
I know what the eval Bar says James but
I'm wondering if you agree with me don't
you feel like Sarge has good chances in
this game not that he's better but this
is the type of position you want when
you need to get a victory practical yeah
practical chances absolutely playing
against the player not the engine right
so yeah this is definitely practical I
mean both Kings definitely have their
their side of the share fair share
weaknesses and that I know f8 is an
excellent defensive piece it stops it
stops H7 and G6 they are both definitely
E4 I mean that's a signal oh sorry oh we
big fella he's swinging yeah he's
bringing the Knight up to G6 you point
out that square and look at how well
he's doing on the clock he is just
playing instantly and if you take a pawn
Knight G6 Knight E5 Knight D3 give me
that square the pawn E4 is super strong
I feel like black has taken over this
game absolutely I mean I definitely feel
that now you can feel the momentum shift
here because Knight g695 93 is great B4
might be some type of move here you
might just have to just hey you know
what get rid of this he took on H4 but
Knight G6 is with Tempo now so now we go
I guess back to F2
well it was a queen F4 instead that not
approved of buy uh the engines
Queen F2 but B3 is hanging I guess it
doesn't matter because after the queen
trade and you take on B3 The Rook slides
the B1 and down goes B6 at the end so uh
anti-stars it looks like he missed his
moment here by Leading with his Queen
rather than bringing the Knight out to
G6 yeah absolutely he's uh he's
definitely moving fast though I think
he's just really trying to keep that
clock Edge which he's just making
practical fast moves in fact is quick it
may not be the best but it's quick it
looks good okay cool keep the pressure
on him and then we'll maybe try to look
for uh or use our time when it really
needed in about two or three minutes
here and we're whereas you will have no
time left E5 I love that move you take
double my or undouble my Pawn snake yeah
it does give up the D5 Square so I would
be looking to hop the knight in but even
after a take take E3 please take me on
F4 and undouble the pawns as you were
suggesting so it's a crazy position uh
should we down to two minutes at 43
seconds it makes a mistake this is what
happens when you use the clock to your
advantage and now it's apparent the
Knight D3 you may be able to take but C4
is loose at the end of all these
variations wow Auntie Sergeant may be
getting Croatia back in this match oh my
goodness this is a big win if he's able
to now of course you actually was made
that Mustafa game it's nowhere near that
that Mustafa game he was getting crushed
she was but then time was not mustafa's
friend and we actually ended up getting
in time trouble and ended up losing that
game this could actually just flip here
you know there's more time for Auntie
here and less time for Zhu the position
is getting a little bit worse here
definitely worse now wow
okay well we will keep an eye on this
one but we do have to look at the other
boards because Croatia will not just
need this Victory if they can get it
they'll need a second and not to lose
any boards look in the top left Mustafa
yamas Down Under A Min on the clock he
is in some serious trouble but in the
bottom right I mean to Connor throwing
her pawns forward she's trying to
unleash an attack let's go to the game
between yamaz and Wei just because of
the clock situation and I think if you
are Mustafa you just need to find a way
to make a draw you are getting outplayed
you're down on the clock and as we dive
into the game here he's 20 seconds
what's he doing bro move you gotta move
Mustafa move stop calling calling
you know it's his turn I mean he's got
to go 10 seconds
you gotta move actually what's he oh man
oh but he plays a bad move so he spends
all that time and makes an inaccurate
choice I feel like black just double the
Rooks up rook B6 I was listening I was
actually thinking what is the move Rook
D6 yeah that looks great or Rook C7 C6
C5
pick your uh pick your choice but also
I'm realizing this Rook may swing to the
B6 Square that's what he's going for
he's going for the attack
okay now we just double oh something's
wrong here oh because the rook's coming
down the B6 as well but you found that
boy instantly
too strong is where you even stronger
yeah I found it it's over
A6 lights out oh okay I see him with a
little fist pump hey nice and a resi and
they only need half at points
wow look at the way they're monster or
the Shanghai Tire tigers
and where he gets the three out of four
on the day turns the camera off says
That's all folks and we're gonna get
away from this game because way he he
shows that he can get it done even after
a first round
oh look at that Irene was winning what
happened oh she had an advantage right
maybe not she did yeah she did but now
look at Louisa ping just saying uh what
advantage did you have my queen is up to
C7 and that's the problem with iqp
structures when you go all in on the
attack the foundation your position is
vulnerable so Irene
trying her best
against Lu ya ping but that's really bad
news let's go back how do we get here I
mean it felt like she had a nice attack
going what oh that's all you need it
though that's all they needed look at
him and he takes a drink of his soda
because that's all they I was like how
you agree to a draw here because it ices
the match he's got ice in his veins does
Lou yaping and he says I earned myself
that Coca-Cola right let me sit pinky up
pinky up gotta do it with the pinky up
yeah there it is uh-huh yeah it Flex
real hard we won smiling look at him I
see you big dog big Louie Big Lou look
at him
well that's it Lou yaping seals the deal
the Shanghai tigers have officially won
the match they're eight and a half two
five and a half and two games remain in
the top right Juan Jun that looks like
she has a pretty good position against
durability I mean that guy's been a
monster for the squad but Zhu and June
with the black pieces James this is like
a great position for her Bishop pair
activity everywhere and this King on G1
could find himself with some trouble
thanks as Bishop on C5 absolutely I bet
it was very strong there we can also
back it up to A7 and call that a snake
in the grass they're just bearing down
no matter what you can't really block it
unless I mean if you do you have some
structural damage that could happen if I
take on E3 if you try to block with the
Knight I also have G6 maybe even G5 play
H4 try to open the H file myself right I
have the D file to myself right now um
Black's just definitely for choice
dang I mean honestly you're paying such
a nice picture I'm like and you have to
look at the position to know how much
easier it is for Black to play so G6 if
Knight H4 James maybe G5 and H4 let's
open up uh this flank but where else can
this Knight go as you mentioned 93 you
can even take you have two sets of
double isolated pawns that's unappealing
and receive takes a bit of time and
brings that back to H4 absolutely brings
the night right to H4 here we may have a
queen G3 I mean a queen E5 to go Queen
yeah right take a queen G3 King H1 now
hmm and then it's rookie too that's
gonna slow down another thing yeah okay
so Queen G3 oh no that's a nice move
Knight E3 gotta go back to A7 or B6
whenever you like
I'm going A7 I'm taking your word for it
because just hiding away from White's
pieces and the queen takes G3 does
become a threat I think white needs to
play a move like King H2 but what's your
next move after that I feel like White's
very stuck here it is so King H2 is on
the board what does black do now great
question F5
King G7 waiting move
if F4 you take because you can't take
with the pawn because the H4 Knight is
loose if you could play F4 F5 all of a
sudden white would be in charge but not
so fast so I might apply F5 F4 might be
I think if I have four take take
I think that's an idea it is risky
how much time she got away this time
Scramble with territory
yes and Bishop Chief oh look at that
please take me open up the H file I'm
going for the kill we I love it and then
F3 of course in the concession in the
dark squares week you can't go King G1
three seconds but see you gotta go two
one four wow rookie one
okay
so we're going to trade Bishops we might
get a piece in there such a great
defender
I need that Knight over here right
to hop into G4 it might be right Knight
B8 97 out of six
just bring the Knight around
that's a long time though
somebody try to open the H final once
again
I'm thinking about H4 when my opponent's
five seconds left I don't know if it's
good but I want to play it she takes
because she is going for H4 H4 there it
is Queen G5 or queen F4
oh I gotta be on you my guy Queen F4 I
mean
[Laughter]
H3 was probably a move beforehand uh oh
actually it was but look at this give me
that those dark squares this Knight is
hopping around
take
oh my gosh
96. look at this speed speed speed
yeah
I think lights out oh she takes a step
back that's too slow she needs H3
even now
x3833
16 seconds
whoa I didn't even see the queen to go
to this side of the board I forgot the
queen could move like that wow
oh the night's out
that's not good for her she's allowing
him back in the game yeah time you
probably don't play a lot of fast chess
which is understandable
understandable yep yeah
working on classical a lot too 96 but
she has to take dark squared domination
right like take this bishop I dare you
because in the f
uck oh goodness H3
dang I was sick nice little Ring Around
the Rosie there wait wait take the Gucci
through check takes the queen G3 that's
it yeah she's gonna spot that boom
because
there it is
she takes it all it's a mate oh look at
the slap put a table oh man he picked oh
man hey don't don't oh man
oh man
see and look at you and June it's like
she doesn't even know the game ended
like she's still concentrated maybe
she's analyzing it but Drew and June
takes down vasif durability and I saw a
comment earlier about just how dominant
the Shanghai Tigers were after the first
round they lost three and a half the
current score is I believe it's nine and
a half to five and a half so Dave went
on nine to two oh my God over the last
11 game wow nine to two in the last 11
games there a lot this is a marathon
right you could win four oh basically
first match and it is not over yet until
it's over eight and a half wins it and
nine and a half got it today tiger first
eight and a half they already got it but
they said there's another game left
still
yeah well this one
we see it's uh a good old draw ending
the day with some peace between the
players and well for sure it means he
goes to three out of four on the day a
great performance uh for the board three
on the Tigers
yeah great performance here by the
Tigers period they're making it through
to the playoffs
they are and there's a lot on the line
for the Bulldogs they will have another
week to try to make the playoffs uh but
this game is officially done that wraps
up the match
10-6 and I almost feel like the score is
misleading because and that sounds like
a relatively close going to the last
round the Shanghai Tigers destroyed the
Bulldogs after the first round
everything went wrong for them and then
suddenly nothing could go go wrong and
you see it led by their top two boards
in that final round of action way Yi
with three out of four Shu Yi with a
very impressive three out of four on
board three and then even scores from
Jew and June and Louis ping
James all tigers I mean that's beautiful
my whole team went 50 and up you know
what I mean like 50 and up for the whole
team you got a squad like that you're
gonna make it to the playoffs and some
right that's amazing I mean three four
two four three four two four I mean
everybody contributed here everyone was
just as important especially the threes
there with a zoo and Wei ye both of them
just having a monstrous three out of
four there was able to take it I mean
that's just six points right there
between two of them you know so one
person you go oh four in the bottom four
and still win with the third board right
so great job from the Tigers here what a
team
as you said three is the key and that
was the third match victory for the
Shanghai tigers and they become the
third team to lock up a playoff spot so
we know three teams out of eight that
are going to make the playoffs it is the
yogis the knights and the Tigers how
about we will have another match coming
up after this one James because bottom
half of the standings they also matter
we have teams that may have
started poorly in the league but the
blitz for example Capybaras they square
off next and they get a victory today
and a victory next week they will sneak
in the playoffs absolutely the Brit the
blitz against the Capybaras today this
is a these are my favorite matches this
is where all the energy comes out from
everyone why because this is elimination
match somebody's going home it's either
it's gonna be a lot of aggressive chests
lots of upsets this and that nerve
psychology here everything times 10
because elimination you get sent home if
you lose today
yeah we have the Blitz and the Capybaras
coming up next of both these teams as we
just saw the standings they're one and
two they've got great logos James said
he might even get the blitz Tech logo
tattooed on his arm uh but James before
we head to break and get ready for this
match what do you expect absolutely uh
you know here the they both have very
strong teams here I'm more familiar with
the blitz so I do know that the blitz
have a very very strong team some
favorites that I liked over there myself
so I mean I'm very curious to see what
the blitz bring but I know the Brazil
copy Bears have you know are just as
good right they're one and two right
same score whatever that matchup looks
like I think it's very important to know
what does the matchup look like today
whatever that matchup looks like and if
they're feeling great then it's going to
go in their favor so we'll see what
happens
we will indeed and we just saw the
Shanghai Tigers take down the Croatia
Bulldogs Jew and June the Women's World
Champion is on that roster and well
there's a very important event coming up
that will determine who plays against
Jew and Jun uh because the women's
candidates finally come to an end on
Tuesday March 28th after taking down six
of the strongest women in the game
including the PCL Zone Katarina Lucknow
and Alexander castenuk Lee Ting Jae and
tan zhangi now Vie first seat across
from reigning women's world champion Jew
and June we'll bring you live camera
feeds and exciting commentary of the
match right here at twitch.tv chess use
the command candidates in chat for all
the details and it'll go anywhere
because while we take a break we reset a
whole nother match of the protesting
will get underway we'll be right back
for the start of the Blitz and the
Capybaras here in the Pro Chesley
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
the weight of a win draw or loss is all
on one's shoulders it's easy to feel
alone
those lonely Days Are Over oh my God
the pro chess league is back
once again in chess teammates matter oh
man oh my God what was that what do you
even do this is resign time welcome back
PCL
a unique collection of teams each with
their own personality of different
colors shapes and sizes there are gnomes
and nights sprawls and Bishops
and whatever the heck this is
the PCL is the only place where the best
players in the world risk their fate
alongside content creators and players
from different levels ages and
perspectives coming in and if white goes
C7 and that's it
we're hitting with a fist bump entering
its Fifth Season 16 teams will reboot
the PCL Legacy with a new format and new
schedule
only one team can be crowned the next
PCL Champion
oh my goodness what a save
my friends it's the 2023 Pro chess
League which team can Rise Above the
Rest they won't be able to do it alone
look at her on the screen she is killing
it today
and we are live for the second match of
today's pro chess link doubleheader it
will be the Blitz in the Brazil
Capybaras once again I'm Grandmaster
Robert Hess alongside me my good friend
James Canty III James we had an exciting
first match of the day what do you
expect to see in this one between the
Blitz and the Capybaras it's elimination
Robert it's elimination that's all I got
to say if you lose you go home so that
means you gotta win somebody's gonna win
today and somebody's gonna lose I don't
know who it's going to be but it's going
to be some great and exciting chess
today because they're facing elimination
you know a few things thus far in the
Pro chess League uh we know which teams
have already clinched their spot in the
playoffs as they bring up the standings
here you will see the three teams at the
top the Indian yogis the Gotham Knights
it took them three weeks to make the
playoffs the Shanghai Tigers joined them
today and on the other side of the
standings we're at the bottom uh we have
today's contestants competitors Blitz
and the Capybaras so James we saw one
team very happy as they made their way
to the playoffs the Tigers but now once
he will be eliminated so the Blitz the
capybara is you know what it's like your
team is right there in between them the
Garden State passers what are they
feeling right now of course every match
is facing elimination every week we like
you know what this could be our last so
we're gonna go out with a bang we bout
to go crazy right so that's how Brazil
and also Blitz this is why you're gonna
get some very exciting tests in these
rounds and people are really fighting
for their lives because this is actually
life or death like you can go home here
there's another like that's it the
team's over it's going to be a lot of
sad faces lots of emotions right today
on these games so it's a lot of emotion
a lot of Psych a lot of getting pumped
up lots of good games team camaraderie I
mean elimination is a bad thing but it
also brings out the best in a lot of
people and we don't see that today
yes no elimination uh pushes you're back
into the wall from the very start and
well there are teams with great
experience particularly the blitz
because they are spearheaded by the
super Grand Master Duo the one-two punch
of Alexander grishook and Maxime vashar
legrov so James they need an MVP
performance out of mvl and so far he's
been solid this year is seven wins three
draws or losses but they also have
Kettering luck no I mean she and
Alexander grashook they're a married
couple and they also are very strong
Grandmasters capable of taking down
anybody absolutely that's a strong Squad
you got a grishek and MBO and you guy
lagno there we and then the people in
between there by Crow right a voyers
there yeah the brick roll oh I didn't
even know there was a brother there wow
that's insane the whole team is stacked
there right so the blitz is definitely a
force we reckon where everybody in PCO
is of course two 2700s on the team how
can you go wrong especially if you're
using both of them like in an
elimination match oh yeah every week
we're going to use the best of the best
that we can
yeah they have been using those super
gems week after week and they have from
top to bottom the roster strong players
but it has not gone their way thus far
uh and a team that had more of a
middling roster a balanced roster as the
Brazil capybara's because the blitz
their top heavy Brazil earlier in the
season they're relying on their 2600 uh
South American players like Sandra
morenco Luis uh supi Jose Martinez but
they brought in the top dogs James they
brought an artemia earlier in the season
they also have hike mortuosion if they
ever want to bring him in he's nearly
2700 and we know how good he is at rapid
and Blitz chess I believe he won the
bronze medal at the recently concluded
World Blitz Championship so when you
look at this roster with their team
captain and manager being quicker
mechatar and our good friend what do you
think can they Stave off elimination
absolutely I think the problem here is I
think they're evenly messed and like the
both teams are it just depends on who
and how the matchups are going to be and
how they favor you know in these fast
time controls and if fast time controls
somebody that's very underrated that
they don't talk about a lot is artemia
in the faster time control I mean 3 100
online 3K plus commonly always hanging
with Hikaru in the likes of Hikaru and
people that's strong even in his uh PCL
so far he's been doing great I mean I
think he won three I don't know if he
won all four games or he went like three
out of four something like that he had
an outstanding performance something
that you would see from artemio so of
course we're looking to see you know
more of that from him they brought some
other players uh as well soupy is really
nice I know they have um Morocco too
Sandro today and I'm not sure Julie I'm
not too familiar with but a lot
um a lot goes with that fourth board
hopefully we can see a lot from the
fourth board today um like we saw in the
last matchup as well
yeah well you mentioned uh the board
orders let's bring them up let's let
everybody know who is taking part in
today's match between the Blitz and the
capybarros you see it on the screen now
we have grishook and Maxine vashilagrove
super GMS for the blitz then we have
artemiev a super GM of their own says
the Capybaras and Mariko supi they're in
there the 2600 Bunch get any luck no uh
probably the highest rated women player
in the entire league and then on board
four Julia Alvarado she's outrated she
will be in every game James and Mahal
Boyer he's been impressive in the PCL
three wins four draws three losses which
means he has an even record and if
you're doing that from the fourth board
that spells trouble for the opposing
teams that actually is pretty strong
meme I have a sort of fourth board shoot
you give me probably have some upsets in
there he has some draw definitely some
upsets drawing and then Etc wow that's
actually I didn't know that about the
stat there so he's incredibly underrated
here so Julie is definitely up
um for a a uphill battle here but at the
same time I mean you know you're on the
PCL team and a lot of the camaraderie
like team oh my team's strong you just
be fine to move sometimes I don't know I
just played out of my mind well you also
wear an elimination match and you didn't
you know you just kind of blacked out
when it could happen that way as we see
even Alice Lee has had a great
performance there being born for and
beaten um literally a blue bomb in the
first round absolutely phenomenal so too
many phenomenal chests today though
especially with this elimination match
happening in a few minutes and you're
mentioning hope for it fours we just saw
Irene sucondo take down way Yi so the
board Force sometimes do upset the
opposing teams board one and those are
the matchups that we start with the most
lopsided matchups happen in the first
round and as we see on the screen in
front of us Julia Alvarado she gets the
white pieces against Alexander gristook
I mean if she can score a half point in
that game the Cappy bars will be over
the moon and Mahal Boyer he gets the
white piece against artemiev that rating
differential not quite as big but still
substantial and Boyer with white or
Tammy with black I mean James look at
those middle two boards for me that
that's what usually the protest league
is about we celebrate our super GMS we
root for The Underdogs on board four but
in board two and board three that's when
they're in the trenches and look at this
first round matchup maximum black
against soupy kind of even luck know
white against Mariko what is this uh one
of the best tournaments in the world ah
really right like that's crazy because
they are fighting each other in the
middle like that that's like man that's
hard to choose there yeah and I thought
I thought this was an evenly like even
match to be honest I really thought
these guys were uh kind of like neck and
neck looking at them at the uh the
lineups here like one could take this
one but then you have these guys that
could take them so in this matchup right
now based off colors I am actually gonna
edge with the blitz slightly slightly
with the blitz I see Grisha up there at
first board there he's supposed to I
mean he's technically supposed to win
quotation marks right based off his
rating but Julia it could definitely
bring it bring it to him and then uh mvl
there Katarina lagno having white to
white and then white again down there I
think Blitz has a slighted
okay James you're calling it uh the
blitz with a slight Edge they also have
the rating Advantage I reminded
everybody that in the Pro chess League
every single team has to abide by the
regulations uh that means that in this
format where you play everybody on the
opposing team uh the time Patrol If you
haven't been watching the pro chess
league is one where you have 10 minute
plus two second increment and we had up
to four rounds of action so at most we
get four rounds because the team that
gets the eight enough points ends the
match in their favor and well the teams
need an average rating of 25.50 across
the four boards but there are certain
exceptions and how it works because
players above 2700
they count as 2700 encourages teams that
the very best players in the world on
the roster and then uh their top women
if you're above 23.50 you still count as
23.50 against the cap that's why having
Kettering luck know is such a great
thing but Brazil they're gonna rely on
Julia Alvarado she gets the white pieces
against Alexander grishook in the first
game that is going to go underway and
she looks ready is that a little stuff
there behind her over there yeah a
little little stuff there right you know
it might be all nice and cute but you
get on the board she'll destroy you
right so you know don't let that fool
you there nice little bear in the
background but ready to do some
destructive damage on the board and I
think I recognized uh you know the ID
that's hanging up on the shelf behind or
maybe from the Olympiad you know you
have to have a player identification
card to get into the uh playing venue so
this game is about to lift off she's had
great experiences in her past she wants
her future to be just as bright and if
she could take down Alexander grishook
that would spell disaster for the blitz
but the Capybaras they'd be jubilant
absolutely got to be very jubilant here
as she looks very ready to go look at
her right ready to go here and I think
that is I saw the mouse and on Mouse is
that clock running
not yet okay they're both ready though
grishek's ready to go
yeah but Grisha always looks ready you
know James every time I've ever seen him
he looks like he's about to buckle down
and go into a fierce battle and right
now we see a King's Pawn game E4 uh E5
and are we gonna Spanish are we gonna
get Italian let's see on Julian says
that question
the tally this was C5 you know all the
same stuff let's see how which route she
goes to slow Italian
the problem is James that for Julius she
really just wants to make a draw if she
can find a way but in these positions
there's no like
Perpetual check no repetition no Queen
trade that allows you to make a standard
and easy draw you have to work for it
every move and grashook right now he's
spending some time because he wants to
come up with a challenging variation he
does not want her to feel comfortable
this early in the game so don't be
surprised if he throws in a random move
at some point like H6 just to make her I
think is he gonna play G5 but yeah you
normally play D6 you play A6 you play H6
at some moment uh of course developing
this Knight is recommended as well so
for sure he's got to find a move but he
loves time trouble he does like he just
sits to like oh I got too much time let
me like look around let me just like hey
what's hey bring me some lunch yeah like
just like you know he always in time
trouble but plays Knight F6 here Bishop
Chief I
um G5 lines we just kind of looked at
this with uh Dora Bailey H6 G5
yeah I'm wondering if we'll see
something like that again uh but it
didn't work out for durability when he
sacrificed the Knight on that square I
don't think that she will you know copy
that because uh that did not work out at
all and
she's thinking here after black Castle
you could play C3 but because you
haven't committed you can also bring
your knight to C3 and try to hop that
pony into D5 so both options are viable
yeah Knight C3 looks really good you
also have the C3 option you have H3 uh
you can even go even really aggressive
and obviously try to cast a clean side
here but this is not this is a
completely different game casting King
side yep going to Natural route Bishop
E7
definitely he wants to make it a game
I'm gonna be the James candy translator
interesting means like what you doing
big fella what was this bishop E7 I mean
I think he's just trying to play it
calmly because he doesn't want to see
any sacrifices on G5 he feels like as
the game continues he can outplay her he
does outright through the Alvarado by
about 500 rating points that's a really
significant Gap there so I think he's
just trying to get a position that she's
not familiar with and then go after her
so while she thinks is when we go to our
bird's eye view because I think one game
that is underway will be one that you
are happy to see so as we look at that
our boards here look in the top right
soupy throws a pawn up to G4 and MPL as
he always does plays in night org yeah
we gotta go see that right now first off
I love the night off myself secondly
it's a Pawn on G4 and I love a Pawn on
G4 absolutely love it love it let's see
which Knight Arthur was which one how
did we get here okay just to go through
the moves yeah okay so we had
in early E5 kicking the night out and
then that means that the D5 Square
becomes whites for the taking and very
quickly the Knight did hop into D5
eventually Maxine took and we see a
position that is not perfectly balanced
we have a bishop pair for white we have
two knights for black
semi-open file on the C file semi-open
file in the e-file though it's very
clogged and then the kings are in the
center so James where are those Kings
going if anywhere you know it's funny
the night or King it either go to f8
sometimes d8 it's it's just gonna sit
there it's going to chill somewhere
sometimes we could Castle but if you you
need to be so short when you Castle
because if you Castle you can get made
in like three or three moves immediately
made it or at least going to lose some
material so you gotta be very careful
where's the white king going yeah I can
still Castle Queen side ranking V1
really get out of there you know your
dark Square Bishop isn't that powerful
yet so actually I still like to play
White in these positions because I'm
cool with like where my king is on E1 or
even F1 but I'm also cool with black
here to do the same this is very very
double legs I love that stuff yeah and
if you know James is he's answering the
question it's just that difficult
because uh if you go to the queen side
ever for white then you might find B5
and this is going to be an attack for
black uh if you go to the Kink side well
why do you just played G4 that doesn't
seem to work together very well so I
feel like for white I'm just throwing my
Pawn to H4 you say A you say B you say G
you say h H4 followed up with a G5 in
the near future and go for the black
king absolutely it's looking very good
for those movies
yeah okay so that's that really matters
so it's White's move honestly
push up on the H4 what you gonna do
about H4
I mean that's the file logical follow-up
I mean you can also do this what they
call it freak attack in the night or
eight where you go Rook G1 very early
and then plus G4 looks very freak
attack-ish H4 Rook G1 G5 and then go G6
there's a Pawn on G6 gonna be very no
there it is I understand yusuke I
understand
he famously won that game against Magnus
Carlson that Blitz game with the fishing
pole uh that was really something and he
wants to take down another Super GM but
Mexico one of the best prepared players
on the planet also one of the easiest to
repair against because he plays the same
thing over and over and over so James I
think that makes us happy if we see
night ORS today how are we going to
complain right unless yeah exactly I'm
gonna love it I'm gonna learn something
too as well and also I think his
philosophy there is I'm gonna keep
playing it because not only I can you
know learn a lot more from this and also
if you prep and you you know you catch
me instant prep that's something I can
add as well because the night off is not
refuted so it is uh it's nice that he
plays these things over and over we can
learn from our from his uh from his
games as well very nice
look at that Queen out to A5 uh maybe
this King will land on d8 but G5 not
available that's a key point because
after Pawn takes unfortunately this Pawn
H4 can't capture back as the Rooks will
have a standard on the H final so black
does have that one tempo to survive and
for white maybe it's bringing this King
around to the G2 Square slow and steady
and then go for G5
yeah you're right you're right King
everyone's night because you don't want
to sit here there's there's like all
kind of and there's tactics maybe not
now yet but you don't want to sit in
this pin like you just don't want to be
there so yeah King F1 makes total sense
casting would be crazy yeah there it is
King F1 just get out the way
get out the way
it does and so uh well there's going to
be an attack on this board that is clear
so James I asked you before has your
mind changed if you come to any new
conclusions where is black skin going uh
you know what maybe d8 d8 at some point
D.A what is his hand his hands going up
I wonder what Envy I was thinking what
width of his mind is then it was more
like a what bro or like like what did
you do I don't know he thought
definitely thought something so I
thought went through his head I was
curious to see what that was there yeah
where is he maybe he thought the same
thing where's my king going like where
do I put my Kingfish we need to figure
that out actually and I think it's just
safe where it is right now
because you got to do some serious
calculation Coe right now if you castle
castle might be just G5 and lights out
yeah no I think that's too too easy I
think that this position is already
getting so dangerous that if White had a
free turn and then played G5 I think
White's already almost objectively
winning so I think black might have to
make some kind of crazy move like B5 and
this the problem is that there's a queen
here so when you take back the queen and
the bishop protect the pawn like you're
just sacrificing a pawn but if you get
to this D5 Pawn then it will make sense
otherwise well you're in some big
trouble
I was trying to get E4 to work actually
in many cases and upon E4 and put the
other Knight on E5 so that's the usual
idea that you get in some night off
lines but the bishop defense well maybe
you can go E4 but then he takes takes
they should have six and c4's hanging
that might be a thing E4 94 95 Knight F6
Bishop F6 you move the queen and then
you know it might be a thing
yeah I think the problem here is that
the queen can go to school like F5 for
example or E4 two yeah yeah yeah with
Tempo and then G5 is coming in the near
future and you're not quite quick enough
to get to C4 but James's point is really
really well taken everybody just to show
an instant replay that E4 is a common
idea where you say here you know what my
position is rough I'm passive take some
material so that's your new Advantage
instead of activity it's material a
black just quickly puts pieces into
better places so I'm with you James I
think that mvl might already be looking
at moves like that ideas like that to
get going with this position because
what are these Superfluous Knights doing
what's this bishop on E7 behind a pawn
and a knight doing the answer is all of
nothing and White's just two moves away
from crashing through this is scary like
sometimes this is like when you when you
don't want to play the night over but
then when you see a great night off you
like that's why I played a night or like
everybody stands behind it and then you
see this this saying like nah I don't
play tonight or if you play that now
yeah
okay we found a move here
okay so Queen going somewhere do not
take this Knight that's pretty clear you
don't want to hand over the dark squares
so this Queen's gonna move somewhere I
like Queen F5 just because maybe Maxine
will forget his work singing or not see
it
uh yeah I mean this is all day I'm
taking white I'm not even gonna lie and
I love a knight or Sicilian but this one
just feels all in White's favor every
piece looks good for me my King's off of
the diagonal Queen F5 and we live that's
the tempo big fan of the tempo myself
there it is love getting the tempo in
Tempo gains that time you need to make
another move
yep so we're hitting the Rook on C8 you
still don't want a castle that will
connect the Rooks but get your king
checkmated after G5 so I do not envy
this uh defensive task for Maxime and
while he is getting down under five
minutes no he says no I'm not going
under five 503 for him but King G2 with
G5 to follow still looks very dangerous
I'm gonna take our attention away from
this one just because all four games are
in session we're just looking at the
game in the top right in the top left it
looks like Alexander grishook and the
Alvarado pretty interesting position
where grishook with the black pieces has
a pair of Bishops uh in the bottom left
early stages between Lucknow and Rico
but reiko's position looks great with
black much more activity and the bottom
right Mahal Boyer against
vladislavartambia that one really is
yeah
all right let's go to
artemiev and Boyer because James sounds
like you're happy about the Triangle
Pawn structure uh where artemiev with
black in the bottom right he's got those
light Square pawns uh out there like a
pyramid I'm curious to see what he does
with this too because I actually have
played this from both sides I actually
like playing it from White's point of
view I do like the best along to the
long diagonal I know Shaq I got into
this uh this attack with uh with um
Madeira off of the bishop D3 right after
moving the bishop to D3 He played Queen
C2 and G4 oh my goodness I just fell in
love with that whole idea because I was
playing G4 anyway so put in the queen on
C2 and then playing G4 is ridiculous
it's just a wicked attack most times you
get many crazy attacks the things that
you're looking for obviously now I am
casting Queen side it is risky but at
the same time it's very cool it's not
necessary but I saw a security limiter
do this and I definitely was like
interested in that so I'm curious to see
what artemiev does in this game here and
see if he's able to get anything this
looks semi-slavish obviously V6 Bishop
B7 probably maybe some slow play we'll
see what happens
yeah and some of the moves that James
was mentioning was G4 at some moment
looks like you're giving away a pawn but
you haven't castled so you can bring
your Rook to G1 and open up the line so
artemia just slides his Rook over we may
see E5 in that final round Irene
sukhander had an isolated queen palm
position we may see something similar in
this one and Boyer for the blitz strong
player International Master uh quite a
young player as you see uh you know on
by his camera here you know he would
like to launch the blitz forward and
keep them away from elimination and you
know that artemia will be deliberating
an eventual E5 push likely on the next
turn so slightly better for white still
early stages I think we have to go back
to the bird's eye view James because I
mean I can't get away from the game in
the top right look at my soupy oh he's
holding nothing back
he's swinging at him which he got
something against mvl you can tell he
got some animosity against him I don't
know what kind of personal beef they got
going on but we need to get behind that
chess.com figure it out we need to have
I mean chess boxing or something that's
because soupy is very angry at this man
for some reason look at this attack
yeah I mean the white king we see where
it went to it ventured on over to G2 H5
played I think I'm gonna get your Pawn
here and if you play G5 only one of us
has a light Square bishop and it's white
and five comes to mind you can't really
get away Bishop D3 because Knight B4
would be a little four uh so I would
probably
just go for uh this move Queen F5 at uh
for now but James I just want to point
out Queen takes D5 check he's a tactic
you need to watch out for it because the
queen is loose on C2 oh the little cute
tactino there that's crazy I didn't even
see that that's like this crazy little
stupid tactic it shouldn't be there but
it is and you gotta watch out for that
so Queen F5 definitely is a nice move I
wanted to put my knight there but now
that the tactic is there so I have to
like do something about that maybe Queen
but then I can't get my knight tab all
right maybe I have to go F1 24 but then
I get hit with Knight C5 wow interesting
um
I see what you're aiming for like Knight
E4 maybe right some direction you want
to just plant this Knight on F5 that's a
light Square that's a really really bad
Bishop for black so I love the look of
this position for soupy but now it's a
matter of being precise you got the
Strategic Advantage you have long-term
pluses so what do you do about it what's
your next series of plans and actually
I'm not so sure but I might even
consider trying to pry open this side of
the board I don't know how you do it
because B3 there might be A3 but you
know what I mean James I really want to
open up the queen side yeah there's some
yeah A3 B3 looks very good especially
because the Rooks are connected he goes
with Queen F5 it's a very logical move
to make and Rook C7 play very quickly
very quickly and how do we proceed here
is the question 94 he's giving up C4
whoa I guess uh for the moment he's got
to cover the universe C5 oh yeah I mean
uh yes yeah you're all good no but it's
something that that white needs to keep
an eye out for is a C4 Pawn so I mean
Knight C5 you called it James just
trying to trade everything off and I
wonder
if I can open up the queen side White's
like immediately winning right B4 but
then he takes oh
whoa James candy everybody he has just
entered because B4 is sick let's pick up
an analysis board the point is if you
take with the Knight that's a problem
you needed that night on A6 to cover the
other night because after I take and you
take you to take with the pawn and that
is an E5 Pawn oh wow that was the one
Bishop C5 D6 so that was crazy
give me give me the house
and if B4 is played then
black has to do something because it's a
fork and you don't want to take the
Knight you take with the queen but James
idea is like let's just go for the queen
side full steam ahead if you go back
here I think your queen might even get
trapped right now it should be 52. I
didn't see that yeah I was looking at
both less less material but then he has
night before
yeah but you win you win the house
anyway so
he played it James he played your move
let's go you're a Madman swinging he's
swinging he's swinging Bishop C5 and
then D6 and get him off the board you're
gonna have to sack The Exchange
yeah I'll have to take this way but
James we know that's bad that's this is
just terrible for black and you said it
soupy's mad about something I don't know
if he's mad at mvl look they got some
personal vendettas they gonna have to he
trying to figure it out right now on the
board he's like Rick B1 wow I mean I
guess you just do anything really
yeah just opening up the board at this
point is going to be good the king can't
safely Castle because at some point
there will be Bishop D3 lining up with
the queen going for checkmate mbo's
getting crushed yeah yeah getting
crushed in the nidor Sicilian his usual
opening chat and he's getting crushed
now we've seen this actually before
Fabiano did the same thing now he took a
whole year when the Canada just got
paused and then one year later played
him and then did some psac and it was
prep and he had an hour up on time
knewing this is the problem sometimes
when you do play the same thing all the
time but at the same time night or is
very very well don't get it twisted the
night off is great but he is getting
crushed
yeah and I think some people may be
wondering what's the idea if White had a
free turn Bishop D2 would already win a
piece by pinning the Knight if you start
taking things like Knight takes A2 uh
the issue is that I can then take on C5
trying to Spring this Pawn forward and
if your Rook ever has to leave the
seventh Rank and B7 will hang and your
king is in a world of hurt this King on
G2
very safe and sound this King on E8 it's
going to fall victim to an attack so
James man I'm still impressed I gotta
show an instant replay B4 that score is
not even protected by any of White's
pieces but it's a distraction tactic it
opens up the B file Here and Now mvl's
position looks pretty hopeless
absolutely the Jedi training pays off
for soupy we don't have to give him a
call and give him that a special saber
we saved for him very nice B4 move there
now we have to figure this out though it
is still uh still time you know to
figure this out from my side and um we
gotta make some precise moves I think
when we saw that game with uh what was
the game the way Yi game Right Moves off
of there I mean that's just like you
have to be precise that game was
completely winning and then it was not
so still have some Precision there
against a very strong player like mvl
bird's eye view we got Robert well the
bottom left looks like category luck no
down to her final seconds and Sandra
morenco I think he's well up two pawns
you might be trying to flag her you know
beat her on the clock but he's also just
completely winning on the board so it
doesn't matter how much time she had at
this point I think Mariko wins this
position a 10 out of 10 100 out of 100
because he's picking up a third pawn and
maybe a fourth after that so come on oh
he goes this way with a fork to win the
A4 Pawn First dang bro just taking all
these pawns here yeah he's up material
not looking good here but it is uh this
is only first round right still got
things to do
but it looks like she throws in the
towel and look at all let's go
[Music]
all right I could dunk a basketball
that's exactly I would have I would have
that same thing all the time that's how
I feel I feel great job wow
and mareko from Argentina playing for
the Brazil Capybaras you got to see his
country win the world cup and now he'd
like to see his team a win in the Pro
chess league and in the top right it's
all Luis soupy he's crushing Maxine
versus chilegra but time trouble is
approaching in the top left Julian
Alvarado against Alexander grishook
she's still fighting James that game
still has a lot of life left and the
bottom right that is the most even game
so we'll go back to that one in a bit
but look at this what's the material
count it's actually even I thought that
black was up a pawn because white has
double pawns but in fact it's Five Pawns
per side and then black has the bishop
pair absolutely the bishop here I am a
big fan of Duel of the bishop hair but I
mean why has some trumps I mean that
that definitely have Knight is a monster
on F5 in Black's territory it also
there's a pass on on the E file so this
past Pawn can get you know if he gets
available or what does he say keep the
past Pond or lock and key if we do not
do this then this past problem will
actually be very very annoying and give
us some trouble there's also some Queen
G5 here right like there's some tricks
even Queen G5 now Queen takes D4 Knight
H6 GG get him off the board she plays it
oh my goodness here it comes she's
swinging oh yes she is a king AJ if
that's your best move that's not the
best sign and I'm wondering she goes
Knight back to E3 I was wondering if
there was a tactic with Knight D6 there
trying to get the queen to d8 but she
kicks that Queen away it goes back to D7
but now I feel like things are oh okay I
was about to say getting out of hand but
she wants a pass Pawn connected in the
end game I'm just worried about Black's
pastors James I feel like they'll be
strong as this game continues you know
what you're actually right and after a
queen trade there now of course he would
have connected the pawns but let's say
we do have a queen trade without
connecting the pawns you are correct
those three pawns over there in fact
they say the queen side majority is
actually the scariest over the king-size
majority when it comes to end games so
it's very important to understand is
push these pawns we got the two Bishops
clear playing get the Queen off push the
pawns GG it could be problem on that
side of the board so white needs to be
played a little bit more dynamic or
maybe try to grab some pawns if possible
so putting pressure on the A4 Pawn also
allowing the Knight to go to the D6
Square that's what she really wants she
would like a position with Bishops of
opposite color that will give her a
great chance of the hold especially it
should get it past Pawn on D6 now go
shook is down under 17 seconds he plays
Bishop B3 it attacks the queen protects
the pawn but that Queen goes into the
center and I'm liking the look of this
Pawn E5
absolutely I love that pawn on E5 Knight
I find now you're pushing those bonds
like he definitely just heard us talking
about them pawns those pawns are for
much further than they were before white
still has an initiative I mean this is
like this could go either way I think
black's definitely the one but this
could go either way
and great move Knight D6 please take me
you free up uh the E5 Square for the
bishop no the queen comes to D7 of
course not let's trade on my own terms
Queen A8 watch out back rank Checkmate
and this Pawn is a bit loose oh that's
it okay King H2 and we move
out of the way
wow uh wow hey he covering everything
whoa she going after the pawns but that
was a mistake apparently because the
queen comes to C6
and there's no threats that's the
problem there's no threats the problem
is push right
you just take that now Queen z7 wow
two precise yeah that's that 2700 coming
out what happened how'd you lose I got
2700 what oh yeah I got 2700 what do I
even mean exactly right
well here this does seem like it's going
to uh be a victory for black because now
the Pawn's on A2 you can't play night
before is upon taking that away and this
black king is ready to go or Bishop
takes this Pawn the center that should
be sufficient wow that was a close one
though yeah it was close but then it got
very clinical at the end there those
Bishops just covered everything great
job from Grisha doing what he does and
also doing it in time trouble I mean
perfect game for him time trouble we
know how he is and uh he's just winning
and I think that Julia she had her
chances she does resign here is putting
the blitz on the scoreboard they're down
two to one right now but a really a good
fight from her that was a close one but
used his experience as a former multiple
time world Blitz Champion to his
Advantage so we have one last game
because Louie soupy beats Maxine vasila
Grove I mean that final position was
brutal but now we see this game between
artemiev and Boyer I see what the
evaluation Bar says but I'm going to
very close State black is better here
black has a better Pawn structure
White's pawns are split whites pieces
are also kind of awkwardly situated this
bishop on B5 in particular whereas black
is very harmonious and artemia is both
2700 plus and a minute plus ahead in the
clock so James I said a lot there do you
agree I absolutely agree right you got
three minutes on the clock guys remember
we use that as a piece around here plus
C4 is actually very very weak right and
then we do trades of course this is a
very easy plan is actually trading when
you have this isolated Pawn to deal with
I mean if you look at on Islands there
is one two three for white and there's
only two for black that's actually huge
when it comes to in games and
understanding this so I mean traits are
easy but it'll work on C8 maybe try to
trade the E5 Pawn trade to C4 maybe kick
the bishop I can play this slowly I can
even bring the king maybe to E7 try to
figure out what do you do because at the
end of the day you have a huge weakness
on A2 and C4 in this end game
exactly what James said here so uh White
is relying on the activity right now the
knights are staring at each other but
Boyer is down under a minute he doesn't
know what to do here James and I'm not
sure how to help him because you might
want to make a quiet Move Like H
he's just quiet I am not going to play
this one peacefully that's a very
interesting but maybe an overextending
move absolutely F4 is pretty solid I
like it because of F5 being a threat and
if 95 obviously this should be five hits
The Rook hitting the bishop at the same
time cool we got a lot of threats here
but it is a very overextending it is a
move that is very committal now of
course it's not super weak because I
could end up playing g3 at some point so
maybe not that bad it also can help me
get my king to the center quite quickly
after King F2 King E3 being an in-game
you on King activity so Knight C5 Timmy
F says I don't care about any of that
I really like Knight Z5 because you're
keeping more pieces on the board you're
giving Boyer more chances to go wrong
the bishop goes back and then to go to
this diagonal that's a fee and Kettle
dangle that's a look at the bishop
quality a bishop on B7 versus Bishop on
B5 so maybe it's time for Boyer to play
a move like Bishop C6 and reroute his
own Bishop but his pieces are just an
awkward squares and he is saddled with
these weaknesses absolutely sad and
there it is Bishop C6 on the board with
a 33 seconds on the clock there
yeah and I think that artemiev can play
Bishop B7 because if we swap Bishops and
the Knight takes back uh that's a really
bad Pawn here 100 Bishop B7 and he plays
Bishop 65 he got rid of that fast but
then we take on C6 and just highlighting
the fact that pawn is weak hey buddy
that pawn is weak Rook C8 Bishop D6 nice
in between move
and if C5 I wonder if this bishop can
slap into B5 with Tempo potentially
against this Rook or if I play B5 and
just say your bishop and pawn they look
nice they're connected but the bishop is
stuck there on D6 and artemia he's up
two minutes on the clock he needs the
punish Boyer by playing quick moves
absolutely quick moves quick moves here
hmm
okay Bishop e or D5 attacking wow and
Eva bar hated that what is that about
it wanted white to play C6 that's why
you see the eval bar go back in Black's
favor it wanted white to establish a
pass Pawn instead Warrior plays the safe
option and he's just gonna put his
Bishop back on B4 James objectively we
know that white should hold this game
with 17 seconds against artemia we know
he's a killer so good luck it's tough
It's very tough and one thing you have
to do with 17 seconds on your clock and
now counting now down to 10 seconds I
have to make these moves and and think
then and remember that you know try to
say that I'm not playing artemia right
because he's got to get in your head
with the Magnus effect oh you can you
know how do I Rook rollermate again when
you play a Magnus like you just forget
how to do things so what you want to
actually just play quick moves here oh
but something happened and he definitely
did not like that see he dropped the
pawn in motion
the pawn that went to F5 we were talking
how it's overextended now you can just
capture it so what Boyer wants is the
trade Knights if the knights get traded
these nights the game is easily going to
be a draw under most circumstances but
that's not easy to do because these
Knights are not going to be offered now
we might even take this bishop we're
gonna Rook down to A2 Bishop to E4 and
suddenly the G2 pounds of Target
yeah he's trying to make that make sure
that we don't have the opposite color
Bishop take that take that you have a
check and pin the Knight I think that's
what you need to do oh that's it nice
combin easy there nice combines easy
there wow yeah that's and that's
beautiful takes check Rook C1
dang that's it you got time to do it
yeah artemio is just up that minute that
is the Difference Maker uh James you
know you really reinforced this for me
that sometimes I forget to look at the
clock today I've been locked in clocked
in you might want to say I mean I'm just
looking at it man I'm like wow that's a
weapon and we've seen that in many
different games right absolutely
especially in the time when it counts
look at him just patiently using his
time I got a Time Advantage so now I'm
going to use it and find the best move
to put this one away
finds the combination
wait two seconds wait what are you doing
barely gets a move off oh we it's making
me nervous
and you can also
maybe just go for this Pawn because you
have a bishop oh I need four at the
end
he going forward the other way
Shaq oh you allowed to check though
93 G3 Ray something okay that's actually
really smart because the bishop being a
long range piece would have covered this
potential past pawn and the Knight is
slow so losing a second Pawn wouldn't be
good but 2.6 seconds left for what I
feel like artemium he just plays a
couple tricky moves and boys are gonna
flag
Bishop takes A3 is coming too yeah there
it is yeah oh
oh
yeah that's it hit the button
tough game
look at his shirt by the way I don't
know what shirt our team is Win unless
they got sunglasses and maybe like a
eyebrow raised um but he has you know a
great performance thus far in the Pro
Chesley he won all three games in his
first match uh when the cavity bar is
they just steamrolled their opposition
and now here against the blitz it's
three to one boards one through three
for the cavi bars and the hero is clear
Luis soupy taking down Maxine Russell
that was absolutely huge there of course
soupy was able to take out mvao MVP he
went down in this one in fact and uh
having those three wins to start it out
now of course we've seen this same thing
in the first match today it was three
and a half half I was like oh they
bought the crusher I'm like that's crazy
and then they lost by four so this
definitely it's too early to call
anything it's still a match but of
course this way to start for the cover
you're right we just saw it earlier
today the Shanghai Tigers had a
three-point deficit and still won by a
healthy margin we'll see if the blitz
can copy what the Shanghai Tigers were
able to do but we will have to find that
out on the flip side of this break this
is the protest League match between the
Blitz and the Brazil Capybaras don't go
anywhere we'll be right back
foreign
did you teach uh certain positions or
openings or middle games or what what
did that you're what did your training
uh people look like I'll give you one of
the secrets here so a good a good coach
will correct your moves but a great
coach will correct your thinking
and um all right hold on hold on I want
to repeat that again for the people in
the back can you just repeat that again
so a good coach will correct your moves
and a great coach will correct your
thinking so really part of the magic of
coaching is holding a mirror up to a
child's and so they can see their own
thinking
and sometimes you made the move because
you were overconfidence uh you were
dismissive of your opponent and so these
whether they were this kind of
self-knowledge the self-awareness is
part of the cognitive process and it
helps to accelerate the alerting curve
as as players
um and so meaning games in that loss
because you didn't know who Roy Lopez is
even though the 14 move of the Roy Lopez
or because you couldn't execute a rook
and upon that end game yes of course
these are these are technical things
that you need to win chess games but
games are also lost because of lack of
self-knowledge so
um
the issue of spasticity losing super
Trojan I tell the story many times but
he lost the world championships have
chosen in
1966. goes back to baffinic and
he says you know why did why did I lose
now uh people many people may not know
but spaski was an incredibly talented
chess player right in many ways he's
considered one of the first Universal
chess player he can attack like a Tau
and he can defend like patrosion but he
loses this match and baffinic told him
uh the great talented Boris basket uh
did you study Patrol
right so meaning it wasn't he didn't
think it was important to study the
opponent the famous line from Sun Tzu
know your enemy know yourself in the
Thousand battles you you will never lose
uh heathus thought it was about about
spaski and
your subscription makes shows like this
possible which is why our twitch
subscribers will never see ads on
chess.com
connectyourchess.com account and Twitch
account at go.chess.com connect accounts
and bang boom voila you're done a
hundred percent ad-free Bliss
forevermore whether you're following our
events on site or on stream type the
command connect in the chat and thank
you for helping bring these shows to
life
foreign
we are back getting set for the round
two of this matchup between the Blitz
and Brazil Capybaras and there's quite a
lot at stake because while a playoff
spot cannot be guaranteed just yet as
these two teams are coming with a record
of one and two the loser is eliminated
they do take home four thousand dollars
that's the good news bad news is they
don't get more games in this protesting
season while the winning team returns
next week to face another team that is
two and two all teams will take part in
the arena Royale on March 24th there
will be prizes available for that and
the total prize pool for the PCL is 150
000 so James you know you're a team
captain you've got a squad in this
league
I know you don't want to see your team
get eliminated and just take home 4K
right so if you're Kevin boardy you're
trying to pump the blitz up
what do you tell your squad hey look we
going home do y'all want to go home like
we have to give them that call like hey
do y'all want to go home no I don't want
to go home all right so we got to play
right no we'll pick yourself up right
and just tell her hey look you're good
at this game it happens it's only one
match and I would also tell my team that
remember look it can happen the last
match we just saw something similar
happen and we're all I mean they were
down three three and a half to a half
that's like a three game man deficit
this is only like two games right only
first match you got the Jitters out get
out there championing like and then hang
up the phone right
that's how it would work so hopefully
they can get out there champ and and be
able to uh bounce back in this round
yeah Maxine Russell Grove will have to
bounce back because as we saw in the
first round he suffered defeat at the
hands of Luis soupy so supi takes down
MBL and green luck Noah had the white
piece against Morocco and lost and so
going into the second round here with
the capybarros uh boasting a 3-1 lead
they get the white pieces for their top
two boards you see vladislav artemiev
and Sandra Mariko down there at the
bottom taking on Kettering lock note and
Mahal Boyer but the top Chris shook an
MBL you two-headed super GM monster for
the blitz they also get the white piece
so James you know I'm Gonna Make You Do
It whose chances do you prefer in these
four games will be the blitz or the
academy borrowers I definitely prefer
the 2700s both having white on the top
boards they got white both have white
and against you know not the not the
number one so they're like hey you know
what we want to go crazy here do
whatever we can with these white pieces
Grizzly has to really take it to super
here especially after taking out mvl
like you gonna hit my man like that
gonna hit my like my teammate
like oh no if I'm Grisha I got a
personal Vendetta against soupy uh for
beating my mans like that so I have to
have white pieces I'm going to actually
avenge him as much as I can here but
soup he is on the roll that man played a
very very great game here so we'll see
what happens with the black
yes just looks way too kind and peaceful
to take Vengeance against you know he's
just chilling he's in his Polo he's just
in a quiet room right he's a dangerous
man I mean he just crushed Maxima
Sherlock that was not close it was as
one side as it gets and he said I don't
care if your rating is 27.50 I am going
to try to take you down so right now for
sure gets the white pieces and we are
off D4 played by the former World Blitz
champion and will we get Queen's Gambit
accepted will we get a Catalan that's
the big question as shook Ponders his
second move
I could just play anything he always is
thinking and like times we're like what
did you do he'd never played this game
before
I forgot is this one every time but it's
so funny to see them
yeah maybe for him you know he just
wants every game every position to feel
new so it's a you know enjoyment like
the first time over and over again but
he has opted has to be for the Queen's
Gambit declined with his early Bishop to
E7 saying no Bishop G5 pins on my knight
well that square is not available and
there's contact here and Knight F6 can
happen next there's no rush to develop
this Knight in the position but E4 that
is available to White because there is
no night stopping at Paul from pushing
and grishek is thinking about all the
files here and taking his time I mean
it's just awesome to see I wonder what
like goes in his head when he's thinking
I really would like to like have just
something on his brain what is he
thinking when he's taking this much time
to the opening and and what is he
thinking about how does he want to do
things but he takes on D5 goes Bishop F4
this is a standard stuff we see this all
the time
yeah now this is just normal territory
uh thus far in the qgd bishop F5
enticing provoking the move Queen B3 and
it's played but if you take this Pawn on
B7 this Knight hops out to B4 and into
C2 and before you know it you're in some
pretty big trouble so oh what what was
that
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa analysis board
we need it G4 is like what soupy did in
the first game with B4 well what is the
relevance to this move bro that's that's
I never see I've never shared my life in
the Queen's Gambit if this was the
Queen's game I would have been playing
D4 all the time if this is what you can
do but
that is a crazy move I think what Bishop
takes then you can take on B7 and maybe
don't worry too much about it but I mean
that's that is craziness because there's
no Bishop F5 anymore right and then
exactly G4 then I don't know it's
something like Knight D5 or queen D5 or
something he wanted
yeah maybe but I mean Bishop E4 is here
like what is that move
is Queen D5 I think you think you're
just trade because if Bishop before now
you have Knight takes C7 uh with checks
so it's gonna work out in White's favor
so wow G4 it has been played before I
confirmed it uh but castles and now we
have a position where it's like you
wouldn't know the bishop went out to F5
and then zoomed right back to C8 so
James I'm gonna ask you you're an
aggressive player you love throwing up
your g-pawn but is it gonna backfire
because now your king can't go kingside
not with this putt on here and if you go
Queen side black will be ready to attack
you uh with more pawns on that flank let
me tell you something Robert when you go
for G4 you're gonna have to go all out
that's it you win G4 H3 I'm at the
castle Queen side I am casting Queenie
sign I'm gonna play Bishop D3 I want to
put a knight on E5 this almost reminds
you of some type of London and I'm gonna
jar jar bass London fan a Joe Baba
London that is but of course uh we have
usually the knights go to E5 in these
type of situations and then maybe we
back the bishop up if we can and play F4
and plan tonight E5 but we do have an
attack for sure on on the king side we
just need to develop our pieces to get
the king safe but we have to do it in
the right you know sequence of moves
Bishop D3 could be hit with Knight B4
and you have to move the bishop again
and it's him another Tempo C5 A5 and
then you're like if you cast in queen
size really looking murky over there
you're not feeling the greatest right so
it is a G4 is very committal it looks
nice I do like it but we do have to
follow it with some very accurate moves
something like A3 then Bishop D3 then
Castle Queen side and then we'll see
what happens
takes a while and we see that soupy has
more time than he started with he
induced G4 we were shocked but he's like
come on guys I've studied this opening
once or twice in my life and now he has
a big lead on the clock but that would
be true to him out of the position
because Alexander grishook is his
opponent Glutton or time trouble so
let's uh take a step away from this game
because you know might continue to think
for a bit all four games are in progress
in the top right Maxine vasilograph
taking on Julia Alvarado that's a king's
Indian defense early stages in that one
as Maxime looks to right the ship get a
win with the white pieces bottom left
artemiev he gets the white pieces and
gets Katarina luck no these two are
compatriots uh but today they are
against one another because our tembia
plays for Brazil in the protest league
in the bottom right mareko and Boyer
yeah that one's early not a single piece
has been trade just yet so James
I'm guessing you want to go to the
king's Indian game if I know you oh yeah
you know me definitely yeah King's
Indian defense but I'm definitely a big
fan of it these days it's harder to play
of course because everybody got some
type of prep against it but it is uh
very solid very strong say solid very
strong opening aggressive it's
aggressive it's not solid you know
very great I I appreciate that you made
yourself laugh there you're like nah the
king's Indian is that's not solid right
we're not talking about a Catalan and
you know something uh you know exchange
slav yeah we're talking about
the king's Indian but James I mean this
is an end game now and white and they
are moving very quickly
unfortunately for black queen side not
moving very quickly inactive and white
is trying to take this file I am not a
fan of the king's Indians when they're
like this this is not a king's Indian
like you won't you don't play The King's
Indian to get to the end games as much
which is why I'm not the biggest fan
anymore of the E5 move early a lot of
times you can trade queens and then you
get it like what is this like if you
wanted to play King City and get an
attack why are we trading the Queens off
we get a boring end game here I think
it's gonna backfire of course because E5
is very weak like of course it may be
even here maybe give a slight Edge to
white but definitely that pawn on E5 is
a forever Target we also are developed
better our pieces are just literally
better than blacks we've seen this uh
earlier today what game was that that uh
right with the Pieces Just the pieces
were just better and it just happened to
win for white because or for uh for Wei
because of the better placement of the
pieces and having development here this
can just be a positional Masterpiece
from um from White easy game easy game
to say the least rookie one Bishop d394
Bishop C3 and like just pile up on the
pawn improve my position I'm gonna win
eventually yeah and white has some
forward moves at some point to consider
as well C5 Bishop C4 as James is
highlighting the E5 punt can't push when
you have hanging pawns and that's what
they are when the pawn was on F5 as soon
as you push upon this Square next to it
becomes your opponents for the taking so
I like this for mvo not that much better
you see the evil bar saying slight Edge
for white but I think his experience uh
will be the key to this game as Julia
spends time plays Bishop F5 decent move
for sure but look at this Tempo move get
out of here with the bishop now Bishop
G4 comes to mind although the C4 phone
will be hanging there I'm trying to
trade the Bishops bring my knight to F5
I'm not liking the look of this James
not one bit absolutely not of course you
have to Knight to D7 okay we got to
develop only thing I do like is the
pieces are finally getting out yes you
gotta develop in every single opening no
matter what it is you need to get those
pieces off the back rank so you like the
decision of Knight to D7 now we need to
finally somehow get this rook in the
game see if there's any threats but I
mean at night D6 is super annoying here
not a fan of his pieces just coming into
the into the party like this the bishop
did get to C3 as we mentioned before
hitting E5 the knight's gonna reroute
from H4 back to F3 hit E5 right there's
all kind of side I can even go Bishop H5
first maybe threaten or at least like
hint at the fact that I'm going to
eliminate that bring the Knight back
around and try to take the E5
yeah many options here for Maxime he's
moving quickly and confidently and well
so I think that he is in good shape in
this one he trades the light Square
Bishops a planet nine and F5 the bishop
just like in many King's Indian defenses
that get strategic rather than tactical
it's not a good piece let's get out of
this one let's bring up our
bird's eye view just because it seems
like the blitz are going to get a much
needed victory in this game that's the
trajectory that I'm seeing here but
across the other boards looks like in
the top left those double isolated pawns
for soupy maybe it's offset by the fact
that white king is in the center and
won't find safety in the bottom left who
knows what's happening between artemiev
and Lucknow both sides are fighting for
key squares and in the bottom right it
looks like a lot of Peace have been
traded but mareko is kind of first to
the action so James bottom left or
bottom right is she prefers go to bottom
right I like that Queen on A1 I'm always
a fan of that strange configuration and
I also uh think this is the b3way how
did it get here again it makes you see
this uh this opening okay it was in the
beginning
and B3 yeah I thought it was some B3 so
okay cool cool yeah he got here and then
brought the queen around yeah we see it
trade of Pawns and I I think James
people see this position like okay it's
just even because we're trading in the
center but as you were kind of
mentioning that you know look at this
the last one played was Queen to B8
because this is D6 square is accessible
to the white Knights so the queen takes
it away the queen goes to A1 it just
feels like white is active it's crazy
creating little threats here and there
and B6 that's the biggest Target on the
board whereas White's pawns are healthy
absolutely I think this is a very
position it's a very good positional
opening because a lot of times black
doesn't know where they went wrong
you're just like where did I go wrong
how am I just lost right because of slow
positional moves and a weakness that was
created in this there B6 is clearly weak
the queen needs to move I'm going to
penetrate the position with Queen to C6
right and then I'm and you're almost
paralyzed the Superfluous Knights don't
look too good you move the Knight on D7
I have Bishop F6 wow is there a check I
mean there is but he don't even care
about nothing Bishop A3 okay
he's very confident but maybe he's
playing a little bit too quickly at the
moment there will be a check down here
on C8 it doesn't create the biggest
threat if the pawn goes to H6 and the
King runs away but F7 I guess is loose
so maybe I smoke a little bit too soon
uh because you might be trying to kick
that King out of there
is gross right right man that's hard to
play especially with the dark Square
weaknesses yeah it couldn't be me that's
for sure you know you're just welcoming
at some point this bishop back to the
dark squares and queen A8 was the choice
here probably a good one from Boyer but
it feels like he's all sorts of tied
down can't move any of his pieces you
know he might be like well Queen B8 is
weird as I was might have been a move he
plays H5 though he some lifts for the
king but is there a nice C8 here I mean
what does that even do this looks
strange oh it hits the bee Pawn Yeah
nice yeah he doesn't move
but then yeah maybe the queen goes to E4
as soon as this Knight moves so I think
he's just trying to keep the status quo
James it's like you can't move if you're
black if you play H4 I play G4 thank you
very much
um now we figure out what to do now
maybe we reroute the bishop next
it should be two and like
something to do with that there's also
uh G4 is too much but it is possible G4
G5 yourself wow that's sick playing G4
and G5 because he's so tied down you
can't move anything even the Knight end
up taking the D7 Knight yeah Queen B8 I
think had to be played at some
pointy six is good he could also trade
and then postpone E4 but you can tell he
wants to just win this game with the
queens of the board he says you're
restricted you have no options for your
pieces E6 is a target can't move up
because the queen and the Knight team up
on B5 so Advantage mareko uh but there
is a game that it's not just
advantageous it's completely winning so
let's hop back to our four board view
because if you look in the top right
Maxine versus he is on the verge of
Victory against Julia Alvarado that one
is coming to its conclusion maximum up
six minutes he's also uh just paralyzed
blacks pieces not even up a pawn but
he's about to take F4 and black and
Harley make a move
wow let me look around the board here
anything else uh we haven't checked out
a timio's game at all let's probably
take a look at them just to uh see
what's going on just to see we checked
in
and looks like a London London system
or something like it it does but
actually it was a toy opening so very
similar because the vision went back to
F4 but you you'll like this James the
last move was Bishop F4 so it tricked
you
oh that's funny Torrey attack
interesting that's nice to see wait a
little array that's a very annoying
opening uh men Jim Min Lei actually is a
very very well versed in that opening
very annoying opening it could be very
aggressive sometimes and then sometimes
you just get London's like this I mean I
think white just has a small edge here I
mean a very a practical Edge or a C file
and of course a openc file where I have
some control over it my Bishop is
developed looks pretty good but I I do
have problems with my queen development
and the Knight on D2 which is restricted
yeah then upon three squares away from
the Knight completely restricts it and
B3 is unavailable I'd also say that the
bishop is protecting B5 while a more
valuable piece a rook is defending A4
both of those pawns are overextended but
White's Pawn very naturally defended you
want to play Rook C8 challenge the open
file but you would immediately drop this
Pawn over here on A4 Bishop on F4 better
and the counterpart on G7 just like in
some Kings Indians the darks were
Bishops staring into a pawn this time
it's White's Pawn on D4 so James I think
every piece more or less seems to favor
white and that's why the eval bar is
saying plus one and you can see on
caterer lock knows face he's like trying
to find ideas she sees individual moves
96 great what if the bishop slides back
okay or slides forward what's the next
plan
and we live wow
I feel like
and Lucknow are married we should play
G4 we were taken aback and she played G5
out of nowhere and it's just a very
reasonable move
it is very reasonable H5 actually is a
plan to as well G4 like you can play on
this side of the board for real that was
very very nice Definitely of energy five
yeah astute
play there by Lucknow just going up the
board the bishop also was on the verge
of being trapped so if G4 now the bishop
can slide safely back to the G6 Square
doesn't have to trade itself off so a
good decision there by Kevin and luck no
and well for the blitz it would love it
if she can handle uh this game if she
even just makes a draw they'll be
feeling good about their chances because
Maxime is going to win and their other
boards if we look in the bottom right
it's uh mareko still trying to press but
on the top left uh grishook he's in good
shape right now Super Beat Maxine versus
Sheila Grove and grishook saying you got
one of us you're not gonna get both yeah
getting us both you know you're gonna
take out my buddy I'm coming for you my
guy that's my buddy mvl it's my good
friend and now I'm gonna beat you right
it says Grisha grishek is trying to
finish this one out but this is very
tactical wow okay this is up my alley
here love this kind of Chess then what
do we do takes
Bishop G6 is too much H4 doesn't work if
you just take the Palm B3 okay
wow
what's going on here is white up two
point yeah two extra pawns for restrict
here but it's complicated because this
king is open you can't take on G4 that's
clear you ever take on G4 you just get
yourself checkmated but there's some
long-term pressure in the position
it might be 95 here 95 looks strong it
feels really good 95 is a move I don't
have a follow-up yet though
black can you have to play G6 I know it
looks scary with the psac but you're
already down two pawns so you might as
well get something for your pain oh
absolutely you know I'm gonna stack that
you I'm not even gonna think I don't
even know what the follow-up is but I
know yeah I know that for a fact we
second first think later says towel so
uh yeah hey you know we're not watching
tall watching Chris shook he always
thinks a lot and then you know sax later
yeah yeah it's backwards his backwards
for Progressive but it works for him it
definitely definitely works 55 seconds
James you keep saying use the clock as a
piece Queen B1
man hold on
[Laughter]
or in Queen B1 today and just had us out
here looking crazy but the Evo bar
hasn't changed so that might have been
the best move
and then Bishop C2 I guess is the I
just want to put the bishop back and
reroute a little ring around Rosie with
Queen D1 and queen D3 so for me G6 is
automatic it might lose the game on the
spot but I need to do something if it's
Knight E4 okay trying to complicate
matters in this manner I actually like
it do not take this Pawn that's clear
you're opening up the rook and this
diagonal and you do not want to see your
king fall victim to an attack or a pin
on the light squares oh yeah that's a
nice move that was a nice find from
Super I'm not gonna lie that was a very
nice fine especially in time travel as a
grishek is always in it was a very very
uh nice move there and now it forces him
to go 95.
which is pretty good nice nice pretty
stable there F6 can't be played at least
just yet Queen D1 I do like
yeah because maybe now white can even
take on uh H5 and bring the queen to G4
to block any checks so grishek is
playing this so well it's a master class
thus far and soupy is up on the clock
but down a couple pawns on the board so
that's not the best news for him I think
that shook has proven over you know
decades that he can play with mere
seconds on his clock yeah for decades
right that's crazy been doing it for so
long like why do you do this I don't
know I'm just thinking about everything
I think that's why we asked him he's
like yeah I'll just think about
everything all right
yeah and somebody who's thinking a lot
is his teammate let's go to our bird's
eye view seeing uh for a moment here in
the bottom right boy are in huge time
trouble down to a minute while Sandra
morenco has six minutes and change and
unfortunately for Boyer he's down a pawn
a second Pawn may be lost in the very
near future and he doesn't have time to
calculate his option
absolutely of course you need that time
right Coe calculation over everything
you do want to calculate but you need
time to calculate or it doesn't work for
you it's not going to matter what you
calculate if you can't do if you don't
have the time to place it on the board
40 seconds here and that's a huge time
Edge for moriko here up upon A5 is about
to hang I mean there's literally nothing
and H shakes just F takes as James says
it looks promising but the story of the
the round that's right is the Knight
Pawn three scores away it just controls
that Knight so it goes Queen C3 hoping
to attack this Pawn maybe get a Queenie
one takes E2 but mareko I mean look at
this he is so sharp right now playing
great defensive moves quickly and then
he's using Boyer's clock against him
absolutely he's thinking on his time
it's just an important thing I'm up time
but I'm also thinking on your time King
G2 quick moves I think you two right or
H2 yes it's easy to take with upon now
keep that Knight at Bay
are they taking what's on Queen D2 next
I think James and give me that A5 Pawn
if I was hanging and then we we Queen
one of the two
okay so Queen B for Queen back to B6
maybe but then the queen comes to E1 so
okay
making
mariko's life difficult for the time
being
over here check him back that's it
oh that's sick yeah checking Queen D2
there it is he finds it
and boom
there it is lightning bolt Queen b195
that's only a single check the king can
always slide away so you don't have to
be too afraid of it but I could see an
argument for Queen D3 as well but no
he's he's playing too well to just get
afraid
F5 blades yeah this is GG you just gonna
move the Knight and you can just push
through I guess the F4 is coming so
maybe E3
E3 maybe then the Knight comes in so oh
wait a second hold up okay yeah he's
being tricky here tricks Queen G5 F4
anymore that's such a good move though
because if the queen goes back you bring
your knight to C4 with Tempo again you
were talking about the James Tempo Tempo
Tempo and that is what mariko's using to
his Advantage absolutely and for in fact
uh Knight C4 was good knight C6 was
Tempo and thanks to Nani nanome in the
chat gifting five Subs to the chat
that's pretty awesome pretty awesome
stuff there that is great
I appreciate that hope everyone's having
a great time here in the Pro chess
league and by the way Maxine versus whoa
wait what how did he just I turn around
for a second
are you kidding me
he's so mad okay
wow
one second he gotta take the draw
[Music]
what
he just completely overlooked Queen F2
check he is so upset with himself and he
should be
this game is about to end in the draw I
mean James kind of shocking considering
how well he was playing and Boyer makes
the draw just very quickly before we
head to our bird's eye view there's one
threat to bring the queen over to F2 and
deliver that draw that we saw in the
game so King G2 stops all the queen
checks you can play for a win from there
so let's head on out of here this game
finished in a draw that's huge for the
blitz because you look in the top left
grishook is just crushing super at this
point but artemiev in the bottom left he
is keeping the Capybaras ahead it would
seem
wow this is crazy well griswick looking
good there in VL with the win there and
then a save there and artemia if yeah it
looks like he's gonna pull this one out
what happened let's go back a few moves
how do we get here
two seconds he doesn't move off oh yeah
just Rook H2 should be good just don't I
love this bishop F3 right if that Bishop
gets over there that's a problem
six wow come on boy come on don't do it
like yeah
Queen six
oh that's cool too that's cool too
that's even
oh my God at least mate wow wow sick
maybe I think I think those extra pawns
came in handy for Grisha because the end
of the game there he was up two uh still
so good win for gruchook that leaves us
with one game remaining and is artemiev
in the driver's seat against Kettering
the luck no it's a messy position though
it's actually an extra Pawn for white at
the moment and if you take this Pawn G4
you lose your knight in the center so
tactical position in fact it's actually
maybe Knight G3 here if Knight G3 takes
Queen F3 but there's Queen I don't have
E4 I mean there's some things here
there's some some definite tactics
Bishop takes Bishop takes F3 that's not
enough and I have to move something
maybe Knight C3 too as well I could also
just simply move the Knight to C3 attack
there it is it's simple you called it
yeah he's just going for this rook and
The Rook is tied to the bishop here D5
it hits the Knight The Rook is cut off
from the bishop 105. great suggestion by
you great play from artemiev and now he
is just completely winning he's up one
Pawn that doesn't sound like a lot but
the pawn structure is healthier for
white in this Knight is rerouting
absolutely nice going to go to D4 and
then take on E6 and looking really
really good for our Timmy up here our
tomato just like he's a cheat code bro
he just
every game he's winning something like
it tells you guys in the that's what
time controls artemio is one of the best
in the world right I mean he's really
really strong and underrated I've
yeah he's an absolute Beast he wins this
game on time but really by position and
that's a huge win for the Cappy
borrowers they entered the round up two
points they leave The Round Up just one
and look at that T-shirt and look at the
drawings behind him too oh he has a
daughter I'm sure that's probably maybe
for her but it's uh it's pretty cool
he's a dad right a dad and a Chad at the
same time yeah wow somebody couldn't get
this man it's too much Drift from him
well he gets a win for the Brazil
Capybaras that was really important
because Sandra mareko he was also
winning but only drew the game against
mahel Boyer whereas the super GMS or the
blitz they won their gameshook and mvl
took care of business so where does that
leave us after two rounds you see it
here the score is four and a half three
and a half in favor of the Capybaras two
out of two or a 10 me of one half out of
two for Muraco could have should have
would have been two out of two if he saw
the Perpetual check uh but I think the
problem thus far James has been on the
bottom boards or the blitz right just
it's a bit of struggle it has been a
struggle there and of course we say this
all the time really when you make these
lineups and you have your team it really
is about your bottom two boys if the
bottom three or bottom two three and
four can strike or do anything as you
see even at one point deficit is from
the third board right so if board three
and four can really you know get off and
running that definitely beefs up the
score less pressure on the one two and
three boards and you guys can find
yourself closer to clinching the match
here so Blitz is going to have to step
it up on boards three and four
they will indeed and well it is
international women's day it is also
women's history month so it's an
opportunity to celebrate the women who
have changed the world with our March
Bots challenge Mary Jackson NASA's first
black female engineer or test your
skills against Ada Lovelace often
recognized as the first ever computer
programmer what lines will Visionary and
activist Malala use safside praying to
the chessboard don't miss your chance to
find out as these Bots will disappear
once March ends head over to chess.com
play slash computer or use the command
whm in chat to play now James I always
love playing the Bots to me it doesn't
matter you know if they're super strong
or if they're for beginner players you
play these Bots yet I've actually played
only my bot and a few other ones because
they was like yo can't you play your
body I'm like man you know I'm the real
Jedi right let me go play this bot and
the first time he beat me because I was
playing around and then I beat him like
since obviously the next five six games
because I was mad so of course you do a
beat the Bots guys go play the Bots it
is fun and definitely play the women
boxes of super International women's
awesome
oh sure well we are going to step aside
for now but when return it's more from
the pro chess League round three of the
match between the Blitz and the Cappy
bars resumes when we return from this
break don't go anywhere
[Music]
I have three puzzles here are you ready
for the last one all right one more like
10 more okay let's have more I need to
redeem myself okay 10 seconds
uh oh my God I did this uh exercise like
before
because you know in Polish national team
we had to like uh exercise we had to do
like 20 of them I think in a map and
this one was one of them and I spotted
it actually
and uh yeah but I think review it
follows I mean Bishop takes by Queen G6
is uh
it wins oh that's
yeah it wins because after 36 that is
1936 followed by Bishop C4 Queen D5
Bishop 65 yeah
yeah again like the second one I'm
pretty sure it's obvious I'm pretty sure
that it is
Rook to EA Bishop takes EA Queen G6
takes Knight G6 and Bishop C4
oh
yeah I guess it's okay it couldn't just
six
yeah okay trivia question six yep
perfect
all right
check Bishop pixie Queen G6
96 game Championship C4 correct
hold on a second so I'm doing a
sacrifice my queen but that shouldn't
work okay
ah
rookie eight check Bishop take V8 Queen
G6 yeah yeah finally yeah I got one
correct arrogate Bishop B Queen G6
Bishop takes Queen Knight G6 engine
Bishop C4 completely correct if at least
I got one correca
foreign
just played an exciting game and want to
see if you got a brilliancy or maybe
where you could have improved
chess.com's game review is just a click
away game review is a fast fun and
instructive guided review of your games
see your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy check out the eval graph for an
instant overview and scroll down to see
how many great moves best moves blunders
and yes brilliancies you have played
learn from chess.com's coach who gives
move explanations opening statistics and
shows you the best lines of play
with retry mistakes you can get another
shot at finding missed opportunities
try game review today on web iOS or
Android
foreign
the Frenchman with three names will have
to become the henchman with three names
if the blitz look to survive in the
protest League that is Maxime vaser
lagrav board two for the blitz but he
used to be number two in the entire
world his Peak rating was 28-19 he was
the 2021 World Blitz champion and his
PCO record thus far has been combative
heading into the match seven wins three
draws four losses and James going all
the way back he was a French Champion a
French Junior Champion he stopped
playing in the French Championship
because he was too good we know this man
we know what he's capable of but can he
do it in these next two rounds
absolutely if anybody can do it it's
definitely him you never know sometimes
he just go on a hot streak and you can't
beat him he's just going crazy we need
that right now especially when the
Frenchman having a very bad uh first
game there especially the night or
something he loves right so I think he
gets black pieces this game so if that's
the case then we'll see uh if he wants
one of the night over for he may be in a
grenfail we'll see if when everybody
does need to hey perform for the blitz
here so they can have any chances to for
instance this match it's only a one
point game
yeah it is a close match and we'll see
that heading into the third round we've
had some strong performers at the top
Alexander grishook and vladislav
artemium perfect two out of two score
but for Maxine vashila Grove that could
be a tough one because now we're gonna
see boards one against boards two or
three against board four and in this
round mareko gets the white pieces
against grishop artemiev gets the white
pieces again against Maxine brushella
grub and then for the blitz their boards
three and four get white against the
capybara's board three and four so
looking at this roster at this lineup
card for round three James who's the
favorite the blitz around three I think
the capybarras have a Sly favorite here
and reason for that is because of
artemia with white is just it's very
scary I mean I just give him a slight
ass there he just he's just been
literally literally like a real cheat
code it's just been her optimia is very
very strong and he's showing that again
time and time again and mareko here with
white looking to avenge himself against
a grishek there that's gonna be tough
because Grisha is no joke we already
know that but if time trouble could
maybe get him here kind of ring a lagno
there I think they see might be a
favorite in her game and then uh you
have a Boyer in soupy so we it's a shake
up there maybe
yeah we see grishek on screen here uh
he's determined he's a former World lit
Champion he won that event multiple
times and he now plays against uh Sandro
mareko so mareko uh will take on
Alexander grishuk and we see her shook
you know he does this thing he looks
away from the board he's pondering he's
going to spend a lot of time in the game
anyway and Mariko is like what did I do
that last game
hey bro it's your move man hey yo Mariko
you gotta move like oh yeah yeah you're
right my bad let me get to that
and he's a very solid player Mariko we
saw in that last game right he was going
into an end game where he had more
active pieces he doesn't really like to
take unnecessary risk and for grashook
he's playing into the Catalan he takes
on C4 he's looking for B5 and he can
play it but he first develops his Knight
because this Rook on Aid is often loose
at the end of the diagonal yeah and this
is uh the Catalyst structure here with
this A6 this is uh there's so many ways
you can go Queen C2 I like the queen C2
stuff the A4 I expect to see one from
Black's point of view I actually think
Richard uh played some very very
excellent games that I've seen from uh
him actually playing uh against the
Catalan many times I think it was that
it was some Blitz tournament I don't
remember but recently he just had a lot
of a good Catalan wins from the black
side here so I'm curious to see how he
handles this one here A6 B5 you got
Bishop D6 and the E5 stuff the two as
well so we'll see what
yeah it's a good point yeah Bishop D6
and E5 is a common plan and black is
playing perhaps to cling to this extra
pawn and White's saying while you're
doing all that while you're playing over
here on the queen side I am going to
create a strong Center and I believe
James sometimes it's for e65 white plays
the move E5 and then you give up a piece
does black I'm gonna show this very
quickly like E5 and then you get to a
position like this where you can give up
a piece sometimes I'm pretty sure you
give up this piece maybe it's not this
particular oh I know what you mean yeah
yeah like you play D4 and you get
something like this exactly right where
I've seen it it's not this position
familiar not incorrect so I made a I
made a boo-boo uh we all do that it's
okay but it's just showing you some
themes in these structures
yeah and that's actually happening right
now I mean it's scary I'm not a fan of
just the black side because I I actually
would play this sometimes and then
realized that I was uh not and we'll
first see her I'm like I don't know what
I'm doing in these positions here well
we it was very scary to say the least
because they do suck that Palm but they
get a lot of initiative on you
quick D5 the white king castled and safe
the black king still in the center and
it's easy to mix up your variations when
you're playing such a sharp line for D5
he takes D5 I think that would be
automatic in a bullet game but you want
to be sure about it because sometimes
you leave the tension for a little bit
that way you don't open up the e-file
for example so Knight B4 is another move
that comes to mind putting more pressure
on the D5 Pawn but also allowing this
Knight to hop into the D3 Square that's
gonna make use of the C4 Pawn absolutely
Knight before is a really nice move to
it it is quite annoying to deal with and
when I go maybe we need two there just
play Rook D1 and E5 Rook D1 stuff like
that but we know one thing grishek is
gonna think so you know if I'm ever
playing here's me like hey at least I'm
gonna have a time it I know that much if
I'm gonna have any ads it's gonna be on
the clock so we're gonna make it very
difficult for her as much as we can
because he's gonna think through it I
feel like I'd almost want to give him
the time lead he wouldn't know what to
do with it you know he wins all his
games when he has no time so like what
if I just said really slowly and handed
him a lead on the clock maybe that's the
only way to confuse him but he's trying
to figure out this position it's
difficult let's take a step away from
this game just for a moment and go to
our bird's eye view because all four
games are in progress asuk brings night
to before hardly a surprise but we see
in the top right artemiev in Maxine
versus uh what is this super tournament
right that's 2700 plus players duking it
out on board two over there at the top
right and then on board the bottom left
we see Katarina luck no taking on Julia
Alvarado so up Katarina struggled thus
far uh lost both of her games she will
need to win I feel against Julia like
the blitz need her to score some points
in these final two rounds absolutely
yeah and really if you can score in
boards three and four that's where it's
at that's what that one point is they're
like how are they at one point it's from
the third board or we're performing on
the capybara so you definitely need to
have that performance in the third and
the fourth boards for anyone to have any
type of pull away in this evenly uh
match between you know Blitz and copy
bars I think they are pretty evenly
matched
yeah so why don't we go to uh the game
between Lucknow and Julia Alvarado just
because uh we have an opening you don't
see all the time in most Sicilians white
pushes the pawn D4 but this was the
russellimo this was played between
Magnus Carlton and five minute karwana
game after game in their World Chess
Championship match and well Katarina
quickly develops brings a rook to E1
sometimes you slide your Bishop back to
F1 and you can play for the move E5
that's key where's this Knight going it
has to go back not hopping forward
anywhere so James I've always been a fan
of the Ross limo
I actually have recently became a fan of
the rosalimo at first I did not like it
and I just thought it was too positional
for me and for when I was suited but
then I I it grew my position of sense
and understanding and then actually
started to like the Ross limo more so I
do like it I also like the ones where
you go Bishop F1 and D4 I also like the
ones I mean is there so many even
there's so many ways you could go you
could play E5 you could play Knight D5
but you could play takes on C6 play D3
and then A4 right there's many ways to
go in black with knights of D4 here wow
Evol bar jumped
what we got here Robert I think E5 is
automatic because we're just talking
about where is this Knight going it
can't go into the center because the
Knight covers it from C3 uh if it goes
to H5 knights in the room are dim it
might get trapped after D3 followed by
Pawn to G4 so I don't like the look of
this uh for Julia let's see how quickly
she responds to E5 because if she's
going back to G8 you know things have
gone wrong absolutely night oh yeah
that's correct you're actually right I
mean it has to go to G8 and then you the
question is how do you get it back out
you have to go H6 wow because if you try
E6 and you put a hole on D6 and then the
Knight goes to E4 in many cases and you
just get crushed on the dark squares
this could be really really bad very
quickly there's also maybe a knight D5
to follow after Knight to G8 with maybe
some Knight F6 tricks like there's all
kinds of stuff
wow you're right you have to keep an eye
out for that James so this is looking
unpleasant you could you could tell she
knows she went wrong when she made this
night hop in the center and after E5 she
hasn't moved yet your Knight's under
attack your knight has two squares H5 or
G8 neither looks appealing one's on the
rim one's on the back rank but you know
that she's not feeling good about her
position whereas Katarina I just
couldn't ask for more it moves into the
game so this happens sometimes tricky
openings catch you off guard and it
feels like Katarina as an opening
success so let's uh bounce away just for
a moment because we do have a an
All-Star matchup between and by the way
in the bottom left we see she went
Knight G8 is sad uh concession of
lacking in development but let's go to
the game between artemiev and mvl I was
going to say this is a matchup of
superstars kind of the best players in
the world going at it it's funny that
mvl is bored too but that's just how
strong the blitz can be when they're at
their maximum potential so James in this
position artemiev down two and a half
minutes he has the white pieces hanging
Pawn structure potentially Black's turn
who do you like here I'm liking white
because of my development I did send me
a court of course black can make
probably make some quick developing
moves it is Black's move right now but
I'm definitely favoring you know the
white Pieces Just because of uh my
development I'm a quick I'm a big fan of
develop my pieces fast and then you
attack so I'm just going to figure out
where my king goes I mean obviously I'm
on the castle pink side but it feels
like the bishop B7 is going to be quite
annoying to deal with and it's pretty
even how did they get here I'm curious
to see you know what was the opening
choice for them
always nice to show everybody how this
game started Bishop B4 gun to a rogozin
and then Bishop D2 so very quiet
variation you're not going to double my
pawns what if and when you take on C3 so
we saw a swap hanging Pawn structured A3
allowed Bishop to A5 so this move order
allowed the black Bishop to get away
because there's a diagonal to work with
and run to so in Knight C6 played here
by Maxime I think it's a good choice
natural development but James to your
point and just castle and at some moment
C takes D5 might hit you and it could
hurt
yeah it could hurt and actually there
may be some diagonal issues with Bishop
H7 also Rook C1 correct Queen E2 even
bringing the F Rox to D1 is a great plan
two
yeah this feels it feels good it feels
good for white here
definitely um also c5s is being really
weak so maybe we can eventually play
something like on e4 and fix uh the C5
Pawn as a weakness for a long time E4 is
just kind of strange but it is possible
yeah it's a good thing to point out that
you want to fix this Pawn on C5 or in
some positions when the moment is Right
open up the C file and go right after
that pawn on C5 so Maxime he is thinking
here the team the blitz they're only
down by one point so you don't need
anybody to score right now even if it's
two to two in this round they will still
have a good chance heading into the
fourth and final round of action uh but
I actually want to call our attention to
a different game because the Blitz
they're looking good on Academy unlock
nose board but I think that the happy
borrowers are happy about what's
happening in the top left Sandra morenco
definitely no worse against Alexander
grishop with the queenless position but
in the bottom right that position is
looking kind of spicy and no pieces have
been traded there James not a single
Pawn hasn't traded in the bottom right
but I feel like it's about to
explode oh definitely a lot of tension
and pressure here and nothing's been
straight at all pieces here that's funny
that's funny you want to keep the
tension as much as you can yes
Something's Gonna open up very soon here
even with black playing C5 with the
queen being on C2 you definitely play C5
in mini games with the black pieces C5
is looking like it's going to be a thing
eventually
uh but I think very level as the engine
says it's just it's like equal which we
totally understand why
yeah it's just a position that you know
it's both sides have their chances very
Dynamic play to come and you can't
liquidate some positions you see all
right I don't like What's Happening Here
let me just trade and then we'll go to a
clearly level game instead pieces will
remain here now we have C5 in the making
you call that move out the Knight on E5
is a bit loose here as Black's forces
are now staring at it uh but there is
this bishop on this diagonal which is
good so both Bishops on the longest
diagonals for white
yeah I like this uh if I can only open
my Dart my uh dark scribbishop on B2
then I would be you know really feeling
great about my position but it's really
hard to do that but especially being
back uh behind D4 I thought Knight B5
would be played wow I was actually
thinking that because Knight C6 I want
to play Knight C6 but I mean C5 oh he's
just inviting it to open up the bishop
or something maybe C6 well what is going
on here Robert Knight A7 take on C6 e5's
hanging oh my goodness there's so many
things right now yeah this Knight only
five is loose over there I mean if we
just bring up analysis board and take a
look at it Knight A7 is probably what
Boyer wants after Rook C7 this Pawn is
under attack a bunch of times Knight
takes and he played 97 so we might see
just this variation Bishop takes Knight
takes and how do you exploit the pin you
play Queen D6 this Rook I think would
have to slide to C1 but when The Rook
slides to C1 the black Rook joins the
party and you're going to lose this
Knight but what do you get you take this
bishop you have to give up your queen
you get a position like this and James
White gets a minor piece a rook and a
pawn for the queen seems like a lot of
compensation that is some conversation
that's some serious conversation it also
is a 97 move there after Knight before
instead of night before what do we get a
rook of Bishop because you can get two
Rooks here after 97. yeah but
unfortunately black has a piece right
and the queen for the the two Rook so
you don't get quite enough in terms of
compensation yeah it feels it feels good
but the bishop's still on the board so
we have to take b42 wow and there's a
draw actually with Mariko and grishek
they have a result
and I ended in a draw okay cool cool and
peaceful peaceful
I think that was team strategy James you
know you're a team captain you know how
that goes sometimes you're like
neutralize their top board just if you
find a draw you make a draw and then
you're gonna trust your other boards and
by the way this one is looking very
complicated let's go back to the bird's
eye view because while game one ended in
a draw between Alexander grishock and
Sergio morrico look at the other boards
in the top right artemia with a big
advantage and the bottom left is a
completely winning position for Katarina
luck knows let's go right there let's
check it out James oh the Knight on H6
it's a bad piece and you mentioned
Knight D5 incoming that Knight's gonna
fly into the center for sure 95 and we
live there's some big stuff coming here
of course uh as the night got around to
H6 in that game and G4 oh my goodness
tonight just went back to GA Robert it's
a sad day this is gonna be a bad night
uh that night in this game here Knight
to G8 once again and now Knight D5 it
can just immediately come in you also
have 94th and Knight D5 and Knight D6
all kinds of moves here what on Earth I
mean that's sick I think she's going for
that Knight B5 and oh she went Queen F3
here come the tactics
gosh I mean it looks like black has
played maybe five moves in this game bro
maximum seven and white has played like
all 14 moves so every white move was for
the purpose and it's just domination you
play E6 you stop the Checkmate over here
but then Knight B5 hits the Queen the
Knight goes into D6 gonna Fork it's
gonna check with you anyway so this is
completely over and just to show you how
this happens in this game I just need to
start from the beginning normal moves
from White every move with a purpose
every single move has a plan E5 Knight
goes back to G8 moving a piece twice
Bishop back okay I moved here twice but
I'm creating a threat Knight to H6 D3
Knight to F5 G4 Knights H6 how many
times that knight move one two three
four and then back here is five you
can't do that in the first 11 moves of a
game and then more development for white
crushing attack I don't unlock no ear in
this one absolutely devastating attack
here from catarating lag no this is
amazing I mean especially after tempo
right we hit Tempo after Tempo and Tempo
after Tempo and now she has a very very
good position with this Tempo here you
either have to play F6 or F5 which can
be responded by literally just taking it
on poisson or taking it like EF Knight
E6 is not a move I take and take on F7
E6 I go Knight B5 you don't have a move
Robert
nope I resign and I think that we should
move on from this game because it's
completely over no matter what black
does it's it's done The Rook staring
down the line at the king as James said
it's just not gonna work out for black
so let's look at the artemia game
against Maxine versus Sherlock uh supi
took down mvl in the first game and wow
look at this position James
white is just up in exchange bro I told
you look something here Chico I don't
understand like we need we need to check
like he got a chip in his brain I know
what it is I don't know how we got here
but it's a cheat code every time how do
we get here like it was all quiet for
like a few moves and then we get back
here and he's missing an exchange
so it happened around here when D4 was
played I mean the position was getting
uncomfortable because at some point
white is going to take and go after the
C Pawn but instead was a D4 and after
the swap of pieces Nike four there's a
big issue H7 is loose this queen is
under Fire and so the point is that
their Knight takes Bishop takes rook in
the corner Pawn H7 both under attack
winning position for white with Bishop
C3 as well so instead Rook d8
trade give me the H7 Pawn back to E4 and
instead of just playing a pawn down with
Bishop coming to C3 he decides to take
and go for some kind of position like
this but James it's clear vladislav
artemium up a clean exchange this attack
I don't think it's leading to a
Checkmate because white will be able to
push the pawn to H4 jeez yeah that's uh
by the way a lagno just won her game at
the move I looked like F6 happened and
she took twice when F6 GG and this one
is looking like it's going to be over
very soon here after we trade a pair of
Rooks which he's not allowing those Rook
h8 F4 very strong literally blunts the
bishop look at how bad the dark Square
Bishop is
it's and it's like an open game it's an
open position but it's terrible like how
many of you ever have that yeah you need
to Bishop on D4 right like somewhere in
open space but F4 takes away that E5
Square uh you would throw the C5 Pawn
off the board like get out of here so my
Bishop would go into B6 with check no
can do and that means that this is just
a terrible position for mvl great news
for the capybars score currently tied
five to five but this would give them a
lead and actually
um the other game that's still going
between soupy and Boyer that's also
looking great for the Capybaras James
they might take both of these games the
queen has been sacrificed by Boyer over
there and he's also down about five
minutes on the clock oh man that could
be a problem that could be a huge
problem there of course the time is is
it is uh a piece as we talked about
before here we do have some conversation
but practically I mean practically
speaking this is very hard to play with
you without your queen obviously I do
have both the Bishops I'm only missing
one night I mean okay you know I would
play this on definitely with the white
it definitely has answers but black can
definitely try to create some things
especially with me being under a minute
that is a Boyer yeah and I like to move
G5 by the way it gives the king Luft to
run away and already poses some problems
with a knight trying to land on e4 Boyer
is down to 40 seconds he survived
against mareko that was very lucky
because he was just down uh one pawn and
about to be down he was right now two
pawns actually and then Mariko just
allowed him to give him a Perpetual
check Knight A1 oh Knight A1
why explain that to me James moment of
silence chat for the night moment of
silence please I need a moment to
silence before the night
thank you okay all right all right he
could do the same thing with Knight E1
if he was gonna trade the Rooks like
this 91 oh that was actually yeah 91 I
was thinking 91 the night to go Knight
D3 but I mean yeah this Knight is dead
bro yeah
and if B4 the queen comes into D3 to
pester the bishop if the Knight comes
back to C2 well you're just kind of
running around and not accomplishing
anything and okay to me I'm playing H5
H5 G4 gaining space over here maybe H4
maybe G3 just you gotta just throw your
pawns off the board that's it that's all
we have we have to use our pawns and the
Knights but we don't use really one of
them uh the Knight on D7 is just not
doing anything but we can't try to move
it into E4 and move around to F6 we
gotta be careful not to trade too many
pieces so we don't give quite really any
hope but I mean sure we we're really
like this Knight on A1 is not even a
piece so we're really playing against
three pieces and not four anymore black
definitely has a huge event
yeah look at the time five seconds
remaining four white knight E4 Knight G5
Knight H3 take those light squares
they're available to your to you just go
in there's nothing
it's going to stop you from moving
forward here I guess 94 Bishop F1 Knight
G5 Bishop G2 Knight H3 Bishop takes Pawn
takes but then I have Queen F3 coming
Bishop D3 is around but there's the
other Knight yep and this is gonna be
night night Queen F3 might be an idea oh
F love it what oh whoa what to say isn't
F2 just hanging I mean I thought I
missed something really I was like did I
admit okay yeah yeah he couldn't play
that you know
and soupy gets it done once again he
beat mvl in convincing fashion now he
takes down my health Boyer so yeah that
was just a nice game from him that
leaves one game remaining artemiev and
mvl it's been
kind of an uphill battle for vaccine for
shiligrov from early stage of this one
but look at the clock our attemptive
down to 25 seconds so James I feel like
Maxime has no attack but he can use the
clock and try to cause some problems
look at the positional dominance here
the bishop is uh on B6 I mean if you
just like you know from a distance it
looks like a pawn like if you just
walked in the door and glanced at oh
that's a Pawn on V6 wow like it's
literally a bishop looks terrible right
it looks very bad the bishop won't E8
doing the same I mean the queen side the
king side lockdown this is absolutely
2700 I'm not even gonna lie this is very
dominant this is a very very dominating
game by our Timmy up here but he is very
low on time so we have to use this to
our advantage and how does white break
through without making any real
concessions maybe Rook H1 King G1 and G4
wow that would be something if the king
starts running away he goes Queen C3
offering Queen trade the reason I don't
like that is what if you take and put
Bishop takes A4 oh and Paul's hanging
you're right it's hanging and he goes
for it boom
you know what that could have been James
in our 10 years time travel he was
thinking there's no way you're going to
trade Queens you're down in exchange but
I don't even think black's that much
worse anymore you're right you see this
all the time in the grin fail absolutely
you're like oh you know here growth
failed players so having this type of oh
and I got the pass a pawn I mean is this
a gun failed now of course put the
bishop on G7 and then we have ourselves
our nice grandfail in game Bishop B3 C4
somehow get the bishop to G7 Bishop d8
Bishop F6 all right type route and push
the a pawn long long plan but definitely
playable especially with his time at
eight seconds here yeah I'm playing C4
for white I mean this bishop is so bad
and I want to keep it as bad as possible
so C4 is tempting uh so there's a busy
trade being offered what do you think
James cue the Bishops on the board if
you're black yeah I gotta keep them I
got to keep him and he does he goes
Bishop C6 he wants to go to E4 I like
the idea Bishop E4 might be hit with
Bishop D3
he also stops C4 just now I was nice
yeah it's taking away that push uh it
would appear wait maybe I'll do it
anyway C4 but anyway and in Bishop E4
let's go I see you NBA
MVP wow
and if you're a tamiyev I'm getting to
the point where if I find a draw I'm
taking it like it's scary territory for
him his Rook is kind of almost trapped
over here
he's gonna take on D5 yeah yeah you're
like you know what you're right bro my
bad
right you're right you got it big dog
all right you got it fake take and then
Bishop one Bishop H3 I mean there's
still chances
this is big though for the blitz because
MBL looked like he had a hopeless
position they're down by one they do not
want to be down by two and that Rook
survives over to A6 okay
back to B6 it goes
I think it's a little pressure
um
yeah this one's tough this one's telling
me this could be anybody here anybody's
here I think I think he's playing for
two though our Timmy has definitely
playing for two well he got four seconds
so oh my God it might be playing for all
three results bro it could be anything
oh and we see the eval starting to say
black might have some chances be very
careful what's this uh he just wants to
hit the g Pawn make him think a little
bit use his time
yeah yeah
he goes back
they're going back and forth at this
point before
okay what's going on here it doesn't
look like much
attempt is too fast man he is fast maybe
they just repeat
you're like me I'll take a draw
right
oh Timmy he doesn't look very happy you
know he's always smiling but I think
right now he is really upset at himself
because he let Maxime versus escape with
a half point and James at that point
minimal time in the clock we get it but
it was a 2-2 split in round three it
looked like the Capybaras we're gonna
take a two and a half one half but that
was not the B and as we finish three
rounds and head into round four
artemia Richard That's The Clash we'll
see in the final round but James I mean
the rest the roster and the Cappy bar is
leading the way on boards two and three
that's the big Difference Maker yeah two
and three and also uh that well yeah
that third board actually and a third
board is really where it says it said
third board and of course the fourth is
a draw down there but every little point
every half Point counts right now is
really I mean this is it fourth round
this is the closest match we've had
today we've seen some matches like this
that were really close but this is a
one-point game going into the last round
if I'm the copy Bears I'm feeling good
hey look we up one game but we cannot
let up we can't get comfortable we need
to play like we actually down right now
right of course uh they do need to play
smart but at the same time it's still
anybody's game
that's true and elimination is on the
line so these teams have a lot to play
for we'll see who's in better shape
heading into the fourth round when
returned from this break this is the
protesting match between the Blitz and
the Brazil Capybaras we'll be right back
[Music]
welcome in to our new video lecture
series here with the one and only the
14th World chess champion vishwanathon
and on if you have to explain that
you're world champion and it's taking
longer than two words there's something
wrong with your adventure there's
something wrong but I believe in we're
talking the 60s and 70s even the 80s and
90s
you could see that
the match format produced something
unique and I remember there was a funny
moment at the press conference where
I was trying to tone it down
uh not get very excited and also I had
not had time to collect myself in fact I
already wanted to calm down and think of
the next game because I knew it was a
wounded animal there I knew that I had
to play a game against a man who was
desperate for the match to be over so
that he could clinch his tightly he
wanted a draw at any price I mean you
can make a joke that he had spent a week
out of the swimming pool already so he
must have been exhausted and waiting to
finish so for all of us there was this
feeling of
um we got to grab this chance with both
hands because it's not going to come by
way
where does that come from that kind of
even Keel like kind of level-headedness
I mean a lot of people get really big
headed and very very confident when they
like get on a roll and you're just like
I didn't play well gotta be better next
time
I mean you can never relax I mean I do
that so I don't relax I keep the same
amount of energy and concentration
during the tournament
foreign
chess is that happening or not I haven't
seen it there's some smart people in the
camp so I wouldn't be surprised if
people
are versed at it really uh a lot of
college educated people you know I
unfortunately am not one of those
sophisticated people that play chess in
the camp she talking about man I don't
play chess
I mean you know how to play I listen
there's a difference with knowing how to
start a car up and then driving Formula
One racing
fancy
[Music]
thank you
we are back and ready for the fourth and
final round of action here in the Pro
chess League match between the Blitz the
Brazil Capybaras the blitz are down by
one point they Trail six and a half five
now but they're no stranger to the tie
break if they win this fourth round two
and a half one half they will get an 8-8
score we will get tie Breakers and James
the blitz they're no stranger to tie
breaks they've already played two this
season wow oh man that's crazy that the
blitz have done that well they're used
to it so they're like hey we've been
here before let's get it done right
let's get the job done let's finish the
job here but we definitely need to pick
it up on our third or fourth boards down
there if we're gonna get the job done
and this is it this is the last matchup
or one divorce one two two three three
and four versus four so you know of
course if you can score on your
respective board it's gonna definitely
be right now
and you said this so I'm gonna guess on
your behalf I feel like you like that
the blitz have white on the top two
boards whereas the cabbie borrowers get
white and the bottom two boards are you
saying Advantage Blitz
yep we're gonna have to think we have to
give it to him it's a blitz because I do
like to have white on the top boards and
black on the bottom boards there
that's gonna be tough it's gonna be
tough black on the bottom drawers there
but uh if I mean if they can hold I mean
you know they'll be fine here but they
are having some trouble on the blitz
there at the bottom board so we'll see
if they could hold if this is the time
they need to step it up this is really
the time right
yeah and I feel like Julia Alvarado
she's a huge opportunity in front of her
she has to wipe pieces against my health
Boyer a Boyer needs to win for the blitz
I feel like that's one game that they're
counting on with the rating differential
but we're gonna start uh with the game
between Alexander grushook and vladisav
artemiev I believe we have the top
boards going at it artemia a bit
disappointed he drew that round three
game from a winning position and for
Grisha that was just a solid draw
against a strong indetermined Sandra
morenco so James we're about to have
liftoff here we can see grishook leaning
back
um
he's already in time trouble we know
immediate time travel E4
what do we have E5 very solid
and I wonder how much pressure is
putting on himself because the team is
down by a point but artemiev is super
strong that's not a player that you take
lightly our teammate beat Magnus Carlson
in the world rapid Championship Max went
out to win the event but he only lost
one game and it was to vladislav so I
feel like if you're grishook you just
kind of say all right my opponent plays
well and makes the draw so be it you
need to count on your other boards yeah
you need to count on other boards here
as well because this is this can
definitely fizzle out to nothing this
can fizzle out to literally nothingness
and then in the next few moves here
there are some little tricks where you
can try if you're playing for more but
Madness these these positions
and if you play D3 and we can return the
favor and double a white spawns over
here it seems like a very level position
I wouldn't be surprised if we get
Bishops of opposite color and oftentimes
those Dynamics result in equality the
game won't be over but I think that
artemia if he's feeling very comfortable
right now as Chris jokes says give me
that pawn on E5 I'm going to eat that
I'm gonna eat that pawn I eat pawns
appreciate it thank you Pawn Grabber and
it takes E5 rookie a and we're gonna get
it right back listen a few moves if D4
maybe we take on C3 then E4 if you move
the Knight we just take on e4 maybe same
idea take on C3 then E4 what we getting
it back
I'm gonna get it back for sure I mean
Knight D3 you take first because The
Bishop's Thunder attack as James is
saying E4 is falling no matter what you
do so artemiev should be very happy with
how this game has started I actually
feel like he is in good shape to hold an
easy draw
I think the same here is as well I mean
very strong both 2700 here dry position
and it's going to take a lot to make
some real mistakes but there is still
things that they can push for try to
make some imbalances or create something
different in the position for some
chances
all right so grishook on the clock we
say that very regularly but in all
seriousness I feel like he's not loving
look at his face right he just kind of
mean mugging but also like ah what am I
doing this is just gonna be a trade in
the center and that's not good news for
him what is this
where's Daniel when you need him you
know oh yeah
does everybody everybody
this is it just must be frustrating when
you're playing against artemium I feel
like you know if you're up to you you
would be like artemio's the goat he's
your goat yeah oh for sure for sure and
especially in the in the fast time
controls and I've even uh like studying
just on my own study and I'm looking at
you know even just games and checking
checking database games and looking at
it and now Timmy have is just on a
rampage or a lot of his stuff that I've
seen like hey crush this guy he beat
this guy like he's just beating
everybody like what is who is this guy
right you don't hear a lot about about
us he is an underdog and when they pick
him up on copy Bears I knew it was going
to pick up a lot I was like oh you got
him now you might have some good chances
right and that's what it was for the
pastors too when we picked up uh
coordinate so yeah
and right now artemium he's five and up
at a six in his two matches in the uh
protest league so if he can hold against
grashook uh he's just gonna improve that
score so let's uh zoom out because
Richard seems to be stuck pondering what
he'll do next I think we see a couple
french defenses in the top right maybe
that was a a caracon actually but in the
bottom right that's definitely a French
defense okay yeah definitely let's go
check that out and look at their friends
defense the reason being is uh lots of
times you know the French middle games
are very tactical usually white is like
trying to rip off Black's head there but
sometimes black could actually be
counter-attacking many times especially
with the weakness that could be on D4
French from Boyer here he likes the
French from France all right nice over
the French in the last round all right I
see it
that's one of these positions James not
a single Pawn or piece has been traded
just yet white pushed upon to H4 but
watch out there's already a very big
threat you always want to take back on
D4 with your C3 Pawn you can't do that
when your king is behind that's not how
the rules of Chess work so you're gonna
have to do something right now to avoid
that Bishop D2 seems pretty natural just
block the diagonal uh but I feel like
for Boyer he he seems like he's
comfortable in these setups yeah
absolutely especially if you play the A5
A4 he you he's a real French player
that's how you know because like people
don't even know that's a real life you
can actually do this idea it's gonna go
Queen B6 probably here yeah exactly so
he's B2 and D4 now you gotta move the
bishop again all right or you're gonna
give a B2 and he gained A5 A4 and
sometimes weirdly enough we take on B2
play C4 take on A3 and queen the a pawn
like literally it could be that fast if
you mess this up with white you need to
get that attack going
the one thing is if Queen takes B2 let's
say black at a free move there could be
like Rook B1 back to A1 and there might
be a way to get away with that but I'm
not so sure I'm gonna actually bring up
analysis board so rookie wants to play
but if we bring up the analysis board I
think that there are sometimes these
tricks where like you take on B2 The
Rook comes to V1 the queen takes on A3
you go okay I'm gonna make a draw by
going back and forth and that sounds
great but I'm wondering if A3 is
possible
see because you take I take back how
exactly are you gonna stop Rook A1 the
answer is you're not because your king
is in a mating that kind of in tune by
its own pieces so that would have been a
nice chance for uh Boyer and that's why
Julia she's too smart she plays Rook B1
said nah that Pawn's off limits you know
you ain't about to do that and then they
repeated here you want to draw bro like
no I think I think she does and James I
mean in this league your captain when
your board four is lower rated because
uh you know you're just that's how the
lineup was submitted you feel like
that's kind of a threat almost like
you're just hang that over Boyer's head
like you really want to draw me because
you know you're supposed to win that's
true of course and it also I mean one
half a point cool we had seven now we
need one and a half right that one point
difference everything matters every
point every move matters the time
ticking it all matters and it comes down
to this somebody is going to get sent
home after this match who will it be
will it be the blitz or the copy Paris
they're definitely a critical moment
it's the big question and while a Boyer
thinks if he wants to just go back and
forth let's go to our bird's eye view
because every single game is of the
utmost importance the season is on the
line for these teams this is a three
loss and you're out league and both
these teams entered the week with a
record of one and two so James as you
know we're looking across these these
four boards my eyes are on the top right
mvl mareko because that one looks
adventurous definitely I see Queen on F4
and ig5 Pawn on E5 final E5 signify
space
um and if this is not their position up
this is uh the other position
yep we will bring up the uh
the board between mvl and mareko in a
second here when we can so good though
there we go
bird's eye view
top right everybody James
likes the pawn on E5
on only five signify space so we got
some attacking chance
so that game space for white by the way
in the top left that game is also just
like looking fascinating because took
one Pawn he took a second and
he's gonna get away with it that's the
big question because our temmie have he
decided to part with some pieces and
he's saying I can hold on
yeah and that looks like some type of uh
there's e45 openings that are just like
that I mean this is Spanish anyway but
Queen takes C6 F3 wow how do you gonna
get it back it's probably just gonna
fizzle out to be honest I'm gonna give
those pawns back and fizzle out all
right here we go we got the position up
those move it is Black's move last move
played was rookie one just to over
protect this Pawn E5 what was his
opening wrench I don't know what this
was what is this
it looks like a French but it's
essentially like a French where you
played C6 and then C5 so you're down to
Tempo
yeah yeah it's just a foreign
I feel like
white is just controlling many important
squares but black is super solid in
these positions you know you're worse
you know you've cramped you get enough
space but how does white actually crash
through that's the big question and mvl
just maneuvering around but then what
and if you're not careful and you allow
this Pawn to get to G5 watch out for the
white king like a G5 G4 could hurt
that's actually true in fact there's
many French defenses as a Carol but
there's lots of friendships where you go
Bishop E7 and H5 G5 very fast it's like
what is this a French or what the heck
is this opening where you play H5 G5 and
you never see it before in French it is
very possible and very doable here um
but white has some plans too and we put
the Knight establish itself onto the D4
Square we gain some space Italian style
with B4 and A4 in certain cases we have
to be careful because B4 could be
hanging we have to prepare it um you
also want to play G4 at some point by
yourself but that is going to take some
time and it's a huge concession
um as well because you do open the H
file maybe you put the King on G2 just
have space space can signify you know um
lots of options and why you can do many
things in this position that's really
what I heard from you I was like
listening what you were saying you told
me like five different great plans for
white and I'm like what does black do
because Knight D4 G4 A4 gaining space
but I don't see an actual plan for black
I don't think you really want a castle
Queen side the king's not going to be
perfectly safe over there but maybe you
need to connect your Rook somehow and
that just is the solution
I think about the castle bro I think
about you know I've seen this in those
fringes too and I'm like hey no he's not
going that way and then they do it and I
was like oh this is a French thing ah
like you just do this all the time in
France they just don't care about life
so Council Queen side they bring the
other Rook over to G8 and plus G5 like
we talked about in there maybe even
Queen d8 and then G5 but I mean I feel
like I'm running right to a pawn storm
E4 B5 like
it's all about who get to that King
first this could be crazy in the next
few moves it certainly Canon uh well
this game is going to heat up I'm just
going to bring us back to our bird's eye
view scene and look at the bottom right
James look at those pawns on the light
squares for black F7 all the way down
connect five to B3 and that's really
really impressive Pawn chain for Mahal
Boyer and well I have a question for you
I feel like black is just completely
winning it's one of these positions
where you see this Knight went to A7
Knight B5 but it's a tight position the
engines hold really well humans just get
impatient they lose maybe the solution
for white is just do nothing and just go
back and forth but black at some point
can play F6 to break things open maybe
there's a p sack you know on these
squares I was saying the same thing
it's terrible it is it's some type of uh
I was thinking about the peace act that
Bobby Fischer did I forgot when he did
like Rook B3 we took upon something like
that whatever famous game is but it's
something like that we could take on
like B2 Knight B5 take on B2 take on A3
but you have to be ready it has to be
ready and if it's not correct and it's a
premature sacrifice which you could
literally lose the game from this so it
has to be prepared correctly F6 is in
the right break black has all the all
the play
but it's a it's a matter of when
yeah I do not like this position
what F5
yeah
um
wanted to go after whichever Pawn you
capture another Pawn will be weeks you
take with the E Pawn and Knight F4 goes
right after the D5 Pawn so I think she
thought that she was going to lose the
game if she sat and did nothing that you
can't just uh keep the status quo so F5
is a bit of a desperation move but it is
about to go after some pawns give
herself some counter play of her own
absolutely of course I do understand
after uh f after d e d e is probably
just not a choice at all so uh f e uh
sorry ef ef is definitely not a choice
because of a knight F4 and you have the
E6 square and D5 right so we have to do
GF I think and then Knight F4 and
obviously Bishop E2 she has some play
there but even if you get to play I mean
weirdly enough I could even run to the
queen side at some point if I have to
it's creative creative here and again I
still don't know what to do with black
after we take on F5 how do we actually
you know we got this nice kinetic five
here but what do we do with
it's one of those moves James just it at
least makes you feel like you're more in
the game just a move ago before F5 the
eval bar wasn't as in Black's favor but
you don't have a plan for what you can
make a one move one move what whatever
like a couple little moves but you have
no plan at least F5 gives her a plan and
that's important because it builds your
confidence it allows you to play moves
more quickly and we've seen Boyer get
into time trouble in many of the games
so uh objectively better for black I
think you should take towards the center
G takes F5 I think we both are
acknowledging that but then white will
get it after this H5 pawn and have a
chance he takes wow he takes F5 come on
look at the eval bar
yeah they didn't like that I mean how do
you oh you're gonna take the Knight and
play Bishop E6 but that might allow
white to just lock down the position and
just stop full
Rook H4 and Bishop B2 and Bishop F1 and
maybe two and Bishop King D2 right make
sure everything nice and oh she's going
for more
yeah there's nothing how does black win
this game you know at some point you
have to play Knight B5 and Sack a piece
that's the only thing I see maybe
there's B5 B4 sacrifice the pawn just
like white to the other side but I'm
actually not seeing a way to crash
through so practically speaking I think
she made a great choice to play F5 this
game is gonna take forever there's gonna
be a lot of maneuvering let's zoom out
of here because other games are looking
like they're more adventurous and uh for
the Blitz in the top right Maxine versus
he is in good shape against senjo Mariko
uh the Queens may be off the board that
doesn't mean the problems have stopped
at the top left Alexander grashooki
maybe down to two minutes but he remains
upon ahead that's opposite colored
Bishop so there are going to be chances
and the bottom left we haven't even
looked there James that one is anyone's
contest between
and luck no both players have their
chance so which game would you want to
go to everything yeah let's actually go
to the Katarina like no and super game
there that looks very exciting I mean is
there a rook hanging on F3 right now
what is this Rook hanging on F3 but your
Queen's hanging but then like Rook G3 is
a thing but the pawn on E3 but C5 is
hanging like where do you look what is
going on here okay so obviously the work
is hanging gotta go Ricky through here
maybe yeah what's the material by the
way it's white up a pawn right now
yes whites of a falling yeah
wow
what's up a pond yes holding two and you
know how this happened
black like Noah was tired of doing
nothing
it's like my Bishop is terrible so she
went C5 here she didn't have to that
might have been a rush decision you see
the Evo bar react and say that it's
turning in White's a favor but I
understand this move because the bishop
was just a big Pawn uh sitting behind
your pawns over here so I get it getting
adventurous going for the initiative but
James if white wants you can just take
back on E3 within Knight takes a four
looks scary so I'm not gonna advertise
that
what else do you see here Ah that's a
good question uh F5 is a move
Knight C5 Bishop C4 I have anything
concrete yet
Bishop c4's Bishop D5 maybe this move
James Knight D6 oh wait he is sick oh
man that's it yeah that's the one we was
looking for yeah that's the one my guy
that is the move yeah oh yeah yeah
Queen D4 get him off the board no oh I
mean Knight D4 first whoa whoa whoa whoa
94 94. Knight F4 there's I guess a trade
and the bishop slides back to whether
you check here
oh yep let's remember now support James
is on it Bishop takes G2 check the king
takes back Knight takes F4 with a second
check the King has to connect to the
Rook because otherwise you're gonna lose
the Rook there's a king F2 take here
King takes the king's just out in the
open without Defenders here and you
bring this Knight you bring the queen
out I feel like this is just devastating
that's a sick tactic you gotta find all
of that how much time she got 3 40. she
got time
he has time wow Bishop G2 here
is absolutely sick I'm guessing it's the
only move that keeps the big Advantage
because Knight takes a four there's a
check you trade Queens you trade pieces
the bishop can slide back to F1 as well
I feel like if you are like no you need
to find Bishop takes G2 check now
reason it's difficult to find is that at
the end of the sequence right if we yeah
she played it so she went for it she uh
her intuition was good and her
calculation was even better that once
the king's out in E3 it's out in the
open but there's not necessarily A
Checkmate by force so sometimes you can
see some ghosts you can get a little bit
scared but this would be huge for the
Blitz
oh wow that's a big move she found a
bishop G2 on the board it is there guys
it is there and he took and Randy King
Rick takes E3 on the board gonna have to
take that back whoa Bishop C4 he didn't
care he didn't touch it he didn't even
touch it but then she just went oh he
missed it you see that he was like wait
what that's possible he just completely
forgot it seems about Knight D5 and the
Knights defend one another and this
Knight defends The Rook yes there's a
king behind it but you know you can't
take a piece when your king would be
captured after it
Queen H4 check is coming too he about to
hit the button he about to hit the
button in the minute wait that's the
resignation button we talking about here
disgusting this is a big win that's
going that's even there's nothing else
going on right now too Blitz actually
looks like uh mvl might be doing a
little well against Morocco there in G4
uh let's see Knight takes H3 check is
probably
available not sure if it's best
because the threat is Queen takes F4 the
Knight on D5 is pinned so be careful not
the blender piece that actually is
pretty ugly
uh yeah this Knight is three hmm
we have six yeah that's a good move here
this one is busted as they say and
that's a really bad news for the cabbie
bars combo
James I'm looking at the boards the
blitz might sweep this round Alexander
grishook is the one player I'm not sure
about because of his time trouble but in
the bottom right where is crushing oh
yes in the in the top right mvl is
dominating that game against this could
be let's go I think it's Christian's the
one who's in time travel so let's go to
that game to see what's happening there
because
if he is able to at least make a draw I
feel like this one's uh in the bag but
in time travel sometimes things go wrong
oh definitely we saw that with the uh
our Timmy I just it was on the other end
of that time trouble and had a draw in a
position where he was up in exchange
yeah but yeah this one's straw bro
really even really really even if shake
hands Rook E2 what no that's that's the
only way you can hang mate
you too the only work on the back rank
please please somebody do it you can do
A6 then H 1687 King G6
that looks like the safest option to me
and no paid actors here I'm just gonna
make sure that the king gets out of
there and H6 is played and that should
maintain the equality here so it looks
like artemiev and grishook will have a
draw especially after that move it's
like let's just trade off the pieces and
you should be able to hold let's go away
from this game because we can pretty
confident it's going to be a draw but
look at the other boards bottom left
oh my God she's cooking them she's
cooking them oh my goodness oh man it's
getting bad it's getting bad it's
probably like a meeting three or
something down there and then Brooke
made on the back rank man just hit the
button bro just hit the button
I think uh that's very likely in that
button resignation soon and even take
the Rook of the corner some of the
bottom left position between soupy good
luck no I think we're gonna see a
resignation in that game in the bottom
right it's all Boyer how many pawns is
he up
oh boy or yeah
how many play crushing how many balls
you have just one wow
he's crushing it but no no definitely
saying that too and when the French we
have a good French and you're winning
like you're really winning in a French
especially in games usually a favor
French
and look at luck no she wins officially
uh in that game that's huge for the
blitz uh now it's at six and F6 now this
game is going to end in the draw you see
them just repeating moves I would
imagine and there it is a draw easy draw
in the books that means it is seven to
seven so
as long as a team can score one and a
half points they take this match and it
looks like they are getting it done
Boyer is in cruise control and let's go
to the game between mvl and uh
Sirens you hear are for the Brazil
capybara season
Sirens you hear are photocopy Bears
because they look like they about to go
down here and they were doing so well I
mean it was such evenly matched like I
knew it was gonna be one of the other
obviously of course somebody's gonna
come out of here but I knew it was gonna
be very close which we see today it's
literally tied mbos winning
this one and Boyer's winning as well
this position has even material which is
shocking because the eval bar is so high
but it's outside pass Pawn Black's
pieces can hardly move it's the worst
bishop ever that kind of French bishop
or in this case the caracon bishop that
didn't get anywhere and the dark squares
are too vulnerable the bishop 185 is a
monster and 13 seconds and counting down
for Mariko
yeah Knight F4 looks great just bring
another piece into the game but negative
four runs in the king age seven huh how
do I get to you bro he wants to play 95
but I can't maybe I bring the bishop to
A1 that's too ridiculous oh wait
wait
why did the email bar go down for a
second there what is happening here
oh man he brought the bishop to A1
that's too funny what just happened how
did it happen why was this such a bad
move
I wanted Knight D6 with a fork Against
The Rook in the pawn here
dang yeah we were so Tunnel Vision on
95.
and somehow mvl isn't completely winning
anymore it says
I think he'll still win but the eval bar
saying that black has chances
also made a mistake what is happening oh
my gosh we're gonna go gotta go to the
bird's eye view quickly because
Mahal Boyer has thrown away his
Advantage Julia Alberto my goodness
she's winning
oh no we got to get the facial reactions
we got to get the phone number for him
to call after this one this is
definitely crazy what happened because
look at this how are you gonna stop
these pawns over here you can just win
F7 and then the pawns go
how in the world did this happen
I'm seriously look at this position
black it was minus four and why has no
plan White's down in exchange by the way
and then right here
giving up this Pawn oh my gosh just drop
like everything in the position like all
the Pawns in exchange it was like too
many mistakes in a row and white should
be able to push this Pawn
just go g67 you win the game that's it
g67 yeah
wait let's check though Rook takes yep
just move your king 57. you still can't
do anything it hurts and Max
did win his game so that means that if
and when do the Alvarado wins this game
we are going to Ty break so Boyer he had
this one under control Julia decided to
fight back at a critical moment and now
once she converts this we will get tie
breaks between the Blitz and the
capybaras
we thought that this was over but the
capybara said try again right I don't
even know if capybara is bite or
anything but definitely they uh they did
what capybara's do which whatever that
is but you got it we got this is a good
attempt by the way King C3 Rook D3 check
and if you take this Pawn Rook takes G3
I see what's being aimed for it just
doesn't work because we'll just see this
I don't even need to analyze once you
promote the Rook will be able to slide
back to G1 and The Rook will be able to
stop this pawning from a distance it
looked like you couldn't stop the pawn
because the road couldn't get behind it
it'll just go back here and that is that
as long as there's no mouse slip
yeah
very unhappy wow
couldn't have been more winning
that's tough you always fight never give
up
dang overtime
OT cha he leans back and loses the game
pump hit this pump ah let's go look at
her
I wonder if she realizes that she just
saved her team she saved her team season
there and that was just you know pure
happiness pure joy and she earned it
there by just digging deep and fighting
but Boyer oh gosh James he is going to
be kicking himself because he had a
completely winning position like no hope
for her it would have seemed and then he
gave away like three different pawns and
she created past one of her own and won
the Alberta the hero for the capybars
right now all right smile in there and
having a good time and celebrating after
a win
much needed when to send us into a tie
break
Robert what does that tie break look
like you see it here overtime is
guaranteed the top four is 3-3 MBL gets
that last round win he overtakes morenco
a soupy and luck no tied uh in terms of
the scoreboard and then Alvarado takes
down Boyer so it's that half Point
difference on boards two and four we
have a tie so what are the tie break
rules for those of you who have not seen
it before we are going to have the same
pairings over the colors swap the time
control three minutes plus two second
increment the first two rounds and if we
have need additional rounds it will go
to Bullet wow
man I thought it was out the capybara
thought that they were out and we all
did it was oh this is over like two wins
and it didn't work that way and he split
it now we're in OT now more chess for us
guys and more craziness that's wild bro
I can't believe what we just saw I
really thought the blitz were going to
come back and win it that was not meant
to be so I'm gonna have to wrap my head
around this I'm gonna take a quick walk
around the room but when we come back it
is free chess it is overtime it is a tie
break between the Brazil Cafe bars and
the Bliss you will not want to miss that
action when return from this short break
do you guys play chess you want to talk
about it let's do oh yeah where do you
play chess at you know okay when I say
chess the first word that pops into your
mind
protect my queen Hikaru intelligent
strategy tactics Toby Maguire oh my God
you saw Pawn sacrifice if you're on
Tinder and you're scrolling and someone
has a chess player on their profile as
that swipe left or swipe right
Play Bright is good right yeah then yeah
instant swipe right okay super into that
right I'm into it you're ready to test
okay that's probably whatever the swipe
is I don't not interested you're not
interested in chess players I'm not into
chess players are on Tinder oh I get
that in fact that checks out if I ask
you to name one chess player in the
world can you name a chess player
yeah no not gonna on the Taylor Joy
Capital Blanca wow name another one oh
casparov casserole if you name five
other world champions in the next 15
seconds I'm Gonna Give You fifty dollars
spasky
holgar
Carlson and
on holy he did you get 50 bucks
dude oh my God we just lost 50 whose
idea was that
[Music]
is uh is anybody in snoops Camp playing
chess is that happening or not I haven't
seen it there's some smart people in the
camp so I wouldn't be surprised if
people
are versed at it really uh a lot of
college educated people you know I
unfortunately am not one of those
sophisticated people that play chess in
the camp what you talking about man I
don't play chess
I mean you know how to play
listen there's a difference with knowing
how to start a car up and then driving
Formula One racing
fancy
[Music]
thank you
if you thought you were going to go back
to work or do something else besides
watching chess you were wrong this is
overtime this is the protest League I'm
Grandmaster Robert Hess alongside me my
good friend feeding Master James Canyon
III James what did we just witness wow
well these guys just were swinging and
battling it out for the last few hours
there is right now and now this is an
elimination match and they don't want to
go home nobody wants to go home but
somebody's gonna have to go home as they
make a tiebreaker here they play the
tiebreaker is this eight to eight
it is eight to eight some players uh
were helping their teams towards that
tie namely the top boards both Shook and
our 10 minute with three out of four
it's been an an even match-up uh from
the start it felt very close and these
tie breaker rules what does that look
like it's no longer rapid chess we are
getting into the French team name we're
getting the blitz it is three minutes
plus two second increment if any team
scores two and a half points out of four
the match is done it concludes but if
it's two to two we get another round of
three minute Blitz then if that's tied
two to two we start getting bullet and
then we may not stop if they keep tying
so we're gonna have to figure it out it
may be an arm wrestle it may be a coin
flip but I believe that in this blitz
James uh that's where it's going to be
decided I cannot see this Going the
Distance with more ties in the time
control
of course if there is more ties then
we're gonna have to pull out chest
boxing that is a format and a variant
now so we're gonna have that ready uh
for you guys so stand by hopefully we
don't make it that far today but we will
see yeah because that's the next an
experience but these guys have to figure
it out here somebody's going home it's
Blitz now hopefully they've been playing
some Blitz hopefully you've been playing
you know and playing online and actually
practicing some fast chess here and I'm
playing because if not it's on show
right now and every Point matters versus
two and a half takes it and somebody is
in the center
yeah no this is one of those moments
where you need to practice all time
controls all different types of Chess uh
because you were just playing rapid you
need to adjust on the Fly and no longer
can grishook spend three minutes on a
turn you spend three minutes you lose on
time so for grishook and our tammyev uh
they're seasoned veterans but on
International women's day Julia Alvarado
kind of the hero for the copy bars their
season was about to be done with and she
stole Victory from the jaws of defeat
she took down Mahal Boyer as she allowed
her team to survive and now the question
is will she help them Thrive because
they need her once again that was great
that was an important Victory but now
they need a second one yeah absolutely
they need a second Victory here and a
lot of times too like things like the
momentum can shift for instance right
Blitz you know had a good momentum then
it shift to the copy Bears who held it
for a long time and then you know for
them to tie it up like this I mean who
is it gonna have the initiative here and
I think of these top boards here they're
just you know Blitz I guess Griffith and
artemia they used to this stuff Grisha
is no no joke though he did almost
qualifier but he did qualify for
something I don't remember it was Blitz
I did commentary for I just don't
remember what it was but he qualified
and he made it all the way through
artemia didn't play but he is he's very
very strong as we know especially in
Blitz I think you're referring to
speeches Championship qualifier as well
that's exactly what it was yeah and that
was a brutal field Dania was playing uh
many of the top players in the world
were competing but grishek made it
through and played in the main event but
right now he was able to strike with D5
when your pawns two squares away you
have to look at the square in between
and D5 has been played and these players
I mean do they realize that it's Blitz I
mean I feel like artemia playing
extremely slowly well grushook is the
one who is playing quite quickly
blessing out the moves here and you get
two second increments so this isn't the
regular Blitz you do get some time here
um as well I feel like he definitely is
moving slow you got 220 yo really like
the opening steel whoa all right now
look at this what is this
what is this nonsense wait did our time
you've just come up with this on the
spot because that is an insanely
impressive move he wants to take back on
D5 and after Knight takes he wants to
chop on D4
what just happened wow
I'm gonna do an instant replay everybody
because D4 was like the last move that's
not a simple capture D4 have fun with my
Pawn here what he's trying to do is
invite the Knight to D5 and now he's a
pawn to capture here and why that's
important before if you went for a line
like this and took on E5 the bishop
takes back the queen protects the knight
in the center so big differences by
small moves and D4 was important and now
the bishop captures the Knight here
which looks time Advantage is a thing of
the past James I like White's position
you're threatening to win a pawn here or
here what does grishek do right now he
closing his eyes I hope like I don't
know if that's like a pain face or more
of a thinking but I think it was a
little bit of both because definitely
didn't expect this but also at the same
time he needs to limit the damage and
figure this out in fact I might make a
move like Bishop C7 hey have the pawn
actually and then take take and play
Bishop D7 and say I got your light
squares are super weak even though you
got the pawn okay I got the bishop pair
which is equal to upon in many cases he
goes Queen D7 instead oh
yeah one stick with the queen get the
fish around those light scores that you
talked about and well uh our team of
thinks candy capture this Knight in C6
what should he do let's go to our bird's
eye view because all four games are in
full swing every single game important
uh none more important than the rest and
I'm looking across James in the top
right it looks like Sandra morenco I
don't believe that Eva bar slight Edge
for him but it's a closed position up
there in the top right in the bottom
left pawns are getting swapped the
position is opening up between Lucknow
and soupy and then the bottom right
Boyer against Julia Alvarado she was the
hero in the fourth round in Rapid chess
can she do it in Blitz Boyer has more
time to start with that guy is three
minutes and 15 seconds oh yeah he's he's
a little bit of anger and also Comfort
uh being comfortable uh hopefully he's
comfortable at least something he's used
to playing but 315 dang well he moving
instantly almost right literally moving
us they have so much time he even put
his glasses on wow he got serious you
know you put the glasses on Robert he's
like extreme extra on it the red extra
honey ELO wow all he's missing is a Coe
hat James he's got the glasses and he's
he needs the hat and chains but look at
that move B5 closing in your own Bishop
but the point was that B3 threatened to
win the bishop behind the Knight but
look at this here comes the queen that
apparently wasn't inaccuracy will never
gonna blend players they barely have
time to figure out their moves but B2 is
loose B4 is coming opening up a threat
against his Queen 22. I like Julia's
position me too see swigen and I mean
we're moving fast comes with problems
because you're not moving and being as
accurate you're not thinking you're not
sealing you're not calculating right
that's what that means so here it here
moving so fast you don't have as much
time to calculate and now he takes his
first think where time is getting more
level here where you do like Black's
position being active Rooks connected we
have a lot of Queen side play B4 being a
threat A2 your queen size weak I
definitely like black as well great job
and you were saying that you know he had
glass on he took them off right so he is
uh you're frustrated he's trying to work
through this and well let's lead him to
it because he still has over two minutes
he's been playing that quickly the other
game still in action here we look in the
top right Sandra mareko I still believe
it's an aesthetic Advantage more than a
concrete one but he's pushing those King
side pawns the board let's go over there
to Sandra morenco against the beast from
Lyon Maxine vasila Grove and look at
this James G5 has just been played by
Mariko he is not slowing down let me
tell you something G5 and we live every
time right that's a big boy move from a
big fella he's definitely swinging I
don't know what it is they got against
MBL how they just swinging on him like
this did you see like subie did on the
same way G4 G5 all in your face we don't
care about nothing French man right like
this crushing right like because this is
exactly it feels exactly the same it
looks like basically the super game the
King was on G2 and everything like
that's kind of crazy how similar this is
but this one's a little different at
night on E5 oh yeah I take on H6 can you
laugh three like this is crazy Knight F3
King F3 six stuff I like white all day
yeah hard to attack the white king with
his Queen back here on B8 and something
important that Maxim is doing while he's
being attacked on the king side he's
opening up the center trying to create
counter play he wants a rook on D5 bring
that Rook to F5 that will help in the
defensive task but white is objectively
better here you see Mariko bring his
Rook on over to the king side it's
already a threat on this pin Pawn if you
play G6 maybe there's H5 maybe there are
other moves as well but it's clear that
white is better and white by the way is
also up a pawn it may not look like it
because the pawns are split everywhere
but it's an extra Pawn
oh yeah and played H5 here yeah cool and
whoa King H7 he just chill man this feel
like this may in 11.
definitely definitely not right now we
do have to maneuver our pieces correctly
which he's doing yeah seems forever away
you can't even cross the F4 because the
rook's coming out five so so far uh
Maxine versus down to a minute we're
putting up great defense let's go back
out to our bird's eye view just because
the game between artemiev and grishook
it's down to the final seconds I mean
sugar has no time and the game is so
complicated
whoa yeah this is yeah and you know
every it's hard to catch every one of
them too because it's the it's so fast
seven seconds here though that great the
time for Grisha is not going to help him
obviously with this uh you know this
fast time control two second increment
every time what's actually going on in
position here Queen goes to B5 Rook C8
okay we have Knight C2 coming after we
move the queen from the queen four
seconds counting down he goes Rook C6 I
think you can if you take a before the
pawn has to take so he takes on C6 first
and now oh wow keeping the material on
the board
this actually is chaos I'm not even
gonna lie
yeah and by the way these are two of the
best bullet players on the planet he
took that opening up the a file that's
shocking to me
James well and loser goes home we know
that so you about to go home somebody's
going home this is all on the line with
seconds to spare chat seconds in every
game so it'll be definitely close to the
time time pressure here 94
C6 is hanging but so is A2 so that was a
pretty good decision but I agree one you
get one
uh-huh so King's coming out though watch
out these light squares it's all White's
control
seven seconds he goes up King C4 getting
maybe a little bit too active
good move yeah he's very active then I
could go to C5 in some cases and then
team King C5 you have a lot of palm
weaknesses okay that was a brilliant
move Knight D2 defense are we gonna see
a repetition James
back and forth
Gotta Move two seconds oh man
soupy wins
wow
super won the game this game is a draw
so soupy wins that's huge news for the
Capybaras uh we didn't get to tune in
the game but to see the final position
and oh my gosh the Queen's trapped on F5
oh my goodness super just trapped her
Queen the position as even material but
White's last move was Pawn to G4 like if
you look at the Evo bar black is better
activity but G4 trapped the queen of the
spot that's a win for super let's get on
out of here because that is in the books
that's official we still have two games
remaining in the top right it's even
between mareko and Maxine versus in the
bottom right that's hovering in White's
favor so um Boyer he's going to need to
win to give the blitz a chance to go to
a second batch of tiebreak games what do
you make of this position James under 20
seconds for black not too many pieces on
the board but white is up a piece for
just a pawn oh I'm up a piece I'm up a
piece and this is this is a clean one we
just gotta finish this out she's in time
pressure too as well how do we get a
piece over there we need a piece maybe
to like I can't move anything whoa this
is difficult
before maybe
how many times has this position been
reached probably just a couple seven
seconds for Boyer Rook B4 she goes Rook
D2 instead going after this D4 upon and
how does white make progress James it
feels like White's stuck in place that's
exactly right I think the only plan I
can get is Kick this Knight away King G2
H3 and G4 I just have to get this in if
I get G40 and I kick the Knight away
then I can get the ball rolling there it
is you found it and the two second
increment is huge he might want some
kind of Knight C4 not sure what it does
but the Knight can just hop around maybe
to F5 maybe to C4 and James if too many
pawns get traded there might not be
enough left to win the game even though
white is up a minor piece that is true
here Bishop
and oh my goodness let's go to the
bird's eye view again because it should
have been equality in the game between
mvl and Sandra morenco but Maxine is not
the former World Champion by accident he
is winning his game this one it's just
done at this point
oh just a winning end game 100 you can't
even stop the queen wow that was a sick
move B G2 and that's it that's a win for
mvl that leaves us with just one game
remaining and if
dude Alvarado can survive this then her
team still gets another tie break but it
looks like Boyer he's taking charge and
that means that the blitz may take this
match if you lose you go home Julia won
before
come on who's the Believers in the chat
who are the Believers in the chat right
now this could be the last moments of uh
the capybaris here
I think it's over G5 great move the
bishop leaves the connection the G7
Square where does it actually go it's
trapped if it goes back here you have
Rook to a check so
yeah the king's going up the board James
the blitz are going to survive
Blitz made it very far they have some
hiccups here
it's very close match but they won it
doesn't matter how you get it it matters
if you got it done and who's going home
and it won't be the Blitz
oh check and f8 equals Queen with double
check and mate on the spot so that is it
the blitz win let's see if Boyer even
knows it because he just finished his
game he couldn't watch his teammates oh
there it is
[Music]
yeah he's the hero you know he probably
felt like it was his fault he lost that
fourth round game but now he's all
smiles is mahal Boyer he earned it he
led his Squad to Victory they survive
and remain in the protest League 2023
season
the game that he won the only game that
he won was the game account the only one
that he won is the game that counted
okay the blitz are going through the
playoffs because of the one game that I
won right after it was five games I
didn't do as well as I wanted to but
guess we're going to the playoffs we
live to see another day the copy Bears
have to go home here heartbreaking as
they did so well there I mean our Timmy
have three and a half out of five two
three and then a one there from Julia
who was the star to tie it up in the
first place here but overall Blitz did a
fantastic job
yeah that was crazy Fitness I'm just
trying to wrap my head around what we
saw I mean the cabbie borrows in the
first round James that feels like
forever ago remember soupy crushed mvl
and they were leading it looked like
they were in charge and then the blitz
they found their Rhythm and then you
look at the top two and you say Okay
three and a half out of five mvl three
and a half of five nvl you hit a good
day but he lost the first game he looked
shaky he was one and a half out of three
but Sandro mareko uh became an opponent
that Envia wants to see time and time
again he beat him both times and he
helped his team win this match and of
course Boyer at the end there that was
huge or the blitz he struggling he lost
a heartbreaking game in Rapid but he
lived up to his team name so James now
the blitz won this one could you see
them winning next week as well and
making the playoffs you know what
because uh they're so close uh to the
playoffs now now you're like oh I can
really do this right when you feel that
close to something like you get more of
a boost more motivation you feel better
you're gonna you know feel good you play
good obviously you have to study and
train to play good but also just being
in the right field right field can
actually be really good so I think
they'll do well um going forward because
they are in the right field here but of
course it does take the right line up
still gotta have the right match up
right line up right mindset and go in
there hopefully to continue to win
and this lineup has worked well for the
blitz I want to give a shout out to
Kettering luck know as well because she
did win some important games after a
tough start oh out of two and one two in
a row so good job by Lucknow she had a
crushing victory over soupy in Rapid but
for the standings I mean this means that
the blitz they remain in the field but
earlier today we saw the Shanghai Tigers
I mean that was a crazy match that they
won against the Croatia bulldogs so
James of the teams that you see here
with two wins and which do you see as
the most likely team uh teams I should
say plural to make it through definitely
Canada chess for us here we got uh you
also have the the Indian team I mean you
drink you drink the water you become a
GM over there in India team MGD is
absolutely crazy so those two are
definitely I think big favorites and
then the toss-up is going to be between
the Gnomes the Wizards and the Bulldogs
yeah and we saw the Shanghai Tigers make
it through we'll see if the Croatia
Bulldogs can do that next week but we
also just saw the blitz stay alive that
was nerve-wracking stuff from the team
from France they go to two out of two
and well James the Capybaras what can
you say about that team in their season
because they have been officially
eliminated well they have a they have a
very bright future I think especially
coming back to the PCL next year they're
they'll have a very bright bright future
especially if they are able to pick up
artemium again if they would have picked
him up earlier I mean they this could be
all the way around this could be two in
one this could be maybe they'd be in the
playoffs we don't know but at the same
time them they picked them up kind of a
little late here they just weren't able
to but it is a very strong team just
like the the Bears and the cobras very
very strong teams just uh maybe bad
lineups at that time you know and other
things just wasn't as sharp wasn't able
to take it but that's okay you know we
still got some other teams on the other
hand that that will make it and trying
to punch their tickets to the playoff
and we should let everyone know not to
cry because it's over but to smile
because it happened just like Boyer who
was ecstatic about his win we do have
More protest League tomorrow the matches
for today uh they're a thing of the past
so we look forward to the future we
start with the candid chess Bros taking
on the levitov chess wizards of the team
the wizards they are super strong
they're led by the chess Queen Alexander
crestenyuk and of course the chess bras
led by Magnus Carlsen and we have an
elimination match will the unicorns or
the passers go home James I'm not sure
if you're familiar with those two teams
but what do you have to say about the
second half of the doubleheader well
first off uh we are facing elimination I
am captain of the pastors there and the
passers all I gotta say is you know when
you pass us the ball we gonna score so
that's exactly what we're about to do
here we're gonna score here shout out to
the unicorn and see our uh fan favorites
and you know they're cool and all but
you know we always like to say that
unicorns aren't even real you know what
I mean so it's just gonna be uh it's
gonna be a heavyweight matchup and we're
ready to swing on anybody and anything
that they bring at us we already know
the lineup so we're ready to go I'm
excited for it but it is going to be
tough it is an elimination match as well
so lots of fun there but stay tuned for
that hopefully hopefully Robert Hess
will be bringing some of that energy and
that some of that luck our way so we can
win that match oh you know I'll be
bringing the energy and I'm gonna make
some predictions normally ask you to do
it but I won't do that to you because
your team is playing I'm gonna actually
predict the levitov chess Wizards take
down the chess bras Magnus Carlson
Jordan Von Forrest they're playing for
the chess bras but the issue is the
Wizards their fourth board is Alexander
castenyuk reminder to everybody her feed
a rating back in November was 25 20. I
believe it's not 25.40. if that's your
fourth board in a league where your team
average has to beat 25 50 or below
that's too much and then I'm gonna pick
another team and this one is going to
make you happy I'm gonna go with the
Garden State passers I feel like savian
Bortnick Linderman on the top three and
Karissa Yip she's playing I know for uh
your squad she's logging into board four
and she outraged her opponent by about
200 rating points on the fourth board so
I think that having the higher rated
board four it helps we just saw the
blitz win this matchup thanks to Mahal
Boyer so James I'm gonna go with the
chess Wizards and the Canty passers for
tomorrow yes let's go I like that I like
that of course Hess has spoken chat Hess
has spoken that's exactly right I'm
actually gonna go with the chest brows
myself big fan of them obviously and of
course my passers you know pass us the
ball and of course unicorns are all cool
and cute but not real so we're gonna
beat them and do our thing right so
hopefully stay tuned for that chat it's
gonna be nice forever well they may not
be real but their team is for Real
you'll have a tough task ahead tomorrow
but that's all for today we just want to
thank everybody for tuning in for making
the processity what it is it's not
possible without your support it's also
not possible without the players so give
Your Love in the chat for the teams that
we just saw today you won't see some of
those teams uh in the future at least
not for this season so you know pour one
out for them give them your love and
I'll come back tomorrow for more in the
protesting goodbye everybody and see you
then
foreign
[Music]
thank you